in this complete game development course
you will learn how to build a variety of
games using lua and love2d first you
will learn the basics of the lua
programming language and then you will
learn how to use lua to create games
steve teaches this course he is an
experienced game developer and teacher
leave a comment with the type of game
you plan on making welcome to your lua
crash course
so this course will contain everything
about lua we'll learn lua and then later
on we'll learn a little bit of love 3d
and then we'll build a few games with
lua
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
what exactly is lua
lua is a high-level procedural
programming language designed in 1993
primarily to be embedded into other
applications
if most of this flew over your head it's
perfectly fine
most things you'll have to take in here
is that lua is a procedural programming
language meaning that things like object
orientation doesn't really exist in
there but you can simulate it
these days
it is mainly used in games so you'll
usually see it being used with love 2d
or roblox or it will be used with games
built in c or c plus plus as a little
bit of extra used on the side
now where exactly was lua used
well it was used in adobe photoshop
lightroom apache the http server
the awesome window manager
roblox
angry birds the sims 2 mafia 2 world of
warcraft and fable free
as you can see a lot of these are games
because lua is very
popular to be used with games because of
how easy it is to embed lua in your game
well what text editor should you use if
you want to code along
well it can be absolutely anything
from a notepad all the way down to
intellij idea
i will be using vs code during this
whole course
mainly because that is what i've grown
to love and learn
but if you have no experience in any of
these
i would recommend using notepad but if
you want something a bit more powerful
then definitely go sublime text
so just go to the lua website lua.org
then here you have a little download
option
click on that
now you want to just ignore all of this
because compiling on windows grows who
wants to do that and this is a linux
only thing if i'm correct so
we can actually just go to here if you
don't have the time or inclination to
compile lugo yourself like any normal
windows user
get a binary or try the live demo we
want to get the binary
is just basically the executable now
don't be fooled by all of this you don't
download it from here you go to this
download page right here then make it a
massive pain to actually get to what you
want it's very interesting
then here you have a bunch of options to
choose from
i would like to go with 5.3.6 because
5.4.2
has a lot of changes and stuff that just
sucks
so here
we have a bunch of things we can choose
from this is linux
this is windows 32-bit
windows 64-bit if you're on windows you
probably have 64-bit and take note this
will also work on windows 11. just
because i'm using windows 10 doesn't
mean it won't work on windows 11.
and then we have mac which
guys seem to not be able to download and
then we have more linux or that's a
source this is linux now we want the
64-bit zip file
so we click that it will start
downloading our files
you just say save file
and i believe it's done
we can now open up our file manager
and we can go to downloads
and you see we have a lua 5.3.6
we can right click and extract file if
you don't have this option i recommend
you go install winrar or some sort of
file extracting software i like using
winrar because it just works
i'm going to extract to lua 5.3.6
but if you just said extract here it
would have been perfectly fine
now in here we have a bunch of options
there are a bunch of options this is
just executables this is the most
important file here this allows us to
actually run or leave our code which
we'll do in a second now what we need to
do is we can go back here and we can
rename this
you can name it to anything you want but
i'll just call it lua because it's
simple you know that's liver
now i'm going to copy this so you can
right click and we can say copy
and i'm going to go to my
local c drive
now you can just paste it in here if you
want but i do prefer going to program
files
right there
and then just saying
paste
because it's a program so we want to
paste it here
there we go
now next thing we can do is we can open
up the command prompt so you can click
here search command prompt and it
actually
want to go to this page
anyways once you search command prompt
you should see
this
now first try type lua
don't get anything as perfectly fine try
to type blue five free
doesn't work
okay if you do get this then that means
it has not yet been added to path
one way to fix it is by rebooting
another way to fix this is by going to
settings which
can i can i search here
i can okay go into settings
and it's searching here
environment variables so here edit
the system environment variables
and in here you can just say
environment variables down here
then you don't have to worry about this
too much you can go down here to path
you can say edit and these are the
locations where all the environment
variables is
as you can see my program files x86 is
here but not my normal program files
or at least some of these 8x86s are here
so i'm going to do this i'm going to say
new
and i'm going to browse because the
thing is
we it's a very difficult way to get
there so i'm going to just browse to
where it is
and here program files we saved it in
there and there's lua now if we say okay
as you can see it added it here for us
so it added it to the program files
or the environment variables now if we
were to say okay i just need to put the
folder there because it's going to scan
the folder you don't have to worry about
the executables you say okay
you say okay
and you close that
then now also if you do want to you
could always rename this to lua and just
remove the five free i don't know if
that will still work but i'm pretty sure
it will you then have to exit out of the
command prompt and just open it up again
okay please open here and to look like a
hacker you can say color
o2
cool now that we look like a hacker we
can clear the terminal
or cls
and we can say lua five free
this will allow you to go lua if you see
this you did it correctly also if you
didn't download lua 5.3 you will have a
different number here depending on the
version you downloaded it
and that just executes the program now
we can say print
test to make sure this works if it works
then you're good to go
next up you probably want to actually
try and run a file in lua
or a lua file itself i'm going to create
a new folder
i'm going to call it lua for my lower
programs
here i'm going to say new
text document
and make sure you can see this dot txt
there we want to change that we're going
to say main.lua and remove.txt if it was
there
and just say yes and you should see this
you can then edit it with notepad if
they give you the option to do it so
let's open it with
and let's see here more apps notepad
there we go
and yeah we didn't need to always open
up with that
then here we can of course just say
print
i am cool
save this file by clicking file and save
or just control this
and you can close notepad
and now here you can just shift right
click
and you can say open powershell window
here there's multiple ways to do this
but this is usually the easiest
then you'll see this
you can then just say lua
fi free
and in the file so then right there
main.lua we can then say main.lua
there you go i am cool if however this
did not work
then you can just open up your
command prompt again
bring it over here whoa
and now we need to navigate to this
folder
one way you can do this you can just
right click here and copy address
now you can just say cd for change
directory
and
right click if you right click then it
will paste it here
press enter and now you're inside of
this folder now you can say lua five
free and main.lua
there you go i am cool
first you open up vs code this is a vs
code specific tutorials users vs code if
you don't have it installed you do need
to go and download it
okay
then once you have your visual studio
code open you want to go to file
and an open folder not open file but
open folder
once you say that you can go to your
folder where your lua program is in so
that main.lua file or whatever you call
that file
and here we go
i have a main.lua file which just says
print i am cool that's all it does it's
just this file right here
and i can show you that this file exists
by going to my document and to that
folder i just opened it there we go
main.lua
cool
now that you have this here you can just
go to terminal new terminal
and here we have a terminal if you have
lua already installed you can just say
lua five free
and then main.lua
i am cool as easy as that you have just
executed your lua code
i'm going to open up my file manager and
i'm going to go to documents i have a
special folder called trash where i put
all of the things that once i format my
pc i don't care about it you will
probably have a code folder similar to
what i have here where i put all of my
other code
but for me
i'm going to put it in
trash i'm going to create a new folder
and call it lua
in here i want to create a new file
called main
dot lua
if you're in windows make sure that this
actually ends in main.lua
and not main.lua.txt
windows will oftentimes append that
extension to the file name which you do
not want
once you have done this you can open up
your code editor in this folder
since i use vs code i'll quickly open it
up here
here we go now everything you see here
is what will appear here
so this main.lua
that is here
if this right here says main.lua.txt
then windows did you win and they try to
add a txt extension at the end you can
just go here and then rename it and
remove that.txt
i'm going to close this file manager
here because i don't need it open
anymore
all right
now first off i would like to resize
everything just so everyone can see
great
to run my lua code i will use this
terminal right here
but take note that this terminal is the
exact same terminal
as this terminal right here
the two are exactly the same
the only difference is this terminal is
inside of vs code
while this terminal is not inside of vs
code
that's the only difference they both run
the same thing
if you're on windows or mac you don't
have to open up a terminal on the side
you use a good terminal new terminal and
you'll have a terminal to use
all right now that we have that out of
the way i'm just going to get my setup
ready
and here we go and this is why i like
having this terminal here it just looks
so much neater and we have a lot more
space to work with
next up i'm going to close my file
manager because i don't need to see this
lua file because i'm already in it
so let's start with the basics
make sure you have low install by going
lua
version
and
actually if you get this then you know
lua is installed but if you go lua
v then you should also see this
if you just type normal lua then you'll
be able to do something like print
any type of text and you should see this
to exit you can press ctrl and d ctrl n
z or control and c
alright so i have lu installed as you
could see there
so let's get started first i would like
to tell you
about comments in lua
oftentimes if you're following along you
want to leave yourself a little note to
explain what is going on
and this can be a comment
a comment is not read by the computer so
when you run this lua code a comment
will be skipped
so we go dash dash and anything that
starts with two dashes
is considered a comment
so this is a comment
this is also a comment you're not
limited to the amount of comments you
want or have you can just do as many as
you want
but that is also a single line comment
it basically means that once i go to the
next line
i'm typing regular code you'll notice
that here we have green text and here
the text is not green that is because
this text right here is not a comment so
this is a single line comment every time
you want to add one you'll have to add
the two dashes to say it's the next line
you also have a multi-line comment if
you plan on having a comment that's a
few lines long
such as a description of something
then you can say dash dash
and in two
brackets like this
this right here is a multi-line comment
and then make sure there's no space
between your dashes and your brackets
here there we go now this can range
multiple lines so
multi
line
comment
it is amazing because now everything
that's between these
is part of the comment meaning if you
put any code in here it will not execute
same here if i put any code in here it
will not execute
this one is just one line whilst this
one can span multiple lines
all right
next up let me actually show you how to
print something to the screen
to print something to the screen it's
actually simple you just use the print
command and i will print something to
the screen
hello world
so print and then in brackets we have
quotation marks and then
a piece of text we want to print to the
screen the quotation marks and the
brackets are both important here so do
not leave either of those out
if you save your file and you run your
file with lua main.lua and take note i'm
in the same folder as this file
i am in this folder
if i say terminal new terminal you'll
notice it's in document trash lua
and that is where i currently am i know
there's a lua file in here because if i
say dir i can see a main.lua
all right
if you say lua and in your file name
you'll get hello world
because that's what we're printing out
here
you can have as many print statements as
you want yet again you're not limited to
anything so let's try hello jeff
and here we'll now have a hello jeff
and here's an example of where you could
add comments
here we could say
print
to the screen
and here we can say
we'll print hello world
you'll notice my single line comment
doesn't have to be on its own line
it can be after
a command for example print
so here we're saying print and then
we're putting a comment after it this
comment will not be ready if we were to
remove those the comment will be read
and we will get an error such as this
as you can see here
it doesn't know what that is so if we
make
this
then it can
continue
take note that comments will also stop
code from executing so if i were to make
this code a comment
it will not be read so when we run this
it's just going to say hello world and
no longer hello jeff
because hello jeff is now a comment
to split your print up into multiple
words
or to add multiple things to your print
statement
we can add a comma
i am cool
this comma here will add these two
together however take note that this
comma will add a tab between the two so
when we run this we'll get hello world
and in a massive tab
i am cool
if you want to add these two together
without getting a tab
then you could use
two dots and these two dots means
concatenate concatenate just means add
two pieces of text together
if we save this we get one long piece of
text
if we add a space here then there will
be a space between the two pieces of
text
what exactly is a data type
well a data type is very easy to
understand
for example when i say 5 what is 5
5 is a number
or an integer
this is a data type
five is the data type of number
and that is how data types works they're
very simple so we have nil
nil means nothing empty null undefined
so if something is nil it doesn't exist
or it's empty
we didn't have a number which would be
something like 1 2
negative
9.87
these are all numbers
we didn't have string and string is just
a fancy word for text so anything in
double quotes or single quotes
these are all text
we didn't have boolean
this is yes or no
also known as true or false so true or
false
if something is true you can think of it
as yes if something is false you can
think of it as no
so when someone says is it true that you
were five
well that would be yes because it is
true that you were five
or if when you make a statement and it
can be out of true or false
i have been to jail that is false i have
never been to jail so nope that is not
true
and then you have tables
tables is the equivalence of arrays in
lua or lists if you're coming from
python
tables are out of the scope of this
video so we'll be leaving them for a
different video on their own
okay so those are data types they're the
basic ones you'll mostly be working with
if you're using lua
now
let's get an example of a variable
a variable
is something that can contain something
else
it's giving a name to something so you
can reuse it later
for example
local name
this is how you create a variable by
specifying local
and in the variable name this can be
anything from x
to name to example
like that
one way i like to teach
is by using a little bit of math
for example
we have x
now of course if we were to print x here
and this will just display what is
inside of this variable
we'll get nil we can also set x equal to
nil
and this will be nil
you also set x
on a different line than when you
created it so here's x and we can do
that that also works we'll still get an
elbow
so let's say x is three
now if you remember the basics of
algebra you can usually say something
like x plus
eight is equal to
eleven now you remember maybe in high
school where you had to convert this to
figure out what x is but in this
scenario we are actually getting x we
know what x is we are providing
x
so we know we'll get 11 here
so we run this we get 11.
so x here is just a placeholder for this
number three here
so we do this we'll get the same output
but this time we're just storing it in x
because now we can reuse it wherever we
want
so we run it we'll get 11. if we change
x here to let's say 8
then x will be changed everywhere to
that eight
and we'll get to showing you more
examples in a second
but you do get two types of variables
you get the local scope variable
which means it is not allowed to be used
outside of this file
and when we get to it outside functions
that is a local variable it's not
allowed to be used outside of its scope
so in this scenario it's scoped to this
file if we create another file we cannot
use this variable
from that file
but then you get your global scope
variable which could be something like
global variable and this could be 10.
this global variable as you can see it
does not start with local
it is because it is globally allowed to
be used
so this global variable is allowed to be
used
outside of this file
so if we create another lua file and we
try to use this variable which we'll get
to in a future tutorial we are able to
use this variable
however it is definitely good practice
to go underscore g dot whenever you
create a global variable just this this
is just to specify
this is a global variable it's not
necessary to have this it is completely
optional but it is we're kind of
recommended to have an underscore g just
to give that extra specification we're
talking about a global scope variable
now a lot of this is flying over your
head don't get too concerned we'll be
practicing this a bit in future
tutorials as well
now let's look a little bit more at
variables
just variables in
general we can have a floating point
variable
and a floating point variable is
something like
3.1415 what not
we can have an integer type variable
both of these are considered numbers and
this would be a free we can have strings
or single or double quotes and in any
piece of text this can include these
dashes that are usually used for
comments
and we can also do boolean so true
or
false
booleans are a little bit out of the
scope of this video so we'll definitely
get back to them in the future
as for strings as i said you can either
do single quotes
or you can do double quotes but you can
also do two brackets and this will allow
for multi-line strings
take note these strings are taken up
very literal so if we were to print f
here
then it will get a very literal
representation of what we had
so if you don't want it to have a tab
and a new line you might want to just
do this
and now you'll notice if we were to run
this it will look completely different
and last thing i want to show you about
variables before we move on to an
example of them
is how you can
assign multiple variables at a time
for example let's go local one
two
three
all right so we have three variables
here separated by commas
now we can just go
one
two
three
so now one is assigned to this one here
two is assigned to this two here and
three is assigned to this false here
so they're following the same pattern
and is how we can assign multiple
variables at the same time
now let's use an example where we
actually use a variable
for example let's go here and say local
name
is equal to steve
then print
hello
my name is
and remember to concatenate we can use
two dots and then whatever we want to
add in this case we can say name
we can say name because name is a
placeholder for this steve here
so saying this is exactly the same as
saying this
let's go here i have a cool name
and in steve
and here we have a little bit of an
example if we were to run this we'll get
hello my name is steve
which is here specified as name
then here i have a cool name comma steve
i have a cool name comma
and then the name variable
if you wanted to you could do this well
this is perfectly fine as well it will
give you the same results
but think of it this way let's say this
was a piece of text that was probably
like a hundred
thousand lines of code right
and now you want to change the name from
steve to mike
now you have to go mic and you'll have
to change it on multiple places so first
mic and then you have to go mike and you
have to do this a hundred thousand
times immediately you can see where the
benefit of using a variable would be
better
because if we use a variable like this
then if we change it at one place
to mic
you can also work
then it will change everywhere
and take note once you have assigned a
variable you can reassign it so if i go
here and say name
is equal to steve
then now name will be equal to steve so
it's first mike or muke and then steve
so take note you can reassign a variable
if you ever wanted to
in this tutorial we'll be talking about
strings aka
text
anything in single or double quotes
so as we've learned from previous
tutorial
local
x is equal to str this is a string this
will be taken as a piece of text and we
can use it
the same with single quotes str this is
also a string
this will also be taken up as a string
and last but not least
these double brackets
these are kind of like literal strings
whatever you put in here will really be
displayed so if i put a tab here this
tab will be displayed if i were to print
this
and run it
as you can see it literally takes those
tabs and new lines
so those are the three ways you'd
usually be making a string
let's continue to actually using a
string
so let's say we have a piece of text
here
hello world
this is just a string normal string
doesn't do anything
to get the length of the string
we can put a hashtag here and the
hashtag in lua basically means return
the length of something
so we go here we'll get 11 because
there's 11 characters in here
we could also put the hashtag here this
will also get us the length of the
string
because remember x here is just a
placeholder for this string here
so this right here that x is the same as
me
doing this
and of course for concatenation you can
just say two dots and then what you want
to add
there's an exclamation mark and now
there will be an exclamation mark
let's say you maybe have a number so
local num is equal to 20
and you want to convert this number into
a string a piece of text because there
is a difference between numbers and
strings
well to do that it's fairly simple let's
say local str is equal to to string
and this will convert this num to a
string
now we print
num and then also string
you won't really see any difference both
of them will say 20.
but if we print out the type of these
and we can do that by saying
type
and then just like that so now type and
then the variable and that will give you
the type of this variable if we were to
run this we'll get number and then
string so you'll see both of them have
different types because one is now a
string while the other is a number
now with strings you have the cool thing
of escape characters
so here with print we have a bunch of
escape characters we can use for example
hello
backslash n backslash in means a new
line so go to the next line
world backslash t this means give it a
tab the same as saying a comma here and
then putting something new there but
this is just in one string
i am
and in backslash v take it back
b may not work on windows
i have heard some comments say that when
they use backslash b they get like a
symbol instead of a vertical tab
a vertical tab is just when you tab down
instead of tab lift and i'll show you
that in a second
but
backslash v gives you a vertical tab
almost
two backslashes will give you a
backslash as a backslash
escapes a character so you'll need two
backslashes to get one backslash
and then here
we're gonna say 20 so it's kind of 19
20.
and now let's say i wanted to put double
quotes in the string
there are two ways we can go about this
the first way is i can replace these
double quotes with single quotes
and now i can use double quotes
years
this works perfectly fine
but
sometimes that you cannot do that
sometimes that will not solve your
problem
in those cases if you try and do this
you'll actually get an error
so to keep these back or these double
quotes inside of your
string we can use a backslash and these
will escape the double quotes
and the same will be done for single
quotes so if you backslash a single
quote it will also be escaped
and these are just a few of them there
are a ton of these escape characters but
i'm going to go through every single one
of them if we were to print this we get
hello new line because backslashing
world then a tab not a space this is a
space
this is a tab
let me get a tab because backslash t
i am and in a vertical tab this might
not work on windows but it just
basically taps down instead of
left to right
almost 19 backslash 20 years
and in our quotes
the ignored forward slashes are not the
same as backslashes so backslashes only
two while a forward sash only needs one
next up let's say we have a
local string
and this string
just contains hello world with an
exclamation mark
now if you print it we'll get hello
world but there are a few things we can
do with this string which is pretty cool
first off we can say
print and then we can go string
and this will use the string functions
we have inside of lua there's a lot i'm
not going to cover all of them but i
will be covering the ones you might like
to use the most
dot lower and this will convert the
string to lower case
and just say str here
you can do the same and then for
upper
to upper case
and then you also have one for ling and
this will get the length of the string
it's the same as if you were to say
instead of string the ling you're to
just go
hashtag hashtag you can see as a
shortened version of this
let's return the length of the string
this will convert the string to
uppercase and this will convert the
string to lowercase
let's see what we get so we get our
normal hello world
then a hello world that's just lowercase
a hello world in all caps
and in the length of this string
so let's start with mathematical
operators there's a lot of them for
example five plus five we all know what
this does this will add two numbers
together
i'm going to add a few here because we
have quite a lot
we didn't have minus which will of
course
subtract and this could go into the
negative values
you're not limited to just positive
numbers
we have times which is represented by an
asterisk
and not an actual x
so an asterisk
we have divide which is a forward slash
not a backward slash but a forward slash
and let's say
we give
19 divided by five
you have to the power of so this would
be five to the power of two
and then we have modulo
and i'll explain this one after i've
explained the rest
so let's go 17.
all right if we run this
here we go
so we start with 10 because five plus
five it's ten
five minus fifteen will give you
negative ten
five times five is twenty five
19 divided by 5 that will give you 3.8
then 5 to the power of 2 will give you
and then 17 modulo 5 will give you 2.
now all of them are pretty simple to
understand we have all learned these in
school
except for modulo
you did learn this in school
just not quite the same
in a very basic sense modulo is what is
left over not literally but it is what
is left over
for example if i say 17 divided by five
well that will be
five then 10 then 15 right
so we were to say 17 minus
15 will get 2 because 2 is what's left
over if you were to divide these two
to give an example
let's just go here
and say
17 divided by five
one gives us 3.4 and the other gives us
two
because 17 divided by 5 will give us how
many times 17 can be divided by 5.
17 modulo 5 does the opposite
it gives us how much is left over once
the 2 has been divided
so not this 0.4 here
but the actual value
because a 5 10 15 and in 20 20 cannot go
into 17 so we'll have to stick with 15
because that's the lowest value we can
get if we were to do this
and of course 15 minus 17 or actually
other way around of course 17 minus 15
will give us 2
and this is the remainder that's what's
left over so it's almost the opposite of
division
you don't have to worry too much about
it we will be using this a little bit
more in the future
but you can get more used to it as time
goes on
one thing i remember
that people in my class always have
trouble with was the order of
execution in math
an order of execution can be a difficult
topic because you might not remember
what order what should be executed in
for example five plus
two
times ten
now i'm relatively okay with math so i
would immediately notice that this two
times ten that should be done first
and then after this has been done we'll
get this five plus two
but not everyone will notice this
immediately because that is just normal
not everyone is made the same
so some may see this and think oh it's
five plus two that's seven seven times
ten that will give you seventy but in
actuality it will give you twenty five
because two times ten that's twenty
and in twenty plus five is twenty five
now if you're one of those that can't
always remember in which order this
happens or if you just want to change
the order in which this happens
then i have a solution for you
brackets
is what we can use to specify when what
should be executed so here we could say
it's first 5 plus 2 then we times it by
because brackets will take priority over
everything else and it will be done
first
now we will get 70
because now it's first doing this
then it will add this
it's perfectly fine to do it over
something that is going to do first
i sometimes do this as well to make
myself remember this is what will happen
first
you can see now we'll get 25.
and you can of course add more things so
now if we go
times seven
they will first execute this
then it will execute this
and then it will execute this
but if you want to change that you could
do
this
now it will first do this right here
then it will do this right here
and then it will do this
so the order of execution
is up to you you can change it depending
on what you want
and now i can look at a few things
inside of the mav library
print math dot pi this will print out
the value of pi
very useful in some cases of 3.14159265
and so on
we have math.min which will give you the
minimum value of something so let's say
5 189
the minimum value here would be 5 that's
the lowest value of all of the values
passed in if we run that we'll get 5. if
we change this to negative
10 for example then now we'll get
negative 10 because that's the lowest
value
you can also do
max
max will do the opposite and return the
largest value so now we'll get 100.
then you have a rounding which can be
very useful
so i have math dot
seal
and this will round up so 20.9
and we actually give a few here
20.1
so these two both will go up they will
round upwards
to run this we'll get to 21. they will
not round down
seal is in a sense the ceiling the
ceiling is always above you
so if you look up
then that's where around it will round
towards the ceiling upwards
then you have the floor
the floor will do the opposite because
the floor is below you it's down so it
will round down
that will give us 20. so this is a way
to force rounding to a specific point
where it's either down or up
and last but not least let's talk about
random numbers
print
math dot
random simple as that you'll get a
random number
run it
run it run it
that's cool
you can do multiple
so that's pretty
neat but sometimes you want your
randomness to be more random
to do that you can pass in a seed
so math dot
math dot random seed
and we can pass in os.time and this will
ensure that all random values we get
here is always
random they will never be repeated
continuously
so now if we run this we'll get more
random values
you did get a few that repeat here but
that's just sometimes if you roll to row
random you'll get the same thing
and there's only updates once every
second
you can specify up until where it should
go so if we say 10 here
then it will random to 10 so 2
7 7
a few sevens there
so we'll continuously round the random
towards one and ten so between those two
you specify another value here for
example 50. now it will be between 10
and 50.
so will not go underneath 10
and it will not go higher than 50.
so your program can make decisions
that it is absolutely epic
your you can make your program make
these decisions by using an if statement
like asking a question
if
something is true
then do something else
so in this case if true take no that's a
boolean
then
and here we can just print
this was true
so one of the most basic data types is
used of one of the most complex
type of statements that is pretty epic
we run this this was true
now the cool thing here is this code
will only run while this here is true
if i make this false
then this code will no longer be ran
so
it skips it
this makes everything way more powerful
for example let's say
local x is equal to 2
and if x and then this is a cool symbol
is more than
and let's say five
then
print
x is more than five
run it
and oh
x is not more than five so this will not
run
but if we were to say x is 9
because x is more than 5
we'll get something out of it
we also have the opposite symbol so less
than
so we have more than and less than where
you can figure out more than we'll try
and get the one that's the biggest so if
this one is bigger than this one
because it will try to eat the largest
one so this is a mouth and it's trying
to eat the largest one
if this is bigger than this then it will
be true
this is smaller than
because now we'll try to eat this one
and hope that this one is bigger
so this will see if x is less than five
run it it skips the code but if we were
to make x two again
then we'll get
x is more that's actually less less than
five but you still get the point
there's a lot more comparison operators
which i'll get a little bit more into
but not every one of them
so we have the
and
or
not
i'll get into a lot of these
more than less than
more or equal
less or equal
not equal
yeah
take note in other languages you'd
usually have a not equal like this in
lua it's not with an exclamation mark
and you have two equal symbols to say
equal
so these are all you can use in here
and they're very powerful to use
for example
if x is less than five
and x is more or equal to two so we're
checking if x is more or the number two
so two three and up
and this is if x is less than five this
does not mean including five if x is
five this will be false because this
only checks if x is less than five
if you say less or equal to
then if x is 5 this will be true
so take note
then here we can say
x is
between
and 2
both included
so this will come see if x is less or
equal to four
or less than five
this will check if x is more or equal to
two or in other words more than one
it doesn't matter which one you use and
more than more than equal or less than
less than equal
it more depends on what you prefer i
prefer just doing more than or less than
but occasionally when i'm a bit more
tired i would usually go for more equal
and less than or equal
and if we run this
it works
if i make x 5
then it doesn't work
but if i say less or equal to 5 which
will now include a 5
then it will run it
this and here just says both of these
should be true so if this is true and
this is false it will not execute
so if i were to say true
and
false
then it won't execute
but if i say true and true
it will execute
or will do the opposite or
we'll see if one of these are true if
one of them are true it will run so it
will run
it won't run or it will run my bad and
if both of them are false
it won't run
there we go
and in a not we'll just basically invert
something so something that is not false
is true so it's kind of like speaking if
something is not false it is true if
it's not true it is false
so not false or false and i will give
this will make this one true
and here again brackets becomes a
important part here
for example
if we were to do this
then it will say if not and then
whatever comes from this
false or false this will be false so if
not false if true then
so take the brackets do play a role here
if i want to make this one true
then it won't work
if i were to remove these brackets
then it
won't work
either because true is now false
in order to make this true
it will work
but if i wrap these in brackets
it will not work because true and true
or true or true will return true and
this will result in it true here so if
not true
brackets can make everything a bit more
complex but also make what you can do a
lot cooler
so let me show you an example of where
an if statement could be useful let's
say local age is equal to 15.
so this person is 15.
if age
is more or equal to 18.
then let's say they want to go into a
bar they say print
you
may enter
they may enter the bar after 18 years or
older
and here
if this works
it will run
they're not 18 or older so if we say 20
then you may enter
now what if we want to give them
something else for example if they're
let's say 17 we want to to tell them to
scram they're not welcome here
so print
you are not welcome
be gone
but you might already notice what will
happen here
if i run it
we'll get both
we could go if
and then age is less than 18
and then throw this in there
this is perfectly fine so now we have
two if statements
and it will work if we go here and say
then you are not welcome be gone
but there's a cleaner way to do this
we can go
else
else is when this here does not execute
so when this is false
now we can just move this up there
and there we go
we run it
you're not welcome be gone if we change
this to 18
then we'll run the top one
let's say
it's this bar is near a children's
tourist attraction
so kids that are under the age of 12
might want to go to that attraction
so we could go here and say
else if
h
is less
than 13 so everyone that is not a
teenager yet
print
the water slides
are down the road
cool
so now we're checking if the user's age
that's trying to enter is more equal to
18 they're allowed to enter the bar
if their age is under 13 we tell them
that the water slides are down the road
otherwise
they are not welcome and they should be
gone because then we're near their teens
and they're trying to sneak in to get a
quick drink
run this you may not enter or you may
enter
if we change this to 17 then they're not
welcome
if we change this to 10
or 10
then
the water slides are down the road
we can of course do more for example
local birth day
is equal to false
now let's say it's their birthday bingo
if birthday
then
print
you get a free
drink on us
so now
if it's their birthday they'll get a
free drink so you can use an if
statement within another if statement
if we run this
let's just maybe make this 18
we'll get you may enter
if you make their birthday true
then you get a free drink on us
and there's a ton of things you can do
more with if statements but most of
these you can just get by trial and
error and by practicing what we've just
learned
and last but not least we can also do
something like this
local
name and let's say
if
local age here is
more than 18
so if age is more than 18
and
mike
or
jeff
so if the age is more than 18 then their
name will be mike
otherwise jeff and we can imprint
name
this is a cool one-liner where
everything can be done in one line
so now we get mike because their age is
more than 18.
if we change this to
then we'll get jeff so in this one line
you can set a variable using an if
statement
you can of course also set a variable in
a normal if statement
so true and then name is equal to
luke
this right here is also valid to print
name
so this will also work however this is
in one line so it might be more
comfortable but if you prefer writing it
out like this then that's perfectly fine
as well
however take note if you were to say
local name here it will re-create this
name variable and it will be scoped
between this
so it will be scoped here
meaning we can't use this name here so
if we were to print out name here
we'll get jeff
if we remove this local
they will add trend access this name
here
and we get look
so take note when you declare a variable
you're using local so local
and this will declare
a new variable
and it will locally scope it so it's
only allowed in its current scope
loops is a way to repeat code so it
continuously happens so continuously
runs until you tell it to stop
in lua there are three common loops we
can use
the most common would probably be the
for loop
and this is basically for a number until
a number
run the code so for
i
and this is just declaring a variable in
this scope
if for i
becomes one so we're starting at one
up until 10 so we're going up until the
number 10
and then
we can just say
then
or not then but do
and here we can say print
i
this will count from 1 to 10
and print it out
so we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
from 1 to 10 it will just loop and loop
and loop and change this i variable here
you can see how many steps it should
take for example one is by default so it
takes one step one two three up until
ten
you can say two and now we'll take two
steps
there we go
you can even make it go into the
negative value so negative two but this
here would cause an infinite loop
so we'll have to go 10
to one so it's going to flip the two so
it's i is going to start at 10
until it reaches one or less and then it
will stop
as you can see it goes downwards because
we said -2
cool
so that's a basic for loop you also have
a while loop
so while something is true we want to do
something else
this here is called an infinite loop
since true here never becomes false so
if i say print
mic
it will forever print out the word mic
until i quit the program with ctrl c
so this will infinitely loop until
either the program crashes or your pc
does
you can use break to break out of a loop
so loop it only goes once
here we could do something like
local count
is equal to zero
and then
if the count
count is more than ten
then we can break
and of course here at the top we can say
count is equal to itself
count
plus one
cool
so now we will break out of the loop
without having to make this here false
so now we can say
that and i will print out mike 10 times
cool
you could also
do this
put that there
while count and instead of more than 10
we can say listen to it so wall count is
less than the number 10
run this loop
now if we run it
until count
is at least
10 it will
run this code
all right and then last but not least is
the repeat loop
so one thing i want to show you is let's
say
count is equal to 10.
if we do this
the while loop will never run because
this here
is never true
the repeat loops
runs at least once it's a while loop but
it runs
at least once
so repeat
until
and we can just take this right here
put it here
and then take this and put it here
it's the same as a while loop but it
will run at least once
in other languages this would be called
a do while
and my bad it goes up until so we should
say
up until count is more than 10 or in
this case let's say
5 just to show you so
until this is true so it will repeat
this until this is true so unlike with a
while loop it will not be while true
this will be while false
if we run it we'll get mic at least once
it will run at least once before it
quits
user input is relatively easy
let's say we go here and say print
what is your
name
and then the user
can input something so we can say local
a and s for answer but you can call this
variable whatever you want
and we can say io.read
and this will get input from the user
and then store it inside of this
variable
and here we can print
ans
we maybe go
name
colon
and there we go
if we were to run this lua file
what is your name i will say mike and
there we go name mic
another cool thing you might be
interested in knowing is how to get
input on the same line as your output
because sometimes you don't want an
output and then an input on the next
line
it just kind of looks ugly and sometimes
is confusing
to get input on the same line instead of
print you can use i o dot write
this is the same as print but it does
not have a new line
at the end
so here we can say
enter
your name
and it will enter
and it will ask for the input on the
same line
as this output
now here we can say nick
and the name is nick
and of course then you can do things
such as if
answer is equal to
nick and they can give special outputs
depending on what the user inputs
but i think we all already know that
so if you're coming from another
programming language tables are usually
considered
lists
arrays
sits
dictionaries
objects records
cues a bunch of these things can all fit
into the idea of a table
a table can be all of these
if you have no idea what i just said
then you don't have to worry about that
so let's create our first table
i'm going to say local
tbl and if at any point say list or a
rate just know i'm referring to a table
and this table
will be
used with these right here so these
brackets
anything that goes in here
is part of the
table
this can contain any types and any
amount of items so
this
and we can put a 2
and a 9.9 and a true
all of these they are allowed
booleans
numbers
strings
even other tables so we can go here and
say
okay
cool
this is all allowed
if we were to try and print out table
then take note that you might not get
what you expect
usually when you print out something
like this you expect to receive that
back
but in this case we will receive a
memory address
but if you want to get the items inside
of a table
you could use a for loop so for
i is oh that's all caps for
i is equal to one
to hashtag
tbl
do
and hashtag is just a short version of
number of items in this table
like if you have a string or a piece of
text and you do this hashtag with it as
you might remember
we receive the length of that string the
same concept
exists for tables
and in here we can say table and then
pass in i
if we do this we'll get each item inside
of the table this 2
9.9 true
and then another table because this is a
table here so we'll have to forfeit that
as well
if we want to see the items in it
now you might be wondering how does this
work how can we do that
well if we go look here and we say print
tbl at index 1 and this is called an
index
and we run it we'll get this
this right here is the first index
so if we were to go like this
we'll get index 1 which is this
index 2
index 3
index 4
index 5 and the more you add of course
the more indexes there will be
so it starts from 1 and currently it has
up until 5. if we go 5
then we'll get a table
if we say 5
then we'll get okay because here we're
saying
okay go to this fifth index here
and then in this fifth index return the
item at index one of it so this would be
one
and this here would be index 2 of this
table
we'll cover this a little bit more in a
second but this is just as an example
if i were to say
4 will get true
if i were to give a value that doesn't
exist like 9 we'll get nil
nil just means empty doesn't exist
nothing
now usually you'd actually create a
table with the same data types it's not
too often that you'll see tables using
different data types
unless you use it in a sense of an
object which we'll get to a little bit
later but when you just use it as an
array so a way to store multiple values
inside of one variable
then you'll usually just use the same
data type so just numbers or just text
for example let's say we have local
x
well let's actually start at a a
b c
d
e and you can imagine this going up
until z
and we could say we're storing one two
three four five now you might already be
seeing how this is not really very
practical
because it's fine to have a bunch of
variables lying around that whole
storing their own values but all of
these values are related in some way
but they're stored in their own
variables which there's nothing wrong
with this method it's just there's a
more comfortable way to do this where we
could go local
alpha
nums
and as we'll get all the alphabetical
numbers which we would have usually done
by doing a and then a is equal to one b
b is equal to two c and what not but
here we can create a table
with one two three four five
this is the same but instead of having
to use a specific variable so print
a
we've already grouped them together and
we can just say
print
alpha numbers at index one
this will give us the same value because
a and one is the same thing
if you wanted you could also put
variables in here you're not limited
to just values because variables on the
end of the day are just values so this
will still work perfectly fine
if i say index 2 or b lies then then we
get 2.
if i were to remove this then this will
no longer work
so we'll get nil because b has never
been defined
now let's go here and say we have one
three five
seven 9
and we can just call this
local nums
then let's say we want to add another
value into this
table here let me just also for
through each item so one to the amount
of nums
and here we can print
nums at index
i
if we run this we'll get one three five
seven nine
now let's say i want to add one thing in
here before we run that we can say table
dot insert
and this will insert an item
into an
table
so first we specify the table in this
case nums
then you can either
specify what you want to put in here or
where you want to put it in
if you don't specify where it's just
going to put it at the end so if i say
19 here
and i
stop here it will insert 19 at the end
so here if we run it we get 19.
but if i instead in the middle put
two then we'll insert 19 at position 2
here so if i run this we'll get 1 19
free
so this here allows you to get a
position you want to put it in without
it it will just append it to the end of
this table
you can of course also remove
and here you pass in the position not
the value but the position so if i say
one
one will no longer exist
if i say
four
four will no longer exist
because four was seven
there's also a nice special way you can
loop through
these tables which is underneath this
normal for loop
instead of using hashtag nums
you can use pairs
so you're good
pairs
and you pass in numbs noms
now you can get
ka and b
so for k and in v
in pairs num if we were to print out k
we'll get these values
so 1 to 5. this would be the index so in
this case we could say index
and v would be value
so index we can actually just do index
and in value and it will
do work the same
so index one has one index two has three
index three has five
so this is a nice way you can four
through
a table in case you don't want to for
through the numbers maybe you want the
index
as well as the value well you can get
both but then pairs it's split
it's up to you which you prefer doing
now let's talk about multi-dimensional
tables
also known as multi-dimensional arrays
this is a table inside of another table
for example
here we can create another table
one
eight
three
okay let's create a few more
this can have four this can have seven
this can have five
this can have two
and then last we can have six and
nine
now if we were to print out
nums
we'll get our table
location in the ram
if we were to print out number index 1
we'll get the location of the table in
that table
if we specify another value in here
then we'll get the first index of the
first item here
if we say 2 we'll get 8.
if we change this here to 2
then we'll get 2 because
this is index 1
of the first table
this is index two of the first table and
this is index three so this will be the
first table
now inside of it you have index one of
the first table in the first table or
the first item in the first table
and then index two and index three and
then index three
two
one
and then one
two
three
if you were to pass in
something like
hashtag nums
you'll get the amount of tables in this
first table so if i were to copy this a
few times
we'll get five
but if you specify an index here for
example one you'll get the length of the
items here
free
so this is free
this is five
we can add more here so
now it will have a different length
if you want to display all of the values
inside of this
then you can also use a for loop
so here you can go
i becomes one to the num or to the
amount of tables and nums
and then for
this time j
because we can't really declare i that
won't be a good idea
for j becomes 1 to the amount of items
inside of i because i is a table so
we'll get the amount of items in i
so this would be i that each item inside
of i would be
or each value here would be j so this is
i
this is j
so here we could print
nums
so nums and then at index i
and index i will give us the table so we
specify the next index which would be
j
now
and in my band this here is a number
it's not a table we have to say nums at
index i
my bad because i is a number
just like j is a number it's not the
actual value
we run this as you can see we get 183
which is the first items
and then we get
four to six which is the second
and then five seven
seven five nine which is the last
so if you're having a bit of trouble
with this just note nums at index and in
the first index
which we can call x
would be the first item
or the second out of whatever x is here
if you add another one here it will try
and access the item inside of this item
so x which is this and we'll try to
access y inside of it so let's say eight
if you have a table inside a table
inside a table you could also add your z
so if i were to have a table here as
well
and we can go 2 4 5
and we're gonna have a few more
then i could do this where i have three
attached to each other to access each
item in a table
but take note tables can become
incredibly complex incredibly fast so i
always recommend
to
when you use a table not
add too many items into the table
as in don't add three or four tables
inside of one table here
so this right here is already very
complex if i were to go here and i were
to add another table here
so now i were to add another table of
more values
then it will be more complex because now
it's not no longer x y and z it has
started going to complexity where x
should now be shifted to something else
i'm just going to move this here to the
front
and we can just put an a here for now
so i would say always follow the x y z
rule
this is the complexity rule where you
don't have more than three tables inside
of one another
if it becomes more than free it becomes
very difficult to not only manage but to
work with
so i'd always say try and stick with
free or less tables
so here there are three tables
if you were to remove this like that
then there are three tables so this
table here this table here and this
table here
so unless you have specifically named
items like an object which we'll be
getting to
then never go past the xyz complexity in
a table
usually just try and keep it as simple
as possible
then you also have one two three if
we're to go like that
now let's say we want to convert this
into a piece of text
well we can go print
table dot concat
and this will
basically join a table of all of its
elements depending on the separator you
give it
for example if we pass in
nums to
or nums and we pass in a space
then it will print it out
with just spaces between each item
this here is now a string
take note this is a piece of text
and you can replace this with anything
so it can be a semicolon another number
so dash dash dash will work
and so on
and then finally for named items inside
of tables and we'll get more deeper into
this but for named items you can go
local tbl
and here we can do something like
name is equal to mic
and then age is equal to 12.
now if we go tbl as index one and we
print that
then we get nil
but if we go tbl
and then
name
we get mike so this is a named table
some people also see it as a dictionary
or an object
and yeah that those are the basics of
tables
now a function is a snippet of code that
you can execute as if it was a variable
for example let's go here and say
local function
say hello
and this will just print
hello
now we can call this by going say hello
and then adding two brackets at the end
and this will call this function here
we will print hello so if we run this
we get hello
and of course we can put as many things
in here as we want
as you can see
if we were to go
print one
and then two as well and we were to do
this so print
it two times by calling hello
then we'll get hello one two hello one
two
so every time you call this function
here it will execute the code inside of
it
and you can call it as many times as you
want
this is a great way to stop yourself
from having to copy paste copy paste
copy paste
this is a very common practice where
programmers will try and reduce the
amount of times they have to copy paste
a line of code or even a block of code
variable variables can save you a line
of code
a function can save you a block of code
now let's say we wanted to make this
hello function a bit more complex
so instead of just saying hello we want
to pass in a name for example hello jack
well this here isn't very useful because
it will always print out the same name
so instead what we can do is we can pass
in an argument
and we can call it name
so this is like a variable that gets
passed into this function
now instead of saying jack we can say
dot dot name
dot
dot there we go
now if we go here and we say
look
by passing it in here between these
brackets and this would be name
we'll get hello luke
we change this to jack
we'll get hello jack
sometimes you want to give it a default
value
so if you don't pass any name you want
to name to be a default value well to do
that we can say local name is equal to
name or
jack
so what's happening here is we're
declaring a new name variable
and then we're basically overwriting
what this is going to be on the end of
the day so we're saying this name
is equal to itself
or if there's nothing in here
if this is a false value such as nil
then make it jack
so it will default to jack
so if we have three here the first has
nothing inside of it
the second has mike and the third has
sally
then if we run this we get hello jack
hello mike hello sally
without that there if we did this
we'd get an error because you cannot
concatenate a nil value
because this name here would be nil if
we didn't pass in anything in here
let's get a bit more complex and do sum
and this will get the sum of two things
let's say we get
num1
and num2
then here we can just
return the value
but how does one return a value here
because
we could print out what it is so print
num1 and num or num1 plus num2
and we could call this sum
10 and just to show you could also go
local x is equal to 20 you could also
pass a variable in here so x
that will be 10 plus 20. if we run this
we get 30.
but what if we want to work
with the value that this returns that
this would give us
so we wanted to store local
answer is equal to sum and then print
the answer is
and then
ons
what if we wanted to do something like
this
well we'll get a problem here because
we cannot concatenate a nil value this
here is nil
because sum just prints out this value
here
to return a value we can use return
and this will return this value
you could either do it like this
or you could go
local
result
is equal to that and then return result
now anything here with return will be
returned from this function
and nothing after this return will be
executed which we'll explore in a second
if we run this now we get the answer is
30 because this here now returns this
result
which can be either in its own variable
or like that
but take note we can go here and say
print
thunk start
and in
funk
end
you'll notice we get some red squiggly
lines
and the file expected after
return that is because after return
we are not allowed to put anything there
anymore
because after return nothing will
execute
so if we run this
it will just press an error because
nothing should be after return once you
return
the function stops executing
but this doesn't limit you as much as
you think it would
if we say
let's go here and say local val
num1 plus num2
if val
is more than 10
then
return val
if
val
is less than 100
then
return
negative vowel
otherwise we could just return
val
times 2.
so this is an example where just because
we have a return doesn't mean it will
stop everything else from executing
because this return will only run
if the value is more than 10.
and this code here will never really
work as expected so let's make that
equal to 10
there we go
so this will only execute if the value
is equal to 10. this will only execute
if the value is less than 100
but not equal to 10 because this will
stop execution first
so if we say
1 plus 2
then that will give us negative 3
because it is less than 100 so it will
give us this
if we say
8 plus 2
it will give us 10
because the value is 10.
if we were to say here
101 so 101 plus 2
that will give us 206 because it's the
value times two
let's first try to
create a file
that is pretty simple so let me just
also open up my
file viewer here so we can see if any
files appear
io dot output
and here we can pass in a file we want
to create
so
my file
dot txt
this will create a file
my file.txt
if i open the containing folder you'll
see there's my file.txt now if i were to
delete it from here
you'll notice it also deletes it from
here this here is the same as this here
anyhow so we create this file
then that will happen
but take note
it will empty the file if it already
exists so if i go and put some text here
let's actually have it here on the side
of the screen
and i decide i want to execute this
as you can see it empties the file
so you should take note here it will
create the file but if it already exists
it will empty the file
now this output can be used also with
writing to a file so io dot write
and here you can put some text you want
in the file
hello world
and we just have to io.close whenever we
use any of these
because you don't want the file to be
open
and then later on try to work with it
again or if other program tries to work
with it but yours already has it open it
will cause issues
so you always close the file after
working with it
now if we were to run this we can
actually show this here the side again
we run it we get hello world
if we run it again we'll get the same
output because this anyways rewrites
this file it will empty it if there's
nothing inside of it or if even if there
is something inside of it
that's the first way you can write to a
file
now the first way to read from a file we
go io dot
input this time so instead of output we
are using input and then the file so
myfile.txt
then we can of course io.close
and here we can say local
file
data
is equal to io.read
and then we can just say
asterix all
this will read everything inside of this
file
and you can of course print file data
we run it we get hello world
we can add some more like x2 x3
i am cool
if we save that and we run it here we'll
get header world x2 x3 i am cool
so you first take the file we want to
read and say it's an input file because
you want to take input from that file
then we read it with the asterix all
which means read everything inside of
this file
and we can print the data that we read
and then we can close the file or we
could close the file and then print the
data whichever you prefer
so that's the first way to read and
write
a file
now the second method is what you'll
most likely see being used
so let's first try right to a file that
will be local and we can say what
variable we want to save this file in so
file
io.open
the file name so myfile.txt
and then what you want to do
so here we could specify
all of these so read write append read
and write
write and read i think
append and everything else read bite
right byte append byte
and so on and so forth but we're mainly
going to be focusing on these here
so first we'll have a write
now w just means right so we'll write
data to a file so here we can then say
if file is not equal
to nil so if the file we're trying to
open exists
then
so if the file we're trying to open
can be opened
then we want to go
file
right and we can just say
hello there and i will write to the file
and then of course file
close
else if we could not open this file we
could just print
could not open the
file now if we were to run this we'll
get hello there
if we were to delete this file and then
run it
it will generate the file and enter
hello there
so this method is usually the preferred
method above i o dot output
as well as i o dot input because we'll
learn how to read right now
now there are multiple ways you can read
from a file
one way you can do it is going file
and then read
and here we can just specify
astrix all
and this will read everything
so if we go here and say x2 x3
goodbye
and we read it
of course we should maybe print out what
we get so print
then we get hello there x2
x3 goodbye
you also have
asterisks line which will only read one
line so we go here
hello there if we then
do it a few times
each time we do this it will read a new
line so hello there x2 x3
so if you want to read line by line this
is a good way to go about it by using
this asterisk line otherwise you can
just go astrix all and that will read
everything
and then last but not least let's take a
look on how to append it to a file
now when you write to a file you will
overwrite everything that's already
inside of the file so if i were to go
here
w and then say right
and change this to goodbye
then it will overwrite everything and
also doesn't help if you print it
but it will overwrite everything and add
our goodbye
but what if we wanted to add something
to the end of this file
then we could use a which means append
so then we can say appended
text
if you run this we'll get appended text
if you wanted to go to the next line you
can use a backslash n here which means
newline
appended text 2.
now let's append the text to on the
second line
so that's how to append
now the term module in lua
refers to a lua file
that returns a single table when it is
called so it returns a table or an array
or an object as semi to understand it
so it's basically any file that's not
this main file that returns something on
the end of the day
and then you also have a package a
package is a collection of modules
so if i say i'm going to go and install
a lua package
that means i'm going to install a few
modules that will allow me to make my
coding in lua easier for example
the
luna cjson package because that's a
package of modules
i am going to use in my program to read
json
all right so let's get an example in
here i'm going to
create a new lua file call it
custom.lua you can call it whatever you
want
then here
i'm going to go and say
mod
is equal to a table
so i'm saying
this is a table here
we can then go here and say
function
mod dot sum and here we could say x y
and in return
x plus y
so we're putting the sum as part of this
mod here
you could also go sum
is equal to function
and then say x plus y this is just as
valid if you just say return
because these two mean the same thing
if we were to put in x and y here
so this will be the same thing
and of course we can have our mod here
with let's maybe say say hello
and in here
you can maybe get a name
and then we could say
print
hello
name now these are just very basic
examples you can put any function you
want here
i'm just making very basic functions
here as an example to show you
then we return
mod
because this mod will now be used
outside of this file
so here in main.lua
we can now use this module
local mod
is equal to require
and then we pass in the name here so
custom dot
cass tem dot
lua or just custom because it will
automatically add the dot luo in
searching for it
this will import this module for us and
store all of the things being exported
inside of this right here to that
variable
we can then go
print
mod dot sum
10 5
or
mod dot say hello
mic
if we run now we get 15 and hello mic
all of them are made inside of this
module here
this is a way to keep one file from
going like to 10 000 lines of code
because you could split it up so one
file could have a thousand another could
have two thousand another could have
five hundred
and they could just make the process of
reading this main file much easier since
we're importing the stuff we need from
outside
but as the basics of modules it's just
another file
that's returning a
table
and this table contains a bunch of
functions or variables
that we can use here once we import it
with require
what exactly is
oop
is object orientated programming it is
when you think of your code as objects
for example
you have a car that's an object a car
could have wheels a car could drive
a car could do this
you have a pit
you could have a cat pit you could be
able to feed your pit you could be able
to give your pet a name because a pet is
just an object
you could have a cup a cup is just an
object that you could fill with water
that's the whole idea
behind
oop
everything in your code is an object
some people love oop some people hate it
i personally love oop when doing game
development
but prefer using procedural programming
basically what we've been doing up until
now
with normal programs
now in lua there are multiple ways to do
oop
there's not just one not just two
there's more
i'm going to show you one way to do it
but if you don't like this method you
could go and search for a different
method that you might like more
there's one that uses meta tables but i
find that method to be very confusing to
understand and a bit
difficult to use
so instead i like to use functions and
simulate oop with them
i'll show you an example let's create a
object
local
function
pit
this is your pit
now your pet could be a dog or a cat but
this is a pet
it is what you use when you go
charlie come here i have a treat for you
you're calling your pet and
we will return
a table
because a table is the best way to get
an object if you maybe come from
python or from javascript then
dictionaries or objects it would be this
same concept
and here we could do something like name
is equal to
charlie
then here we could go and say local
pet
or even cat is equal to pet
and then we could print
cat.name
anything inside of this return is public
and can be used with this object
now if we were to run this we get
charlie because this is just a table
but we disguise it as a function which
generates an object for us
this is nice because now i could have
two pits one that's a dog
and now i could go
dog.name
both of them will be charlie so this pit
is a bit flawed
let's allow us to change the name so
name
we would say name is equal to name or
charlie
so if they didn't enter a name it will
default to charlie
here we could say jack
so my pet is called jack now my cat is
charlie my dog is jack
on the end of the day
these are just a bunch of tables
but we can create or generate tables for
us by calling functions
so that's pretty neat
now take note if something is not in
this return it won't be returned for us
to use if i go age is equal to 10
i cannot use this age here i could use
it here so i could go
days
alive is equal to h times three six five
there we go
now here i can't go cat age and then
dog days alive only dog will return a
value because age is not returned
only the things in return is returned
also we can just go local here
so if i were to run this we'll get nil
and 3650
that is because age is not returned so
we don't know what it is
this can be seen as a private property
of your object so something you can use
only in your object and it cannot be
used outside of it
and this here could be seen as a public
property that can be used and called
outside of this object
you then also have two types of
functions
you have the
speak
and this function is just a normal
function
and we can just say print
and let's just go meow
even if it's a dog let's just say it
meows
then you also have another function
which we could call
feed so if you want to feed this pit
that can be a function that takes in
itself and we'll discuss it in a second
and for now right now we don't have to
do anything here we can just say print
okay so here we have a basic
class with two type of functions
this first function here
can be called with this dot syntax so
speak
and this is return anything so we don't
have to print it
but you take note this second function
so we could feed here
will not work
because it takes in self
and self is what you use to specify
this object
this right here
this is the self it is this table self
is referring to this table it's
referring to itself
but this won't work so if we run this
we'll get meow and eating
when we go
self dot
name and we try and run it now
we'll get an error
because self is a nil value
so once we want to use self here which
allows us to reference anything inside
of this table
we cannot use this dot syntax anymore we
have to use
colon
basically passes dog into itself in a
sense
so this first value here
is going to be this here
so if we go here and we run this we get
eating and then jack
so these are the two functions you'll
usually get
i usually just say make all of them
include self even if you're not using
self because then all of your functions
will require a colon and you'll never
have to wonder
is this function not working because it
needs a dot or a colon
it will always need a colon so i always
say include self even if you're not
using self
and itself here can we use to access any
value inside
of this right here
so i can go self
speak
and now we can speak we run this we get
meow eating jack and then meow that is
the basics of these types of functions
but usually just stick with self and you
won't have to memorize what the other
does
now let's say
you want a type of pet
that isn't in its own a pet or it is a
pit object but it's more specific than
that
this is called inheritance
so let's say i want another type of
object so local
function
dog right
dog takes a name
but now
we go return
and we're like okay
i want all of these inside of dog as
well
so we copy we paste
we now have all of the same things
but now we want to add a few new things
we want to add breed which is equal
to doberman
and we have loyalty because dogs can be
very loyal
and we'll make that equal to zero
so now we have a dog that has all the
same items as this pit object here
and we can go
local
doberman is equal to
dog jesse
now we can say
doberman
dot breed and now we can get the breed
of this doberman
and that's while we're adding it
doberman dot
name if we now run this we'll get jessie
which is a doberman
cool
but now we decide here inside of our pit
we want to add another item
we want to add
status and status
will be something like hungary
now since we want dog to have everything
played as we now have to remember and
this could be like a ton of objects that
could have the same types of items in
pit but now we have to remember hmm
we have to copy this and we have to go
paste it here as well
we have to remember that and a lot of
times you'll have five or even more
objects that will be inheriting from
this object so it will have all the same
items
so you will have to remember all of the
objects that's using this object so you
can go and copy paste all of these here
this isn't the way to go
instead you should use inheritance
inheritance is when you inherit all of
the
different types of properties in one
object
and you use it in another
so here we could say
local dog is equal to pet and we pass in
this name that gets passed into dog
cool
now we return
dog
and then instead of creating this object
here we can now just append to this
already existing one
so dog
dot
breed
and we can make that equal to this right
here
dog
and then dot loyalty
like that
and then we can remove this part here
and now we have successfully inherited
all of the properties that's being
returned here so we get name we get
status we get speak and we get feed
we get all of these here
and now we add two more properties onto
this property we have or onto this table
we get from this
and return that
now we'll have both the name and the
breed even though we didn't copy paste
any of these here
if you run this we'll get the same
output and once we change anything here
so anything here for example we can add
points for some reason
and make that equal to 10.
i can now in my dog
i can access
points
even though i didn't actually copy paste
that data here
we can now also go breed and we could
rather pass in the breed
or
doberman
so now we could actually go here and say
poodle so now we get a poodle instead
we run this we get jc poodle
we can overwrite functions that already
exist here as well
for here we say meow
we could go
dog
dot speak
and speak is a function that takes
itself
and then instead of saying meow it says
woof
so now when we go
poodle
speak
it will say woof
this is the power of inheritance so we
can have a bunch of objects that's
inheriting from this object so now we
can maybe go here
and we can create a cat
which has the same
types
but this time it maybe doesn't have a
breed because they don't know any cat
breeds
it doesn't have loyalty doesn't have
speak
and here's a cat
and we can go here and say
lazy and that would be cat that lazy
is equal to true
so if the cat is lazy or not
now this cat has all of the items inside
of pit
and one more that's lazy
and of course if you wanted to you could
make cat inherit everything from dog
you just of course have to pass in the
breed which i don't know idk
and now cat has all of the items inside
of dog and the pit because dog has
everything inside of pit
so cat now has everything inside of pit
and dog
because cat is inheriting from dog here
and this is the basics of oop you might
not quite understand everything here yet
but once we get to the game development
section of this course then you'll
quickly start to understand the power of
object orientated programming and how
everything here connects with one
another
and hello everyone if you are enjoying
this tutorial please leave a like and
subscribe for future tutorials
and hello everyone welcome back
to another tutorial so in this tutorial
we'll be looking into
love 2d live 2d is basically a framework
that you can use to make 2d games in lua
now first of all you need to install
love2d
if you are on windows then you can just
go and get the installer if you're on
mac you can get the zip and if you're on
ubuntu or linux you can just get one of
these
since i am on arch i can just do this
i'm going to go to terminal new terminal
and just pac-man dash is
love and you just need to consider that
and that will woo and that will install
love 2d for me
so as you can see it's already installed
and up to date so i'm not going to
install it but if you're on arch that's
how you would install it
cool then once you have it installed
then you can just say love
and that should pop up something similar
to this
you might not have this exam this
exactly same thing here it highly
depends i have loved version 11.3 if you
have a lower or a higher version of love
you will see something different
i do recommend having the same version
of love as i do or at least a higher
version
because a lot of the features may not
exactly work on later or newer versions
of love so i'd recommend having 11.3 the
same as mine
if you ever wonder about anything or
whatnot you can just go to the love tv
website to love tv.org and you can click
on this wiki here
this wiki will basically give you all
you need to know about love we won't be
covering every single thing here but we
will be covering quite a lot of this for
example let's go to the
let's see let's go to sound let's say
you want to play some sound which we
will cover in later video as you can see
you have a bunch of things here you can
use to work with sound let's say you
want to go to a window then here's a
bunch of things you can do with the
window
so there's a bunch of things you can do
here i'm only going to show you the most
basic and we will be building two games
at the end just so you have a good idea
of what we'll be working with
okay
now i think we're ready let's get
started
so first we need to just move this
to the right because i don't like it if
it's at the bottom i do love it if it's
at the right side
now first let's create a new file i'm
going to call this main.lua you need to
have at least one main.lua file here in
order to be for love to be able to
execute otherwise love may not know
which file to execute
so here it's main.lua and now i'm just
going to close that so we have more
space so we're still inside that file
now take note i have a terminal open but
if you're on windows i do believe you
can just
double click that love that main.lua
file and that should run live 2d but i'm
not sure
if you're on windows i would actually
recommend opening up the command line
same on mac open up the command line and
just saying love
dot in that directory because as you can
see i'm in this directory right here so
if i were to
just let's say open up my folder here so
funner
as you can see there's main.lua i'm in
this four right here
now first thing we need to do is we need
to set up a basic project so to do that
we need to go under scrutiny and make
sure you do have love to the installed
otherwise this might not work dot love
this means make this a global variable
with the name of love and we're going to
require
the module called love
so basically this is normal
lua we're just importing a module called
love
then next up
we need to create three functions
these three functions are the basic
concepts of running a game
so first we have a function
called love it needs to have love at the
start here love dot load this is very
important i'm going to explaining all of
this in a second we can just ignore this
for now i'm going to copy this and i'm
going to paste them two more times
and i'm going to close that
then this we can make love dot update
and update will take in ddt and i'll
explain that in a second
and here we can say love the draw
okay
so let's explain what these are now in
every game you have three stages you
have the load
the update and the drawing stage
live2d makes this incredibly simple to
do the loading the update and drawing in
their respective functions
one of the reasons i do love love is
because of this right here because it's
languages like java for example you'll
have to actually go through and make
these functions yourself and let them
work in the background as they should
where love2d has already configured a
lot of this for you
so first loading is to basically load in
data when the application starts up so
when we boot up the game this will load
all of the data we need so we need to
put things in here that we want to load
then here with update this basically
runs every
once every 60 frames this should run
once every 60 frames so this is 60
frames per second love2d is kind of
locked to 60 frames per second it can go
lower if the game requires a lot of
resources but it's kind of locked to 60
frames per second so once you start this
up you'll get 60 frames a second
dt is basically delta time it's the time
between this frame and the last
currently you don't have to worry too
much about this it's mostly just math so
don't worry too much about dt we'll get
deeper into that later
but basically this is every frame
imagine that it's a frame so you have 60
frames a second this will be every frame
it's the time between this frame and the
i last
to draw oh wait and we're still here and
this will just also update everything so
let's say we have a player if we want
the player to move the player will be
moved inside of this update function
here so this will move the player
then we have draw and this will draw
everything to the screen so first we
move the player and then we draw the
player the player at its new location
or we
the player gets hit and then we update a
heart getting destroyed in the game
that's what we draw
basically that's how it works we'll get
deeper into these things as the
tutorials go on but for right now it's
not too important but we will we will
get to it
so let's start off with just creating a
basic hello world so we're just going to
skip these two for now we don't have to
worry about them and here we can say
love
and you'll notice most of love's
important
functions start with love
got the graphics graphics is what we use
to draw something to the screen so we
use graphics
dot print and this will just basically
print to the screen it's very simple it
doesn't do too much
and we can just print
hello world
all right now if we were to say love and
then dot this means run love in this
folder and it will find that main file
and will burn it
you'll see this but then you'll also see
this little pop-up right here
just saying hello world there's a little
icon there's some text which you can
change later and here's like the basic
functionality you'll have and yeah
that's the basics
we have created our first application it
it just displays hello world it's a
first game
now let's do something a bit more
intense than just printing something to
the screen
just so i can show you the difference
between load update and draw
so here let's create a variable called
number
and make that equal to zero
take note this is a global variable you
can either do it like this or you can
say underscore g dot number
so that this will load in this number
when the game starts it needs to be
global because we need to access it
between the other functions
in this update right here we need to
update the number so with every frame we
want to update this number so we can say
number because we're accessing this
number right here
if you don't know i do recommend you go
watch the tutorial i made
and you can say number
plus one
this will take this number and it will
just add one to it
then here where we do this we can just
display
number
[Applause]
so i'll explain what this does more in a
second let's quickly run it and see what
we get
so right here you see a little number
constantly increasing
that is this number right here so let's
just move this to the side
first we set the number so when the game
loads we set the number to zero so once
this boots up this will be zero
then every time with every frame this
number updates so this number increases
with one with every frame
and in this drawer right here
this will print the number to the screen
so as you can see we first set the
number
and this only runs once this load that
only runs once this update however and
this draw runs every 60 or every frame
so these two runs every frame
and this prints it every frame
so in this tutorial we'll be covering
the
live love2d configuration file now this
configuration file is basically a file
that allows us to configure application
more to maybe get certain permissions or
to add certain features to the
application
so this gets started so we just have a
very basic application here what goes on
in here doesn't matter too much
because we wouldn't be using this a lot
so first thing we need to do is we need
to create this configuration file so you
just right click new file or you can
open that folder it is in for example
you can see here there's my main.lua
file it's creating a new file and we can
call it conf
dot lua
like that and now we have a
configuration file
and inside of this configuration file we
can put a function so function
and then love.conf
and inside of it we can just p put t
so t is basically a variable that's
going to be passed in for us that will
basically contain a bunch of information
and stuff we can use
and then of course
this is just for love and then here we
basically say we want to manage the
configuration for application
so there's a lot of things here
for example t dot identity
and we can just make that equal to a
little for now
this will allow us to
assign a save file i'm just going to
also do this for now
so this will allow us to assign a save
file we can insert the path to that save
directory for example
saves or let's say data
saves
like that and then here we can just
create a new folder called data instead
of that saves
now we have a folder with the name data
and inside of that folder named save
and there we can see that's the path to
it
so that's just basically the saves
directory
not too much there
the next app
we have and of course you can add
multiple things here so i can continue
underneath this if i wanted to
and next up you have things like the
version
and here you can see the version of your
game
this is very useful because sometimes if
you update your game especially on
android
there are two things that can happen
one you can install an entirely new
application
or two
that application that already exists
will be updated where it is that's what
you usually happen to have applications
and that's what should be happening
so here it can put like a version like
1.0.0 and i didn't do it instead of
creation marks
like this
and then how you can basically determine
when you should update what here it's up
to you of course you can even add more
things here like v1
and
lstl or whatnot you want to add to this
but usually if it's like this
then you can just say for minor updates
let's say you fixed a small bug you can
increase that by one
and let's say you maybe just updated the
output so
there's just like a so instead of it
saying game over it says game lost that
will make it two
so if every minor change you can
do this
then
with every
major or a major change but bigger
change so let's say you add a full blown
menu system or full-blown settings to
your application like it's a new
it's a new path to your application like
the whole new version almost
then you can increase this by let's say
one or two and it remember it doesn't
have to be small numbers this could be
like something like this and it's
perfectly fine to make it very large
numbers
it's it doesn't have to be small values
like we put in here for example
and then once you have basically a
change that makes this the version 2 or
the version 3 of your game or like any
major version of your game you can
increase this so this means it's
basically not
the first version anymore it's basically
like the second version of the game
a lot of people also just like to do
this just to keep it simple they just
use two numbers where if every major
update so let's say for example and you
implement in whole settings page for
your game they will increase this
and with every minor update they will
increase this so let's say you added
like a little title at the bottom in
you can just add that or you added like
another
character that or npc that doesn't do
anything
add one there like that all right in
case you mess around with it too much i
just put basic versioning in here let's
actually keep this one here just for
interesting and remove that one
then we also have t.console
and
this
is basically
if a
console should be attached
to that game and there should be a true
or false value so false means which is
it by default there shouldn't be a
console attached to the game this is
windows only take note of that if you're
on linux or mac this won't really affect
anything but if you're on windows you
might notice sometimes that there's like
a little black box this command line or
cmd that pops up when you open up an
application
that's the console so if this is true
this means that the console should be
running in the background and it will
basically be attached to this window so
once you close the window the console
will close as well
windows only though so take note of that
next up let's say you want to save the
files but on an external storage
like you want to save the files but on
and
sd card for example
then we can say t dot external
external
storage
all lowercase
and
false or this would be true then this
means you want to save the files but you
want to do it
on the sd card and not on the normal
phone storage
and i do believe this is android only so
take note of that i think this is
android only so you should also
take in consideration about this
we also have t dot gamma
correct is equal to true
now this will basically in a sense
if the system supports it
it will enable gamma correct rendering
i have no idea what that is
but if this isn't supported it will do
that it will probably just enable better
gamma whatever i think gamma is like
lighting or things like that
let me google that
yes so it is the overall brightness of
something so
the more bright it is the higher the
gamma i guess
and yeah it's something like that i
don't usually work too much with that i
usually just do the basics in the
configuration files i would go for
camera correct unless someone
specifically like gives an issue about
the gamma being wrong or something like
that then i will enter that but usually
i don't care too much about that
okay
next let's say you're have you played
like an online
game and it's like a game like pubg
on pub g you have the option to click a
button and then it will hear your voice
speak
so you can speak to people on pubg by
clicking the microphone button
we can enable that as well
now
on android
we need to basically get a prompt that
allows us to
hear
the user's voice because you may have
noticed if you want to talk to someone
on pubg the first time you click on that
button it will pop up a prompt asking
you if it can use your microphone that's
what we're going to do here so t dot
audio
dot mic
equal true so if it's on android and you
want to enable microphone
then this will basically give them a
little pop-up asking hey
can i use the mic
cool now let's actually configure
something we'll be able to see
such as t.window.type
and that should be window
okay
and we just make that equal to whatever
title we want for example cool
ball game
now if we were to love this
we'll get this right here which says
cool ball game so that's this part right
there
so that would be the the.title
we also have things like the window icon
you'll notice i have a little folder
here here with an icon inside of it
it's called game icon.jpg
usually you want to save these as ico
because that's a con file but i use the
jpg just because
so here i can just specify
icon
slash
game
icon
dot jpg
now if i want to run that
then you'll notice i have a little icon
here now
and that's this icon we got right here
it's a very dark icon i should have
picked something a bit lighter but you
can see there's a little icon there so
that's to change the icon if you wanted
to do that
then you can by doing this and you see
it's an icon and then game icon take
note this path is kind of relative at
the moment because you can see here if i
were to move my conf file outside of
this folder right here so icon was in a
different folder it would not find this
icon here so keep note that the location
of where the conf is and where icon is
that's very important
but we're not going to go too deep into
that that's something completely
different you usually have to worry
about you can also set the window with
for example if we were to do this
and you can also set a height it is to
go like this and you can say we'll go
away
with
and here we say
height
and then
all we need to do is specify the width
and the height for example let's say the
width should be
400 and the height should be
which is which is a very weird ratio but
there you go so the width is now 400 i
believe pixels and the height is now 200
i believe pixels
you can of course make this as big as
you want for example
1200 by 700
which is almost a 16 by nine aspect
ratio as you can see that right there
now it's a lot bigger so it just depends
how you prefer it
you'll also notice that if i would just
do here again
that
if i want to resize it i can
so i can't resize it so even if i wanted
to
it just moves it it doesn't resize it
and this is by default like this because
usually you don't want games to just be
resized because that could break the
game
but if you do want this to be allowed
for your users you can say t dot window
dot
resizable is equal to true
now the window can be resized so if i
were to bring it over here
now to go here
then i can resize the window
so it by default it is disabled and for
good reason
as i say you usually do not want to
enable this because that could cause the
game to break you'll notice in more
popular games as well you can't resize
the window because it's dangerous to
resize the window
you can also give it a minimum width and
a minimum minimum height
which could be better if you have this
resizable on for example
but i can just copy this
and in here instead of just saying
we have and height we can just say min
and i'm going to copy that width there
and just paste it here
so now i can sit like the minimum width
and height it's allowed to be for
example let's say the minimum height
it's allowed to be as 500
and the minimum width it's allowed to be
is let's say 1 000.
now even though it's resizable true it
can only be sized to a specific size so
here if i were to resize it as you can
see after a while it doesn't allow me to
resize anymore but i can make it bigger
but i can't make it smaller
so it has like a minimum size it can be
resized two if you want to enable the
resizable as i said before rather not
you can also remove a window border by
saying t dot window dot
border
list
is equal to true
this will remove the window border which
i don't always recommend but it's a good
option if you want to allow your users
to have that okay so as you can see it
doesn't have anything up here
this should be optional if you want to
put it in you shouldn't force this onto
the user because not all users like this
you'll notice with most games you have
an option to remove the borders and
that's a good there's a good reason why
there's an option to remove it and
usually by default it's not removed
unless it's by default full screen
you can also enable vsync so
vsync
and this you should specify with a
number i don't quite know what this
number means but you should specify the
number if you wanted enabled
here it is now vsync enable
if you don't know what it is it's i
think it's vertical sync and it's to
sync sound and
and the video but it's it should be
optional because yet again not everyone
will benefit from b-sync
because it's by default it is
aligned as it should be but
usually you don't worry too much about
it
okay so that should also be optional for
the user to change you shouldn't force
it on him again
and here's something that could possibly
solve my problems
display
tell it on what display to appear
for example if i say display one but
actually nope it displays that one if i
say display two which is not my main
display
then ah it does appear here
so now what we can do is instead of me
having to continuously drag it over to
show you i can now go here and i can
make
full screen
i actually didn't know this display was
here i just realized
that it exists and just as you can see
it's full screen and i didn't actually
think this through because you know i
can't really exit
but yeah so that's if you wanted full
screen now i'm going to keep that there
because that's actually very useful i
wish i knew that existed much sooner
you can also specify the x and the y
coordinate coordinates so we were to
copy this
and go here then we can like say
x
and let's make this 200 i don't know if
this is not going to go back to this
screen because the displays are kind of
linked
okay so you know it's here so the x is
now 200 as you can see right there but
to make that list and let's say 100
then it's 100 from the side here
so yeah
then we also have y
and let's make this 100 as well
so let's see 100 100.
that's very useful if you wanted to be
at a specific location but yet again you
might just want this if you want to save
where the user last had the application
when they closed it that could be a good
feature but forcing a location yet again
not always a good idea because that
location may not exist on the user's
monitor because let's say the monitor is
smaller than yours and you set it to
specify beyond 500 500
they might not have a screen which is
very rare but they might not have a
screen that size
so yeah just keep that as note this
should usually be an optional thing you
add
all right so next up
is something i do not recommend you play
around with it
it's good to know it exists but you
should not be playing around with this
unless you know what you're doing but
usually you do not want to play around
with it
you can disable and enable modules by
default all modules are enabled in
love2b but you can disable them if you
don't want them
for example t dot modules
dot and let's say timer is equal to
false by default this would actually be
true because the timer is enabled
now this timer right here provides this
dt here which is the time between
this frame and the last frame
so if we remove that module dt so if we
make number here dt
and then print that value dt would be
zero
so right there and i've accidentally
removed my one thing i liked as you can
see there it's zero
but if we were to yet again just remove
that from there and actually let's bring
back our window display i did kind of
like that
so if we were to remove that disabling
module
then as you can see dt is a number
so just take note you can disable
modules which i guess would probably
decrease the application size
or something i don't know what it will
really benefit in doing but you can do
it if you want to do it
so just take notes of that
so usually don't just don't disable
anything that's a good rule of thumb if
you know you're not using something and
you know and you know you're not going
to use it
then i guess disable it but usually you
don't want to disable anything
now if you might have fallen behind or
you want to maybe remember some of this
you can always find it
here on the con on the love 2d website
so for the most part we're going to use
load or update here we're mostly just
going to use draw
so we can just focus on that
let's try and draw a rectangle
in lua which is pretty simple so it's
just love dot
graphics
dot
rectangle
and here we can specify the type it
should be
so you have different ones like line and
fill we'll cover both of these in a
second so let's just say fill for now
and then we can specify the location and
i'm going to explain all of this in a
second as well
now if we were to run this you'll notice
we have a little white square here
and yeah so let's go look here what is
all of this
first we have the type fill so as you
can see here this is like an entire box
just wide
but if we were to make this instead of
fill we were to make this line
then now we'll have a outline instead of
having a fully filled white square
then we have our x position which is 50
so this is the x position
and then our y position which is 50 and
this is like that you can remember which
one is x and y by remembering that x is
going horizontally and y is going
vertically and as you know y if we were
to put a y here
it has a thing that goes downwards
so
this would kind of represent a y shape
and that allows you to remember that
this section here up to down that's why
so this point right there would be zero
y and zero x
here would be
50x but 0y and here would be 50x 50y and
here would be 50y 0x
we'll explore this a little bit more in
a second
and then here we have the width and the
height so we were to make this 100
then now the width with 100 as you can
see here 100.
let's change the x so let's make this 10
instead
like that
now if we were to run you'll notice it's
only 10 pixels from the side here
as you can see
and then here is the y let's increase
the y to let's say
500.
i don't know if that's actually still on
the screen it is there we go so this is
500 pixels
so yeah that's the basics of just
drawing a rectangle you have your x you
have your y you have your
width and you have your height so you
can of course make the height having
bigger so if you wanted to make a little
bit larger you could you see there
now as i said before if we were to make
this zero
and then run it again you'll notice that
now it's here because the x-axis if we
go back here
is zero so it's right there it's against
the wall because it's zero
if we were to make this right here zero
and let's say this
ten
let's just close this
then now as you can see it's here at the
top because that's the y index of zero
as you can see because remember y is
going down like that it has like this
little y symbol
i'll see if i can try and edit that in
and of course if we were to make it zero
zero then it would be against the wall
as you see here zero x zero wise it's
against the wall
now before we continue to let's say
something different let's try and change
the color
because currently we only have white
what if we wanted to make it a different
color
we can do that by saying love dot
graphics
dot set color
and we can make it let's say
one zero
zero
which would be red and i'll explain why
in a second so we will boot this up
you'll notice a red square now and not a
white square
so this right here uses rgb values
now rgb if you don't know
stands for red green blue
and here below we have between zero and
one
so 0.5 would be fine for example so 0.5
that would be
halfway
so 0
zero zero so for this was all zero
this would be black
because that means there's no red
there's no green and there's no blue
that's it's only black so none of those
colors exist whereas if we were to make
this one one one
then this would mean white because that
means all of the red all the green that
all the blue is in here
now usually you don't really want to
figure out colors like this
oftentimes you'd want to get your
browser and search up
color picker
and you'll find something like this so
let's say you wanted a nice greenish
color so let's go here
and then we go like this
cool and you'll notice here we have rgb
we can copy that
and now here what we can do is we can
paste it here
and we can say
divided by 255
and if you do this then we'll get this
greenish color
as you can see right there
we divided by 255 because by default
usually it's actually 255 so it's a
number between 0 and 255 but in lua it's
a number between 0 and 1. so if we
divide it like this we'll get a value
with it so if we go like this
then we can just say
75 divided by 255 and that gives us
0.29411 so we could have put we could
have done this
zero 0.29411
but first of all this is kind of
difficult to read because you can't
really tell
how much that is some people this is
pretty simple but to me it looks a lot
more than what it really is
and that's why i just prefer this
so you can choose between using this or
this
it will give you the same output so if
we were to run this we'll still get that
same green
if we can just get love as you see there
we get the same green
so yeah but what if we wanted to make
this
black so zero
zero zero
you'll notice
the background is the same color so if
we wanted to make this the same color as
the background is now we won't be able
to see it
so how does one change the background
color
well it's pretty simple now you can
either do it here or you can do it on
the on load so you can change it on the
unload or you can change it on the draw
if you change it here it's going to do
that change every time or every frame is
going to make that background color the
color you set it to
every time you
call this every time draw is called so
that's every frame if you do it on
unload it will do it once and that's
only when it loads up so for extra
performance sake i would recommend doing
it here unless it's part of the game to
change the background color
anyways we can say love dot graphics dot
sit background color and here we have
the same option so i'm just gonna say
0.5 0.5
and let's maybe say one
and now if you were to run this you'll
get this purplish color
and then with the black box right there
so that's how i can change the
background color
now let's get back to the actual topic
of the video
let's draw another shape let's try and
draw in circle this time
so let's go love.graphics.circle
as simple as that i'm going to make the
circle
line and not fill but you can make it
feel if that's what you want i'm going
to position it at 100 100 and i'm going
to make the size
50.
now take note this is the radius so it's
not a width and a height it's a radius
meaning it's going to be 50 pixels to
the left and 50 pixels to the right 50
pixels to the top 50 pixels to the
bottom
this is going to be a pretty big circle
as you can see right there
we can actually move it out a bit more
so let's maybe go
200 or 200
that's an x and let's make it
500 on the y
now if we're done this as you can see
we get this
so it's nice circle and whatnot now what
if we wanted to change the color of this
circle
because we've already set the color have
we not
well it's pretty simple we just copy
that line of code
and paste it here again
now we can give it a different color so
let's say
one zero point seven
and
zero
zero zero point one there we go
now from this we get this yellowish
color that's kind of difficult to see
but it is there
so if you want to change the color you
just basically set it here but take note
this is important that these colors stay
the same because of every frame
it's going to call that again so we do
this right now everything is going to be
this yellowish color as you can see
because i commented out this part so
when this code runs again because it's
going to set the color and then when it
runs again it's going to not set the
color again
or it is going to set it again but here
it doesn't change the color back it just
draws and then it sits the color but
it's already this color and then it goes
here and it does it again and again
where with this
every time this runs it changes the
color back to this
this is something that's very important
and you'll notice when you build the
games
that this does come in handy to know how
this works
i do recommend you play with this
because you'll notice if you comment
something out then this might not work
if you'd maybe move this to a different
location it might work so if we put this
set color there it won't work
as you can see there
because
the color is set here
but then we come here and we change the
color then these two execute and then we
set the color to this and nothing is
really drawn after that if we were to
comment this out then now everything
would be yellow again even though it's
at the end as you can see there
very good to note that
so let's draw one more shape and then i
want to show you how to just make
something move
so
here we can maybe draw an arc
i'm going to make it a line once again
and
let's say we need to exposition y
position we can maybe keep this but
maybe make this 250
and in here we need an angle one and an
angle two so i'm going to make zero and
two and you'll see what happened in a
second
my bad i forgot to add the radius
because we also need a radius i'm not
going to make it that big let's make it
20.
and now if you do this as you can see we
have a little thing there actually let's
make a bit bigger because it is kind of
small so let's go maybe
60 i'm pretty sure that would not 660
should be good enough
as you can see here we have like a
little cheese shape here
now let's see what happens if we change
one of the arcs to let's instead of two
we make it five
what will happen
as you can see we get a little pac-man
that's pretty cool
you can make a pacman game of this
because
it already draws the arc for you all you
need to do is make this change
so let's see what if we make this
two
what will happen now because what does
this arc really do
as you can see
it kind of changes where this and that
starts and ends
what if we made both of these 5 what
will happen then
nothing because now both of them start
and end at the same place if you were to
make this zero
and let's make this five again
you'll notice this
so if we wanted to make a pacman
we might want to go
one
six
i'm pretty sure that should be
relatively close to man
relatively close not quite on it so let
me make this zero again
and as you can see here we have a little
version of pac-man
we might want to make the mouth a bit
bigger so maybe make that five and make
that one
as you can see there now we have a
pac-man
you can play around with this this is
mostly just kind of playing around to
figure out what you want
so you basically give it x to y the
radius and remember the radius is
basically from middle to the outer ball
so it's from here to there that's 60
pixels that part right there
and that's there that's also 60 pixels
now let's try and move pac-man so notice
here we have pac-man let's try and move
pac-man here
forward because that's what pac-man
would usually do it will move forward to
eat maybe that little square there so we
can even put that in front of pac-man so
you can eat it so let's see here let's
make this
x axis
600 and to
200 i'm pretty sure that should give us
what we wanted we go here you'll notice
these are square for him to eat
if we were to just make it a little bit
smaller so
maybe instead of six hundred
for remains of a hundred i mean we can
go to 70 and 70.
so let's see that's a nice square for it
to eat
okay now let's make pac-man move
so here
i'm going to create a little variable
just a table basic lua
so we can say
pac-man
and we can make pac-man equal to nothing
you could of course go underscore g dot
pac-man that will also make it a global
but it's optional both of these are
considered global i'm going to do the
underscore g pacman
i'm going to say pacman
dot x is equal to
let's say
let's give these x and y values here so
let's say 200
and then
pac-man
dot y
is equal to 250
okay now we have pac-man's to locations
so this is basically the same as saying
x
and then 200 and
y and then 250 and that should be an
equal symbol
it's basically the same as saying that
we just split it up and do multiple
lines so it's optional if you want to do
that i like splitting it up into
multiple lines like this
and in here we can just specify the
pac-man x and pac-man y
so now pack my next
and then pac-man y
now if we were to run this everything
should still look the same as you can
see there and let's fill pac-man so
so let's fill pac-man
as you can see now pac-man is nicely
filled
now let's move pac-man so here in update
we can say
pac-man
dot x
plus equals one
let's do that and see what happens
oh that might be a little bit too fast
so let's maybe and i think this should
also be equals pacman dot x
plus and then how many this might be a
little fast we might need to slow down
but let's see now it isn't so as you can
see pac-man now moves until
it eats this right here
cool
now let's make the square disappear
once pac-man has eaten it
so i'm going to go here and make
pacman
dot eat equal to false
cool
now i'm going to do
is i'm going to go here and say
underscore g dot
food
i'm going to say x i'm going to create
an entire
table just for food i'm going to make it
equal
to
600.
there we go
now here i'm just going to paste food x
here
and now i can say
if
pacman dot x
is more equal to
food x
and let's maybe add a little bit just a
pacman can move a tiny bit before it
actually disappears so maybe maybe 20
pixels
so if pac-man x is more equal to this
value here
then we want to say
pacman dot eat is equal to true
and then here we can say
if
not
pacman dot eat
and still this basic lure if you do not
know what i'm talking about here you
should go watch my tutorial on it but
i'll explain anyways so let's first see
what happens before i expect so here we
have a little pacman that's now moving
trying to eat this little square here
once it gets to it
it disappears because pac-man just ate
the square
what did we do in this small game
program we made
so first we set the color of the
background which doesn't necessarily
need to be this
then we created a pac-man table
and pat that pac-man table contain the x
of pac-man the why of pac-man and if
pac-man has eaten the why in this case
isn't that important because we didn't
change it the eat is important because
if pac-man has eaten meaning if he has
eaten that pellet
that will basically make us not droid
because if this is
true then this will not execute because
not means if this is not true
then execute otherwise if this was false
it would be if this is not false
as you can see
doesn't work that good but you could
also have swapped it around and say true
and in here you can make
false
and in here you could just say if
pac-man.eat
or you could have actually given it to
this food variable here instead so
instead of doing that we can just say
underscore food
eaten
and we made it made this false
and then we could have made food eaten
equal to true
here and now if we were to
now we can just say
food eaten
this will also work perfectly fine
so
yeah
that's the basics of that whole part
there
as we run this you'll notice it'll works
yeah my bad
and just turns out
because there's a global variable it
doesn't really know that too well we
might
so it thinks we're reassigning or we're
kind of creating any variables i'm just
going to put underscore g here so it
knows we're talking about this variable
right here
and this should be not my bad
because if it's not eaten if the food is
not eaten we want to draw that food
so that's what we're doing so if it's
not eaten we want to draw it but as soon
as it is becoming eaten
then we don't want to draw because it
has been ate or eaten i didn't know how
to do that in the previous 10 or past
tense very weird
and here we just move pac-man here we
check if pac-man has
accessed that food palette
and in here
we just save it should be drawn
and in here we draw pac-man
so just pac-man pac-man moves and
pac-man is about to eat this palette
here
as you can see but it's a very boring
game because we're not doing anything
so why don't we move pac-man
i'm just going to
delete that and here i'm going to go
underscore g
dot food and i'm going to make that
equal to an object
and then i'm going to say food
dot x
and here i'm going to say
food
dot eaten
and now these two are both objects but
just to show you that both of these
methods work let's actually go x is
equal to 600
and eaton
is equal to false you can do it like
this as well there's nothing wrong with
that
now here we can say
food dot eaten
and here we can also say
food
dot eaten
the game should still work perfectly
fine at the originals just say
and here as well so both of these two
places
food dot x
now the game should still work perfect
fine if you run it if pac-man reaches
the food palette right here it should
pop disappear let's see
it does cool
now
why didn't we try and move pac-man
ourselves because currently we're just
moving it with every update which is
kind of boring
so let's try and move it ourselves
so first i would like to be able to tell
pac-man when to move forward now usually
pac-man will move forward on his own but
i would like to move pac-man forward
only when i tell pac-man to move forward
so
let's do that
so here i'm going to
say if
well if love
dot
keyboard
dot is down
and i'm going to say the letter a
then
i want to
basically move pac-man backwards
so
pac-man
oh no package pac-man dot x
is equal to pac-man whoa
pac-man dot x
minus one
and that's your b dot x
i'm going to comment this out just so
that doesn't or literally actually
deleted we don't need it
now basically we're saying if this if
the a key is pressed because if it is
down if it is being
held in us down
do this
that's what we're saying so if the
keyboard key is pressed there are better
ways to do this than what we are doing
but for right now i think that's
perfectly fine it's not too complex or
anything
now pac-man doesn't move but as soon as
i press the a key
it moves backwards
which we didn't really want when we want
to move the other way around so let's
actually
go here and say else
if
and we can just copy this
and let's
put
a
let's put d there
and d will move pac-man
to
the right
so we want to just copy this
and paste
now we can just make that a
plus now you'll notice we made pacman
here we added that dot wider so we want
to move pacman up and down as well
so
let's actually
do that
i'm going to copy this
i'm just going to paste it two more
times and i'm going to make this w
i'm going to make this s
and now we can say
y instead of x
like that
and this should be minus
and let's see what we get
now we can move pac-man any way we want
because we have control over pac-man
that we try and eat this pellet
still gets eaten but you'll notice if i
press a and w at the same time
it doesn't really move up and down at
the same time or up and lift at the same
time
so how do we get around that problem
well we just instead of saying else if
we just say if
and we just add our end here
as simple as that
so just
end
and here we can say
n so we just add our individual if
statements here
so instead of saying else if where any
one of those can be executed we're
saying if
meaning all of these can be executed all
at once without a problem
so now if i run this
you'll notice i'll be i'm able to move
up and down at the same time
as you can see right here
and that's something you should take
note of because sometimes in your game
you want that to be something you can do
but sometimes it's not so you should be
able to kind of figure out which one you
want for your game
so you can know if you
use an if statement or an if else
statement
cool
now what if you wanted to rotate
pac-man because i know the real game
nearly rotate that much he either looks
up or he looks down but what if we
wanted to do that what if we wanted to
rotate pac-man slowly
if we want to move around because let's
say this is the normal pac-man we want
to make pac-man that can kind of just do
everything
well that's not too difficult
so you'll notice here we have two angles
the x angle and the y angle
under the x angle is just angle one and
angle two
now we need to change this if you want
to rotate pac-man because you'll notice
if we make this two and then this 6
pacman will know it will now be rotated
as you can see right like that
so let's try and rotate pac-man
so i'm going to go here
and say i'm just going to copy this
really
and now i want to if the
user presses down so that's the down
arrow on the keyboard
if they press down
we
want to basically take this angle right
here
and we actually want to modify it a
little bit
we're going to create maybe this pacman
right here
and say
angle
i'm going to just say angle one is equal
to one
and then
angle
so two is equal to
six and that's what we have here so one
and actually it's one and five dollar
one and six my bad
like that
i'm just going to attach it to pac-man
here
so pac-man will now have two more
properties angle one and angle two
like that
now what we want to do is we want to
change the angle one and angle two here
so i'm gonna go like that
and let's do this
and maybe make this angle two
now let's just try and see how that
works
now we can't really see anything
happening
and actually you know why this didn't
work it's because we never assigned
angles here
my bad i should have done all of this
from the start
so there we have angle one and now we
can make this angle two
now if we were to run again
as you can see pac-man spins but it's a
little fast you know because we can't
really control where the spin ends it's
too fast for us to actually figure out
so what can we do to make this slower
well we can actually just say
math dot pi
times dt
and this is where dt comes in real handy
because now
we can slow it down with a lot
as you can see here it's a lot slower
now if we want to basically
add more here we can just say
else
i'll see if i mean
i'm just going to copy this
and i'm going to paste it here i'm going
to say
up
it's going to contain the same code
but now instead of being plus it's going
to be minus
meaning i can now move either
up or down
as you can see here everything still
works
currently the angle you keep it on it
won't really change which way it moves
if you press w s or d but you could
change that if you wanted to but it's a
little bit more of the scope of this
video
but yeah
that's some basics on actually moving
things in your game using your keyboard
so getting keyboard input there are
multiple ways to get keyboard input
and we're going to discover those ways
when we create the games
but for right now i think this is more
than enough to cover what we need
so we have a little character here and
we want to make him run around
just like that this is an image and we
basically want to load in an image and
make it move
so if you want to ask it you can come to
www
www.gameart2d.com and just this link
right here i'll paste it in the
description
and you can get it right here
and yeah let's actually show you what
you'll get so if you go here you click
on free download
then you just wait for it to download
boom it's downloaded now you can open it
up
then if you extract it
like i did right here i just extracted
it by clicking right and extract to you
will probably have the same option on
windows if you don't i just recommend
you
go to windows and or you just download
winrar or 7z or whatnot then you'll find
a png file
and you'll find all of these well the
thing is
i didn't exactly use these like that
what i use
is more something like this
as you can see it's just one image with
a bunch of them in one this is what i
like to call a sprite
these right here they're to me they're
images but they're actually sprites as
well now you can of course just go
online and find a way to like add these
together i believe there is like a
sprite option
or a sprite website where you can just
go and create a sprite from images
otherwise you can just
all right so let's get started let me
just close this browser
now i'm going to just delete all of this
because we didn't need it
and all of this as well
and which is very long so we just plop
that
and then all of this as well
cool
now
first we want to set up some of the
core basics we'll need
and also actually i noticed i left
myself a comment here so if you want to
also make the sprite yourself instead
which could be good practice if you want
to make your own sprites
then you can go to this
code check dot io image sprites sheet
generator and you just browse images and
throw them in here that's this is what i
used i completely forgot about it
anyhow
now here we first need to set up some
basic information about the character
jack because that's what i like to call
my character but you can call main
character or character or whatever you
prefer
and we're going to make that equal to
and x is equal to zero and y is equal to
zero so this will be x and y position of
jack and you're going to go underscore g
dot to jack to specify jack or you can
go here
and you can say quick fix
and they just disable by diagnostics
like that
and this is a vs code thing where
basically it won't give you an error if
you use the lowercase global like this
about specifying underscore g
okay
now you'll notice i have a sprites
folder in my directories if i were to
open the containing folder there's a
sprites folder inside the sprites folder
is a spritesheet.png
this spritesheet is just what contains
the spriteboy over here jack
now we need to go inside of sprites and
we need to access that so for the
character i'm going to also give him
another property called sprite to
specify this is its sprite
it would be love
dot graphics
dot new
image
and here we can specify sprites as you
can see there so
sprites
and inside of it we have a
spritesheet.png
i'm going to rename that and then just
copy the text i don't actually remember
just copy the text and i'm going to
paste the text here
this will basically get that entire
sprite for me
cool
now that we have that
we can go here to underneath jack
and here we need to set the sprite's
height and the sprite width
so if we were to go back here and we
click on this sprite right here
i know can we see the properties it
doesn't seem like it if i click here
nope let's open up my containing folder
properties
and let's say image as you can see this
is the size of this
image
so 500 5352
by
569 nice
now i'm going to copy that
and i'm going to go here to my main.lua
and just paste it there in a comment
because that is the width and the height
so i'm going to create two variables
to specify the sprite width and height
so
sprite width
and then also sprite
height now of course you could have also
if you wanted to say sprite
and it makes sprites equal to a table so
a table within a table then you could
have said image
is equal to
this right
here is perfectly fine as well
and then you're going to specify the
height
and the width in here as well
you could have done this this is
perfectly fine
but i don't want to get too complicated
with tables because they can be kind of
become kind of complicated so for now
we can just do that
okay cool right
now here we just say it's equal to and
now we can say 5000 or you just copy
this part here
paste it here and then just change that
into a comma
and now this basically says the sprite
width is this and the sprite height is
this
you're going to split them up into two
lines but i like to do it in one line
just because it's fast
so now that you have that
you can go to the next line
and we can finally start working with
the sprite in a sense
so we need to specify a quad of the
sprite's worth so quad is basically
let's say right here this one block here
that would be a quad this would be the
next quad this would be an x squad
now they have to be equal with support
otherwise you might get confused and
might have a lot of trouble so make sure
that they are and what not
so here we can just specify the quad
stuff
so
quad
width
is equal to
669 nice
and how do i know this because i
actually measured this beforehand if
this is 669 per quad
i don't know how to measure it versus it
did ask me how to do it i can't remember
for the life of me
and then you have your quad
height
which will be the same as your sprite
height why because as you can see all
the quads are the same height and
they're the height that the entire
sprite is
so like that
and you could have also put this in one
line but i wanted to show you you can do
both if you wanted to
now what we need to do is we need to
basically specify for each quad now you
could have just used a bunch of images
like they pre like they gave us inside
of the
folder
or if you use what i use you need to do
the following you need it for every quad
you need to specify to love got graphics
dot new quad
and here you specify the location you
start at this will change the
height of it won't change but the width
of it will change so we're starting with
so this starts at zero zero so meaning
it starts right here right there
and then we want to specify the quad
width row
and then the quad height
and this will just specify the height
and width to get it with
for the quad and you need to specify the
entire sprite width and sprite height
cool now for the next one we need to
basically specify
the
quad width
and everything else stays the same
and now we need to do it again and again
and again and you can already see where
this is going you're going to have to do
that a ton of times
and it's going to be a bunch of copy
paste code which we want to try and
avoid as much as possible
so an alternative way to go about doing
this
is by creating a quads table like that
and then creating a for loop
so for
i
and then we can just
remove all of these because i need it is
equal to one
two and how many was there let's see
one two three four five six seven eight
there are eight of them so one two eight
do the following
and we want to just copy this
paste it in here
and now we can just say
quads at index of i
is equal to this
but now what we can do
is we can specify
the
quad width
times
i minus one
so it starts at zero so by default if
it's one minus one this will be zero so
then is the quad with time zero which
will return zero because anything times
zero is zero so just what we had but now
it has times so now once this is two so
once i turns into two those will become
one so there's a quad width
and then we have our quad worth times
three and whatnot i can actually show
you an example of how it would have
looked if we didn't do this it would
have looked like that
so let me actually just
do
there it would look like this
but instead of it looking like this we
used a for loop to make it shorter so
this quad with part here
as you can see it starts with zero then
it starts with itself it starts with
times two
times three times four that's what we do
here so quad width
times zero one two etc
so we just saved ourselves
tons of time because now if we just add
another quote to this sprite we can just
update this
as simple as that
now we want to draw this sprite to the
screen
so let's go here to draw
and
here we can say
glove dot graphics
dot draw
jack because jack is our character right
here
and we're going to specify the sprite
that you draw
and you want to specify the quote it
should draw so once and let's just
specify one for now
and then we're going to say jack
at index x and also jack at index y to
specify the location of the sprite
now if we were to run the oh this is in
python this is love
now in order to run the program we get a
massive dude right here but that's a
sprite
with every sprite this will change
because the sprites will provide
animation the remakes that sprite 5 will
get this where the fit is now moved
so yeah now that we know we can do this
let's first make jack smaller because
jack is very big so let's say
love.graphics.scale
and we scale it to 0.3
this will just make it back a bit
smaller by scaling all of the graphics
to 0.3
so now he's about 0.3 is original size
of course you could have also just made
the sprite smaller
by actually when you make the sprite
making it smaller
but in this case it's not really that
necessary we can just say scale it and
it will be scaled
next up we need to work on the animation
and we can create another
thing here and yet again you could have
put all of this inside of here i just
want to show you can make them different
but usually you do want to actually keep
them in here
but that's not too important for now
now we can also create an
animation option here
and this will be its own table it again
you could have made this into this table
here as well would have worked perfectly
fine
now i want to specify the direction he's
going to move in so if it's left or
right so direction
is equal to and then here we can specify
something like right
you also want to specify
the if he's standing still or not so
idle is equal to true so that means he's
standing still he's not doing anything
this will allow us to kind of give him a
specific position so let's say that's
the idle position so if he's standing
idle he should look like this
if he's not idle he should be moving
through the frames
then we can create the frame
and we can make that one
and we can create a max
frames
and that can be eight so these max
frames is basically
just the amount of frames we have here
this also means now that we have
implemented this max frames here we can
go and say jack
dot animation dot max frames instead
meaning if the max frames here ever
change we can just not have to worry
about it here
we can also change the speed so if you
wanted to faster or slower and we'll
make that let's say
20 for now
and then we also have a timer
and we can make that 0.1
and this will just determine when the
character should change frames
so the lower the timer the more the
character will change frames
all right so now that we have all of
this we can start implementing it
so first here we want to say
if
and not
jack.animation.idle
then
basically if he's not idling
we want to say
jack
that animation
the timer
is equal to and it is a very long thing
to type so i'm just going to copy that
and boom
and now here we can say plus dt and this
will just basically be our timer it will
determine when the frame should be
changed
and here we can see
if
the timer
is more than 0.2
then
the timer will be set to 0.1 again
and here we can basically specify
the character
everything
so let's first specify just iteration so
we can just see the character move
so if
i'm just going to say
frame
is
more
than the
max frames
then you want to change this frame back
to one
so just like that and just say
frame is equal to one
now that we have this in place we can go
above this line of code
and we can say
frame
and we just make that equal to itself
plus one so this will basically change
frame every time the timer hits 0.2
and then once this frame is higher than
or higher than 8 which is the max amount
here
we're going to change it back to 1
and it's going to start over
now instead of saying quads here we can
just say
and frame
there we go
so now we just specify the frame it on
instead of an actual number meaning if
we right now
we'll we're supposed to be getting a
moving body
and that's because this is if it's not
idle and currently
our character is very much idle
so let's just for now set the idle to
false
so you just see a move around
as you can see we get a moving body we
can't really yet do anything because we
haven't given them any way to do
anything
now that we have that
what we can do is we can implement key
presses
so in the previous video i did show you
how to do key process so let's quickly
implement that
so if it's not idle
actually we don't even need to use this
if statement we can just say
if
love
dot keyboard
[Applause]
dot is down and we specify
uh let's say
b
if we specify d
the idle should become false
so we can just specify this idle
and you can make that equal to false
because this is being held down meaning
it should move
and then we can say
else well let's go i'll save here
and we can copy this
paste it here and we can make this equal
to a and we'll do the same thing so both
of these will do exactly the same thing
for right now
and in here we can just say true
and if none of them are like that we can
just say else
copy this and make it equal to
true again
like that
so now
this we can make a move
by specifying or by pressing a and d but
you'll notice it doesn't go back to the
idle frame
that is because we need to set
the idle frame
so when this doesn't get doesn't get
clicked we should set the idle frame
so basically here we can say
frame
is equal to
and
we can just specify one
because if we're not going to press it
we can just say one because then by
default it will be that one as you can
see now goes back to his idle frame
pretty simple
so yeah so if none of these two buttons
are clicked then we're going to set them
to idle and set this frame to one
we can maybe go here and here we see the
directional right
so we can get the direction and here we
can say
control c and just change this to
direction
and we can make this equal to right
and here we can make it equal to lift
now i can use this direction here to
specify where the character should be
moving to
so if
the whoa
direction that is right
so if the direction is equal to right
then we want to change the characters
go to so
we can say jack
dot x because i want to change the x
position of jack
is equal to
jack dot x
plus
anyways i just
paste that or damn it jack dot animation
dot speed
so basically we'll move further to one
side depending on where don't do that
depending on the speed we put here
cool
now we want to check if it's left as
well
so here we can see
else
and we just copy this if statement
paste it here but now we can make this
if it's lift
and we can say
minus
like that
now if we were to run this you'll notice
we can move forward and we can move
backwards that's pretty neat
if you want them to move forward or
backwards faster or slower
then here we can make that 30 that will
make it move forward or backwards faster
as you can see here
so the more you make this the more you
increase this
the faster it will move so you can see
now it's running
i don't have enough frames to cover
running that fast interesting
also i forgot to mention if you're
seeing a very bad frame rate on your end
just think that i am filming at 15
frames per second so you might see bad
frames compared to what i see
anyhow now that we have that
we can start making the character switch
which way it's looking towards because
currently the character just
runs forward backwards like it's not
normal to run backwards like that
so we need to make the character start
looking forward
so i'm just going to turn down the speed
here to something like 20 again
now here we can basically just get the
direction so i'm going to just copy this
if else statement
and now we can just draw the
character
let me just actually do an lc really
need the rest
now we can just draw the character to
the location we want it to
so if it's right we can just draw him as
normal
but if it's
lift you have to do a little extra to
make it him turn because currently he
doesn't turn
so we have to flip him because here he's
only facing one way so we need to kind
of flip him around to make him face the
other way
so right here after you specify the y
position
you can specify
zero
negative one one
quad width
and zero
now you might be wondering what are all
of these numbers
so this first zero here this specifies
the radius or the radians not the radius
this will make the character maybe let's
say flip himself
so instead of looking like that he's
facing upwards or facing downwards
that's this part right here that's the
radiance
this part right here
is the scale factor
to the x-axis and the scale factor to
the y-axis so this will make him flip
other way around
this right here is the offset as well as
this this is just to make him not look
weird while we're moving around and i'll
shoot her in a second so as you can see
we can now face two ways
so let's start with the first part if we
go here and make that 20 for example 20
radians not radius but radians
actually yeah as you can see it goes
crazy so once we switch him around he's
facing a way different way i find it
very funny actually
but yeah that's if we change that
because that will just kind of swap the
way he's looking towards
so whenever we don't press d it's going
to flip him around
this is just to keep him looking to his
specific location so if i were to remove
that negative there is going to look the
same way
no matter which way we turn actually
he's just going to disappear oh wait
that actually just moves him to the
okay
very confusing but yeah that just moves
him backwards so i guess my origin
offset i got that wrong probably anyways
i can make that back to negative one but
you'll anyways notice he didn't while i
was doing that so as you can see it
didn't quite turn either so if you were
to make that one it's not going to turn
[Applause]
you're going to kind of
run the same way looking
just from a different location as you
can see right there
and of course you can play around with
like making 0.4
seeing how it turns around now could be
interesting
see here
yeah now he just looks weird but
basically he's being flipped so he's
literally being completely flipped
around
you can play around with that use x to
kind of play around with it a bit more
to understand how it works i'm going to
leave it right there then here is the
same thing but just the other way around
so if we were to minus that now we will
do the y-axis as well so boom yeah yeah
i probably bring him down otherwise we
won't be able to see him
but yeah that will do it on the y-axis
as well
and here we just specified a quad width
to kind of get the offset and then the
height so these two aren't too important
we just need to put them there to so it
knows where to put it
and right now we have created a
character
they can actually walk around
and do as he pleases
and hello everyone if you're enjoying
this tutorial please leave a like and
subscribe for future tutorials
you probably want to see what game we're
going to build
so let me just
start up everything here and then boom
now here we go so this game is called
save the ball it's one of the very first
games i made when i try to create a game
so we have things like the fps counter
which is optional we have buttons
and yeah
now if we click on play game we
basically get this we get a little
counter here that counts how many points
we have this is based on seconds so
every second will give you a counter or
a point
and then if you have enough points then
the next level will start where there
appears another ball
now these balls will get faster and
faster with every level you make
for an example in this case
the first level is 15
and in the second level i believe is 30
yes
and there's another level at 40 i
believe and one at 60 and it just goes
on
but it's very basic game but it teaches
you things like collision detection
how dt works how to get the fps how to
draw shapes all of these things in live
2d
and then you also have your game over
screen with your score
and you can say something like replay if
you want and yeah
so that's the basics of the game
now if you do ever fall behind when
trying to play this game
you can always just
go to
well my bad
and always just go to github and this
link will be in the description if it's
not just
send a comment my way and i will
remember to put it here
now in this repository here youtube
projects on
you can go here to lua
and inside of it you'll see a folder
called save the ball
and in here you'll have multiple parts
we are on part one so everything we're
going to do is going to be right here so
if you fall behind or you want to maybe
go check you can come here
and part five would be the end result
okay cool
so let me just move this back to its
original screen
now here i have an empty folder i'm
going to create a new folder and call it
save the
ball
you can add spaces and whatnot i'm going
to keep it spaceless
and then in here i'm going to create a
new document or a new file and call it
main dot lua
now what do you need to know before we
start with this tutorial
you need to know love 2d i have a whole
course on it with like five parts or
something
that you can watch if you have not seen
those tutorials yet i do recommend you
do
because they are going to be very useful
you don't have to see them we are going
to cover a lot of things from the start
but i do recommend you do because it
will just make things so much easier if
you do
and you also need love 2d installed of
course
now i'm going to open up vs code in here
but you can open up whatever you want to
i just prefer coding in vs code
so here's vs code i'm going to close
this
and here you see there's my main.lua
file i created
cool
now
let's start by first importing love
so i'm going to say
local love
is equal to require
and love
now we can create our free functions we
need so function
love dot load
and this one will be love dot update
and this will be
love.draw
cool so as we know this will load
everything we need into the game
this will update the game
and this will draw everything to the
screen
now
we can save this and we can also open up
our terminal which i'm going to move to
the right
and now here we can say love dot
so it does nothing love2d here does it
absolutely nothing
so what i'm going to do you do not have
to do this but i'm going to do this
if you can just
there we go i'm going to create a new
file call it conf
lua
you do not need to create this
configuration file i however am going to
create it
because
i would like
my
window to pop up on the second screen
but you do not have to do this because
you might not have a second screen
so t dot window
dot display and we can make that
equal to two
this should open it up on this window
now we can just run
love dot again
and there we go
cool
now we can go back here
will you close that con file because i
don't need it open anymore
and yeah
so first i would like to set the title
of the window
so love dot window
dot set
title
and we can set it to save
the ball
now you could have also put this inside
of that conv.lua file if you saw my
tutorial on it you do know how to put it
in there although i want to show you the
alternative methods of doing these
things as well so i'm going to do it on
the unload of this love2d game
but if you want to you can do it here as
well because you can do this windows
display thing you can also do it in here
you can do the windows resizing in here
you can do everything you want in here
first thing i want to do is i want us to
be able to see the cursor
because if you might have noticed or as
you may have noticed
if i were to just move this back here
our cursor is a little white dot that's
our mouse
i want to code this into the game right
now
so let's do that let's code it in
so first thing we'll need is we'll need
to get the player location and that's
going to be that little circle
so local player is going to be equal to
this and you could also put this inside
of this load it's optional
then we need three things we need the
radius
going to make that equal to 20
within an x position and we're going to
make that equal to 30 and we didn't need
a y position and make that equal to 30.
you could make this equal to zero as
well
it doesn't matter i just like doing 30
because why not
cool
now we need to basically always update
that position so player
dot x
and player dot y
is equal to
the love dot
mouse
no mouse
dot get position
so this right here returns two values it
returns an x and a y position value
so we're storing the first value we get
into this player.x which is this and the
second value we get in the player.y
which is this
and we're doing it on every update
because every time the player moves the
cursor
an update will occur
now you may also notice
if i move around things might look a
little bit laggy but that's just because
i record on 15 frames per second
because that's just what i'm used to and
that's what i edit in
so things may look a bit laggy but on
your end it should not be looking laggy
you should be getting about 30 to 60
frames a second
all right
now here with the draw
we want to basically draw the circle
so i'm going to say
love dot
whoa
love.graphics.circle
i'm going to go
fill method
player.x
player dot y
and also player.radius
this will draw a circle where the
players x and y meets up and give it the
radius that we specified up here
now if we were to run this
we'll get a massive circle
now this is the end game circle
because we will have two states
that we're going to be using right now
and those two states will determine the
size of the player
so i'm going to create a local game
and it's going to be a table
with state
now we have a menu
and we're going to make it equal to true
now this will be the states we have
so for example we have a menu state if
it's a menu state it's going to show the
menu if it's the paused state it's going
to show a paused menu
now here i'm going to make that paused
i'm going to make that running
and i'm going to make this
ended
now currently
we want all of these to be false
and just this one to be true
that's for the menu state
now down here we want to specify
when should it do what size
so i'm going to go if
game.state
and we declared state up here
and then
in square brackets and in quotation
marks i'm going to say if it's the menu
state
so like that and you'll notice right
here
so if it's the menu state then we want
to
basically do this
and we just want to divide this by two
so if it's the menu state then it should
be the normal circle size but just
divided by two
i'm going to create another if statement
but this one will contain a not menu
and there's a reason i don't make this
an if else statement and you'll see in
the future tutorials
so here i'm just going to remove that
divided by two
now if we were to run the game
we'll see this a much smaller circle
that's because we're in the menu state
so the circle is half its original size
now if i were to change the menu to
false
and then the running to true
and my bad these two should be running
not menu
and now that we have that we can
actually just move that so divided by
two and we can just move it to the
bottom one
so now the first one is if the game is
in its running state meaning if the game
is being played give us the full
circle
otherwise in any other state have the
size of that circle
now if we run it we get the full circle
because it's in a running state
any other state we switch to no matter
what the state if we make this false and
we make the state
of paused to true
then you will get the smaller version as
you can see here so any other state will
give us a smaller version but running
will give us the big version
cool so i'm going to change this back to
menu state
now we need to hide
the cursor because as you can see the
cursor is still there
we don't really want the player to see
the cursor because it breaks the
immersion a little bit
so to get rid of the cursor
what you can do is here in the load we
can say
love dot mouse dot sit visible and you
can make this equal to false this will
make the mouse
invisible
so now
if you run it there's no longer a mouse
i can still move around but the mouse
itself is gone
now one last thing i do want to
implement is the fps counter because
let's say you're getting very bad fps
you might have coded something wrong or
something like that because the fps
should usually stay at around 60 fps
may be falling to 30 but usually it
should be 60 fps and we need a way to
see that
so here at the top because we don't want
the fps to block anything so it should
be at the top so it always if there's
something above it the fps doesn't go
over it anyways we can say love.graphics
dot print
print f
and here we can just say
fps
colon
and then dot dot is to concatenate the
string
love the timer
dot get
fps
and should be timer not time
and there we go now if we run it
we actually get an error
and i believe we get this error
because we should specify
our font
so
love the graphics the new font and i'm
going to specify 16
and let's specify an x and y location as
well so let's go 10 10.
so now we have a font size of 16 at its
x and y position is 10 and 10.
now if we run it we still get an error
and we just also need to specify where
it stretches to
so
graphics dot
with
should work perfectly fine and this
should be get with
[Applause]
as simple as
that now let's hope for the best there
we go we get a little fps
as you see it's around 60 fps and that's
where it's good
okay cool now just because i have a
little screen space i'm going to just
split this up into multiple lines
like that okay
so first we display the fps
then we set the font size
then here is the x position which we can
keep
here is the y position which i would
actually like to go
love.graphics
but get height
-10 and this will put it at the bottom
of the screen which is what i want i
want the fps to be at the bottom of the
screen just because it's less
distracting let's make that 30 just to
make a bit bigger or a bit higher
and then this basically sits how far as
you go before wrapping the text
now if you were to run the code
or fps is here at the bottom
and that's the very first part of the
tutorial
we didn't do a lot we just basically set
the game state
created the player
created the load the update and the draw
functions where the load sets the window
title
it makes the mouse invisible
it then we get to update and it updates
the player x and y positions then on
draw it puts the fps on the screen
and if the game stays running it draws a
circle with the player x and y position
and also the player radius
if the game state is not running then it
does the same as with running but it
divides the player size in two
so first of all
this right here this doesn't need to be
here you can actually remove that it
will run perfectly fine because by
default love will import it but i'm
still going to keep this here just to
get all of those errors away and whatnot
so yeah that's up to you
before we continue right
okay so in this tutorial we'll be
creating the enemy the enemy that's
going to kind of run after us
and whatnot
so first i would like to give our game
another
difficulty
and difficulty is going to be set to one
now the higher the difficulty
the
more difficult the game should be
as simple as that because the speed of
the enemies will be kind of dependent on
the difficulty as well
and then we want to create a table
called enemies
now this table isn't going to be used
too much in this tutorial because we're
only going to have one enemy
but once we get deeper into it this
table will be
containing all our enemies
so all our images are going to go in
here
we want to basically create our enemy
object
now we could do it in here but this file
is already going to be very big by the
end of this tutorial
so we want to create a new file
so right here we can right click new
file and say
enemy dot lua i'm going to give it a
capital case
e in its name to signify that this is an
object it's completely optional it's
just how i like to do things
if you have seen my tutorial on oop
you will probably know there's multiple
ways you can do oop in lua
and the first way is by using a table
the second way is by using a function
and a table
and there are more ways but i don't like
covering the others because they're kind
of difficult to understand in my opinion
so in this case i'm going to use
functions and tables
because i found those to be the most
easiest to use
so first we want to import love so local
love is equal to require
love
cool
and we don't need a semicolon
we're going to create a function and
we're going to call it enemy and this is
going to be our object for enemy
now at the end of this function we want
to say return
enemy
and this will basically export this
enemy when once we import it here so
this will be exported this function
right here it's just so this massive
function won't have to be found or used
or what not in here we don't have to see
that massive function in here because it
will be stored here so let's start with
very basics we're going to return
and whatever is inside of this right
here this table is going to be what's
returned to us
so first we want to set the level
to 1 by default
the radius
i'm going to make that equal to 20
then the x is going to be equal
to and there's going to be enemy
position for in case you didn't know
i'm going to make it let's say negative
and the y is going to be equal to
negative 50.
so basically this is where the enemy's
start position will be
we want it to be off the screen
and we're going to randomize where they
actually come from later
but currently we want it off the screen
because it should kind of just pop into
the screen as the level goes on so more
enemies will pop into the screen
cool
so these are the first
few things we'll use
next up we need to basically create
something to draw the enemy and
something to move the enemy
let's first try and move the enemy
because that's probably going to be the
most difficult part here is just moving
the enemy and that's going to be a
function inside of this
table so it's a function inside of the
table
and it's going to take in three items
self it again in my oop tutorial
because it's going to take in itself
we also want to get the player
well player
x and the player
y
you could pass in the entire player in
here but i feel like that would just be
kind of a waste of memory on the end of
the day because you're going to pass an
entire object where you can just pass
into values so i do recommend passing in
these two specifically just x and the y
cool now basically we want to make the
enemy move to the player
that's all we want to do very simple we
just want the enemy to go towards the
player
so it will just be basic if statements
so if
player at index x
or at x position
minus self.x and this self is
referencing this x right here so where
the enemy currently is
so if this value is more than zero
then
self dot
x
is equal to self dot x plus
self dot level
so what we are doing here is basically
if the player x
minus self.x if that is more than zero
and we're minusing here because
remember x starts basically at this
point right here
all right so future steve here and
you know i realized this wasn't a very
great explanation
so let me actually explain it better let
me just move this to number three
so
here we have basically our example
it's saying if the player at position
the x position of the player
minus
the x position of the enemy so let's
quickly go here and just draw it out
let's say the enemy is a red square
so this is the enemy
and but actually let's make it a circle
otherwise things might get confusing
okay so the enemy is a red circle
and the player
is a blue circle
just draw a nice circle here there we go
now
here we're saying
if the player at position x
okay
so the x position of the player would be
there at the center
that would be
the x position from here
all the way up until there that's the x
because remember x goes from side to
side
that's x
while y goes up and down
so this would be y
so then so just remember that
so this is the x right
now we go here if the player x
and
yeah so the player x minus self.x
and self.x would be the x of the enemy
so this right here
this would be the enemy x that's self.x
so
so this is the enemy south.x right there
now if we go here
we see
if it is more than zero
okay so let's put this in a mathematical
perspective
so let's say this right here is 63
the x position of the player is at
position 63
and the x position of the enemy is at
position 10.
now we are saying
player at position x okay so it's
63 whoa
just
right
minus self.x okay so it's minus 10
because remember self.x is the enemy so
it's 63 minus 10
right
and that will give us
so the position between this point
and this point is 53
that's basically what's being said here
and then we're saying if it is more than
zero and we know 53 is more than zero
then we're saying self.x
so this would be the player x or the
enemy x not the player the enemy x is
self.x everything self.x
is equal to itself
okay so self.x which is 10 let's let's
make this red because we're talking
about enemy so it's 10
because we're saying south of the x
okay so it's going to be itself so that
is self.x
plus its level
so plus
one
so we are saying south to x
becomes itself plus one so now self.x
will be eleven
because it will now be one step closer
to the enemy meaning this right here
will minus with one because 63
minus 11 and remember we got 11 with
that quick equation so that would be 11.
so 63 minus 11
is equal to 52.
so that will basically close the gap
between the enemy and the player
this might be a little bit confusing to
work with like a lot of the math might
be in game development but don't get
discouraged because the more you work
with it the more you'll understand it
so yeah back to the video now we also
want to do the other side of x so let's
say the enemy is to the right of the
player so
else if
and then player
[Music]
minus self.x
is less than zero
so basically
if the player x minus south.x because
remember x becomes more the more you
move right
so if the enemy is more right than the
player then this will be a negative
value this will return something
negative
so basically
let's say this right here
that's the enemy
and this right here oh yeah no not
yellow we can't see that
okay and this right there that's the
player
now let's say on x
so x here will be equal to two
and x here
would be equal to five
and remember this is the enemy that's
why he's red he is bad he's the enemy
bad
uh so let's just full screen this so
here we're saying if the player minus
self.x is less than zero
so
if the player so two
minus self.x and remember this is the
enemy so minus five is less than zero
then do something now two minus five is
negative three
so
this will return true so if the enemy is
to the right of the player
it will return true
and with the top one if the enemy was to
the left of the player it would return
true if the enemy you know it would be
the same thing just other way around
now here you can just say self dot
x is equal to self.x minus self.level
because we want to decrease the
exposition of the enemy
if you're having trouble kind of
wrapping your head around this don't
worry the first time it can be a bit
difficult i had the same problem when i
first thought of this like oh well my
brain can't wrap around this math many
worry it gets easier
and it's going to be the same thing but
for y
so if y let me just
change all of these to y
so if player y minus self.y is more than
zero
then sound.y becomes the same but plus
it's the same thing now it's just why
because if i were to open up drawing ooh
and basically remember y goes down
that's how y goes
so this is the player
and
this is the enemy
now let's quickly go check here
so if the
player y
minus the enemy y is less than zero so
the enemy y let's say is equal to
ten
because remember goes down so this would
be zero and this would be something like
20 or something
and here the y would be equal to let's
say five
now here we're checking
if the player y minus south of y is less
than zero
so is five minus ten is less than zero
and those two minus will be negative
five
right and that is less than zero
then
we're saying the wrong window
self.y becomes itself minus level so it
will decrease
so now we're saying okay move this
upwards so now the y
will
become nine because we're moving it
upwards
and this is going to run with every
update
so it's going to move the enemy closer
to the player with every update
so yeah let's continue to the next part
then
now you want to be able to draw the
enemy so that was going to be another
function called draw
it's going to be function
taken self doesn't have to take anything
else
and here we first want to set the color
love
dot
dot graphics
dot set
color
this is basically just going to set the
color of the thing we're going to draw
now i'm going to choose a very random
number
in order to figure this out so i'm just
going to say 1 0.5 and 0.7 i just random
number that popped up into my head
remember you could have also gone like
255 divided by two five five
and the same here you could have just
gone
what's the half of two five five
anyway the half of two five five divided
by five five so you could have done that
as well
but i preferred not to in this case
and then we're going to draw a circle
but you can make the enemy a different
shape than a circle i just find it
easier to do it as a circle
so love dot graphics dot circle and
we're going to fill
this circle we're going to put our
position self.x self
dot y and it's make the size of
self.radius
we're going to draw a circle
it's the x index the y index and then
we're going to give it this size right
there
and we set all of that up here
and then we can say love dot graphics
dot sit colors we're going to reset the
color back to white because that's going
to be your default background color you
don't have to set it here but i prefer
setting it here then having to set it
here in this draw function over and over
and over it also just brings it also
just prevents a bunch of bugs that could
possibly occur
okay so that's the most basic version
well later on for in letting jump in
from random size but i think for now
that should be fine
so this is the enemy
now here we have our enemy object
and now we can insert our very first
enemy so here in load we want to insert
our first enemy
table.insert and it's just a normal
insert method
and i'm going to insert it into the
enemies table right there and we need to
import enemy now that i think about it
so local
nm enemy
and you don't have to
[Music]
give it the same name
i just like using this name and we're
going to say
enemy
and it should be capital e
that just means basically import enemy
from this file right here
that's what we're saying right here
cool
now that we have that
we can go here
and we can say at index one
insert
our first enemy
and it should not have a capital e
because we gave it a lowercase e as a
name or we should have there we go
lowercase e not capital e
okay but you could give it a capital kc
name i just preferred going lowercase
cool
and that will insert our first enemy
now here an update before we can
actually try and use this enemy
we need to basically for
i and yeah let's just like that
for i
equals one
and let's also remove all that
until the number of enemies
and then do so basically for every enemy
inside of this enemies table currently
we only have one but later we'll have
more we want to go
enemies
or enemy
or yeah enemies actually and then add
that index so index i
colon move take note i'm using a colon
here and not a dot
and then here we can just pass in the
player
dot x and the player
dot y why am i passing these in because
here in move we're taking player x and
player y we do not have to pass in self
because self gets passed in for us
cool so for every enemy do this you can
also create an update function instead
that will instead of just moving it it
will do all of the updating for the
enemy that could also be something you
can rather implement instead of move but
this game is so basic i'm just going to
have a move function and not an update
cool now we need to draw the enemy
let's go here into
if the game state is running right
then we can go
and above the player because we kind of
want the player to overlap with the
enemy or you could do this below it
doesn't really matter that much and
actually i'm just going to copy this
because it's going to be the same code
just a different command so boom
and here i'm just going to say
draw so this will draw every enemy
inside of the table
okay so let's try to run this and see
what we get
love dot
let's see
and you know what we're not getting
anything
it's because currently we're in the menu
state and everything just gets drawn if
the state is not the menu
so
yeah let's go there and just go false
and in here we can just say running is
true
there we go now it should work
as you can see there the enemy comes to
get us but currently nothing happens so
the enemy just stops once it gets on top
of us
but it should later on like
stop the game if the enemy touches us
but you'll also notice
the enemy always comes from the same
side
and that's very boring because we want
the enemies to actually come from
different sides to make the game more
interesting
so
to do that we can just implement a
little bit of math
and this map will basically make the
enemy come from different sides
now
here at the top i'm going to declare
four variables
local well local dice
local
x and
y i take those these have underscores
you didn't have to give them names of
underscores i just find it much easier
to work with them if they have that and
also local and an underscore radius
cool
these two are not going to have any
values associated with them at the
moment radius will make 20 as a default
but you can later on they modify this
radius to give you
more
interesting
sizes so let's say you want different
size enemies that could be kind of neat
now this radius here i'm going to paste
it here
this x here i'm going to paste it here
because it's going to be modified that's
why here i'm going to paste it here
so these are all going to be modified
except for radius so these are all going
to be modified and these two will now be
set here
and we're doing this because we want the
self to work when we want these
because this is not part of the table
it's part of the function
but it's not part of the table that's
being returned to us but it is part of
the function
so this one won't be returned to us we
won't be able to access these values
but we will be able to access any values
in here it's something you have to wrap
your head around because it can be a
little confusing
okay and this dice will basically
determine from which side will the enemy
appear from this side
from this side from this side or from
this side
so i'm going to make this a
math.random
and we're going to make it 1 and 4.
and before we forget
in the main.lua file not in the enemy
but in the main.lua file
we want to just math.random
seed and we want to just give it os.time
now what we are doing here is we're
basically saying
every second
change the
seed we're going to get so whenever the
user
boots up the game
their random numbers will be more random
because if we don't add this then the
enemies will always start from the same
place
and we don't want that
because currently as you might have seen
in my random video the random numbers
don't really change they kind of stay
the same
unless we seed them so at least we see
today
if you don't understand that yet i do
recommend you go watch my tutorial on it
i do have an entire crash course on it
after all
cool
now we need to basically give the dice
functionality so we can say if
dice
is equal to 1
then underscore x is equal to
math.random so we're going to give it a
random position on x-axis so anywhere
random here
so
there we go
master random
and an underscore radius
because we wanted to start at minimum at
the radius so the
the enemy will always be hidden no
matter where it is on the x-axis
and then love dot graphics dot get
with
and this will just further work so it
will give us basically a random number
between the radius so 20 and the width
that's given to the window
and then we want to say
y
well you can actually do it underneath
y is equal to
minus so negative
underscore
underscore radius
times four
so if the dice is one
and it should be underscore y
x can be anywhere on top of this right
here anywhere
but y
specifically
will be minus the radius
so remember it's going to basically be
here so y 0 is here so y minus the
radius would go up
so minus the radius will basically mean
hide the entire
ball hide the entire enemy and it
retimes it by four so it's going to be
basically being hidden four times itself
this will also give it a little bit of a
time you have to wait once the knee
level starts before it actually starts
to jumping in so it doesn't just go into
the screen immediately
you'll kind of understand it once we
actually use this
so now we can just say
else
and i'm just going to copy this right
here
all right the little disturbance i can't
remember where it was but okay yeah i
believe it was just like this and boom
okay
now else if the dice is equal to two
it's going to basically be the same
thing i'm just going to copy these else
if's because we're going to have kind of
a lot of them except for the last one
the last one will just be else
and this one we can make three
and in the else would be if it's not one
two or three then just give it this one
by default
okay
so with the second one it's going to be
a little bit different
it's going to basically be swapped
so x will contain this
and y will contain
this
and then here we can instead of say get
with we can say get height
now why is this like this why did we
swap it around here well if the dice is
two
we're saying okay x should be here
but
it should be minus its own width
so
basically if you hide itself times four
so it's going to go to the side here
four times itself its own width and then
with why we're saying okay
find any place from
this part right here
right
and
just anywhere towards the height
you don't necessarily have to specify
this radius here you can make the zero
because remember it's just going to come
from a random side anyways
but basically it's going to be able to
come in from anywhere on this side right
here so if the dice is 2 anywhere here
if the dice is 1 anywhere here from the
top
if the dice is free however
then
we're going to do everything the same
but
this one right here this y
we're going to say love dot graphics dot
get height
plus
and then we're going to say radius times
four
whoa radius times four
and known minus
so why are we saying this here
well basically we're saying okay if the
dash is free x can be anywhere from this
right here
and they were saying okay
the y should be the height
plus
itself times four so anywhere from below
here
so now it's not anywhere from the top
but anywhere from the bottom like from
here
that's what we did here we basically set
the y to the bottom of the screen
and then here it will be basically the
same
as with if dice were two
so we can do like that
but now the difference is and remember
to remove this
minus symbol right there
x here we can just go and
well no no no no no
we just go and do this
and we can say
love dot graphics dot get with
plus
and now what we're saying is okay it can
come anywhere from this side right here
so now it can come the the ball the
enemy can come from anywhere inside of
this window here not this one but the
game window itself
so you can either come from here the top
which we did first
or it can come from the side which we
did second
or from the bottom which we did third
and or from this side right here from
the right side which we did last
and now these x and y values as its
default values that that ball first gets
comes from here and this will be
different for every ball that's the nice
part because every time we create a ball
is going to execute all of this
and then it's going to return this to us
but this x and y would have changed and
if you want you can also change the
radius
so yeah
now if we were to run the game
it comes from down the part down here
okay let's run it again and see it's
happening again
oh
attempt to perform micro let me go get
field a function value so this is enemy
18 let's see here
ah there we go that should have
those little bracket things there
okay let's see and it starts from this
side now okay one more time just to make
sure we have everything
it starts from the top
so that's the nice fact every time you
start the game it starts from a
different angle which is pretty neat
and i believe that's all we need to do
for the enemy
all right
so first we want to go to the main.lua
file this main one right here and we
want to make this true because today
we're going to be working on the menu
so we want to be able to see the menu by
going here to true
this shouldn't do much except for
resizing your cursor
so make sure it does
now we're going to create another
table here called local
buttons
and these buttons will basically contain
all of the buttons for all of our
different states so menu underscore
state
will then become
an empty
table
cool now that we have that let's go here
to the side and just create a new file
i'm going to call this
button.lua
it's going to be a button class
and this button class will basically
contain all of the things we'll need for
buttons
so
local love which you know is optional
but i love doing this
require
and we can just say love
you can create a function
called
button
and
yeah simple as that
now we want quite a few things we're
going to mess around with too many
things just yet
but i can tell you from the bat our
button will probably have text on it and
we probably want to set the text when we
create the button so something like text
and we also need to be able to execute a
function
so funk because when we click the button
it should be able to do something and
this func we pass in is what it should
be able to do
this befit isn't too great i don't love
it that much but it does get the job
done and that's what we want at this
moment
we also want to be able to pass an
optional parameter into the function
so we can include func param
and then we want to include the width
and then the height of the button
okay so next we can just say return and
it's going to return a table
this table is going to return will
contain width
and that's going to be either the width
passed in
or 100 by default
and then we want a height which will be
the same thing
so like that
so either the height passed in or 100
then we're going to create a function
and this function will be able equal to
the function passed in
to func passed in
or
to a function that doesn't do much it's
just an anonymous function it's not
going to do anything really i'm just
going to print
this
button has no
function attached
as simple as that if you wanted to you
can even make it shorter and make it one
line like that it's optional you can
make it more than one line i kind of
like it as one line because it just does
a quick one-liner
and then the function parameter
will be
the function parameter passed in if
there's no function parameter passed in
it will be nil and no parameter will be
passed in
and then the text will be equal to text
or
no text
then the buttons
x position will be equal to zero
the button
y position will be equal to zero
and then the text on the button
should be at position zero and in the
text y of the button should be at
position zero as well
exit this is a lot of things we're just
setting by default you don't have to
worry too much about it
and then of course you want to return
the button down here before i forget
because i'm going to forget what i did
now
cool now we are going to do things like
making the button clickable and what not
but first we want to be able to draw the
button that's the most important part
right now because we need to kind of get
the button just on to see that it works
so let's create a draw function for the
button which will be a
function
and this function takes itself
and then
the buttons x position the buttons y
position and in the text x and the text
y position
now
i might be putting it here like the
button x y text x and x y might be able
to be passed in
from here so these four attributes but
if you wanted to you could pass them in
here
the reason i'm doing this is if you ever
later want to animate the button so the
button moves from one position to
another position
then you can do it from here
you can when you draw it you can just
move the button x and y positions as you
please
instead of having the x and y positions
kind of set as soon as you create the
button this is personal preference i
like doing this you don't have to do
this you can put all this you can put it
in here there's no problem with that
i just want to do it here
and this also keeps this from kind of
cluttering up and having 50 000
freaking things it needs to take in
because now it's being split into two
cool
now here we want to say self dot
button
x and of course you could have made this
a table as well but we're already in a
table so having another table within a
table is just
uh
you know personal preference yet again
and that can be equal to button x so
this button x right here
or self
dot
button x
so this button x here or this button x
here one of these two self.button x is
referring to this button x don't get too
confused here
so just as i said you could put the
button x and y up here as well and it
will be set here as well
anyhow
and we can just copy that and do the
same for y so
self dot button y
like that
then here we can basically set the text
position so
if
text x so the text does exist the x
position of the text which is passed in
here
then we can say
self.text
at position x
is equal to text at position x
plus self dot
button x
else
self dot
text x is equal to self
dot button x
now you could have done this yet again
in one line
where you basically check if this exists
and if it does exist you do your things
you could have done like this but i find
it to be a lot less confusing and just
so much easier to also understand if
you're reading it if you do it like this
where if it's take six do all of this
otherwise do this instead of using this
or way here which could work
but i'd rather not because that's going
to be prone to bugs because i'm not too
good at reading that
and in here we could of course just go
text
y
and in here we can say button at y
like that now here we're just saying the
text on the button so this is the text
that exists on the button
if the x
exists so if this exposition is being
passed in for it then
make the original one here
make it equal to what is passed in
plus the button x
we're saying the button x here because
the button may be 30 pixels to the right
but the text isn't just going to be
placed onto the button automatically so
we'll need to tell the text to add that
x so we're going to have our button x
and then we're going to need to add to
it that's this here i'll show you how
this works in a second once we actually
draw this to the screen just so you can
kind of get an idea
now take that this bottom order i'm
going to do here is very important so
love the graphics
dot set color
and you can pass in your own color the
color you want for every single button
but in this game i'm just going to keep
all the buttons the same color 0.6
0.6 0.6 is going to be a lightish color
then we want to draw the button so
love.graphics.rectangle
and if you're still a little bit touchy
on this right here don't worry i am
going to explain it
i just want to kind of give you
something you can visualize when i
explain it
and we can just say
fill it because we want to fill it so we
don't see the background color of the
game
and then
self.button x position edit x
self dot
button y
self dot with
and itself dot height so this is where
the button is going to be drawn to
and how it's going to be drawn
okay so that's for the button we can do
that now we need to do the text because
remember the text isn't really part of
the button it's its own thing so we need
to do it here as well so love
dot graphics
dot
dot sit color and we're going to make it
equal to black
now you can make it a different color
but i feel like this color works
perfectly with this lightish grayish
color
then we want to love dot graphics dot
print
and we want to print self dot
text
dot
and then self
dot text
at position x and then self dot text
and position y
taking it i'm using self everywhere
because we want to on the end of the day
use this everywhere in our code this
will just make things so much easier so
whatever you do do not change these
values here or any values
you sit in here try and keep it as much
as possible to these globalist values we
have here
because believe me it's going to solve a
lot of problems later
and then we just want to reset
this is optional you can do it somewhere
else but i'm going to reset the color
here to be white
so that's going to be my always fallback
default color it's going to be pure
white
okay we have created the button and the
button can now be drawn
now here we want to basically create the
three buttons
for our game i'm going to create just
one button for now
and here we have our menu state button
so we want to create it on here so in
the load
we are going to
go here
so here with the unload
i'm going to create a button
or go to our buttons say dot menu state
and then i'm going to add a play
game button
now this play game button is just going
to be a button which we need to import
let me go here and just import the
button
and here we can just make that
cool
now here we can make that equal to a
button which we just imported from this
file we have here make sure to export
the button by saying return button
and in here we can pass in our value so
first it wants text
so here we can just say play game
because that's what it does it tells you
to play the game i'm going to pass in
nil nil because we do not have a
function or a function parameter we want
to pass in
then i'm going to pass in
let's say 50 and 50.
we're going to position it nicely later
so they're going to be the x and the y
position of the button
now down here
where we
draw the game
and here it says game.state running
we want to add an
else
if
because i'll save the game dot
state is not running
but instead it is of menu
and this should just be in square
brackets not circular brackets
so else if the game state is in menu
state
you want to go to buttons
dot
menu state dot play game and we want to
say colon draw to call the draw function
and now in here we want to specify a
bunch of things so i wonder if yeah
there we go so the button x position
you can get 10
the button y position 20
and then we can just maybe say
10 and 20 like that
just as an example
now it's not going to give us anything
great and was this really x and y what
was this
this was
oh the width and height so it's going to
be 50 with 50 height and then here it's
just going to draw it at position
10 and 20 and then it takes is going to
be at position 10 and 20 as well but not
the same 10 or 20 as this button because
we changed that and i'll show you that
in
a second because i know it's going to be
confusing
and take note this is still here this if
statement because if the game state is
not running we just want the circle to
be smaller so this the circle should be
smaller
in this menu state
and the circle should be smaller in this
running state or it should be larger in
this running state
anyhow
let's go here
and here we go so we have a button not
really the best it's looking kind of uh
kind of small there
so let's just make the button a bit
bigger
so i'm going to go here to the above
where it's 50 50.
allow me to maybe make it a bit longer
so 120 and maybe a bit shorter
or bit less
tall
so 40.
ah now that does look much better
okay
and then here we have a play game
and you'll notice it looks kind of weird
now if i were to show you something
interesting here so
what do we have here we have the button
x and y position so let's make this text
x and y position
uh five and five just so i can show you
what's happening because this is a kind
of
part that may have been confusing to a
lot of you
as you can see here it's five from this
left side
and five from the top
now if we go back to button here
and we don't do this we just say okay
just make them what is passed in that's
all you have to do just make them what
we pass in or actually no let's actually
uh change this up so go like that
and we uncomment these
there we go
so if we just did this
i want to show what would have happened
so we just said self.txtx and self.texty
is what we pass in
then
you can't see it
because the text is now five pixels from
here and five pixels from the top
not from the but the button width and
height but from the top so
that breaks a lot of things so we change
the text color then instead so here it's
zero zero zero zero we can just make it
one one one one then
because all these finger pop-ups there
we go one
then you'll see it's right there
now we don't want that right we don't
want that that is why
we have this right here
this self.button x so even if you don't
pass in anything it's going to be at the
same location our button starts at
so for example if i were to comment all
of this back in again
and i want to not pass in a text x or y
which will run this then
then
it would look like this
as you can see it's right there at the
button but not at the game so that is
why we did that we didn't want this to
start here at the game we always wanted
to start at the bottom x and y positions
cool
now let's make this
maybe like a 1710 that should look good
for right now
yeah that looks perfectly fine later on
we'll change the font a little bit to be
a bit bigger and just match the button
better but for now i think that's fine
so yeah there's our first button play
game
let's create two more buttons
and i'm going to just go here
now this second button is optional
because i'm not going to code it it's
going to be your homework at some point
so settings
so it's going to be the settings button
and then we want an exit
game button
and in this button we'll say
settings
and it's going to have the same width
and height
and in this button right here it will be
exit
game or just even exit if you want to
and then the same with that and because
all of them are the same width and
height you could always make this the
default width and height like here we
redo this you can make it the default
here
that would actually be a good idea
now we can code the exit button right
now we can give it its function so love
dot event
dot quit
because this will quit love
so once the button is click
it will run this code or we haven't
really implemented that but that's what
it should do
take note all these are from the menu
state because they will all be displayed
once the menu state is true
okay
now we can go down here again and we can
draw the game so
let's go like this
and let's draw
settings
exit game
and
let's see how do they look what do we
see
like we just see x again because that's
what's been drawn last
so we can just make them all go down a
bit we can leave the rest to be exactly
the same so we can say 70 and here we
can maybe like 120.
and that looks fine to me at least
so now we have a play game a setting and
an exit game they don't do anything if
you click on them but now we have that
now we want to go back to the button
because we need to
make some function that will allow us to
press the button to click the button
so we're just going to check if it's
been pressed and we'll do the press
doing
on the main in the main file
so here we can just do something such as
check pressed
right
and in this will be a function
and here we can just put a comma
cool
now this will take in a self
a mouse
x position so where the mouse currently
is the x position the mouse
y position so where the mouse is
currently at the y position and in the
cursor radius so if we ever change the
cursor size we don't have to worry about
changing it here as well so cursor
radius
cool
now here we can just create a basic if
statement so if mouse
of the exposure of the mouse plus the
cursor
radius
is more or equal to self.
button
x
so let me actually draw that because i
think this will become a little bit more
difficult to understand
so let me just go like this
so we are saying let me just make this a
good
uh easily seeable color on white
so this is our cursor right
and this is our button i'm going to say
b for button
now
if i go here you'll see the mouse x
position
okay so the mouse x position and
remember this is our mouse that right
there is our mouse
but remember our mouse if i can just
make this red maybe
our mouse is here in the center that is
actually where our mouse is that's where
the point of our cursor is you might
have remembered from the first video
where when we drew this you would have
noticed the mouse cursor thing
it's like that
so that's her mouse
right there
now
we go back here
there we go we say if the mouse x
okay
so this is x remember so that's x and
this is y so because remember this can
make a y ish shape that's why this is y
this is x
so if the mouse x position
uh
let's go like that so this is the mouse
x right so boom
the mouse x position right there let's
make that 32 for example
right
plus the cursor radius
so
this part right here
this is the cursor radius
because remember a circle
not a good circle there a circle
has a radius
that right there that's the radius of a
circle
so take note that term is very important
that's the radius it's only half of the
circle so this right there so this x
plus the radius and let's say
this whole circle
is
20 right
so the radius would then be 10 because
of the whole circle from here
to here if that whole circle is 20
and the radius is half of the circle
then it would be 10 that would be the
radius
so 32 plus 10
that's 42.
so we're saying
if
42 is more or equal to the button x
position
so let's say this button exposure which
is obviously further than that circle so
that would be this button x position
which would be like this
this is the button x position i should
actually choose a different color at
this point
let's go maybe something like a bluish
color i hope everyone can see that
nope it's good like that
okay so this is the button x the button
x we can say
is
62.
this would then be false
because
here we're seeing if it's more or equal
to
more or equal to very important
it's not more or equal to 62. it's 42
it's less than 62.
so if we move our cursor so the cursor
is let's say like this
so you'll notice the end of the cursor
is inside of the button
this within remember that's the radius
right
and this is 32 and let's say
i know
this right here that part right there
so from
this point right here to this part right
here
is let's say
45 because remember it's not like a lot
there
so that's just 45
then we can just add the radius to it to
get back to the middle
that would be 10 so we can make that 55
right
now we can add the radius again because
we're at center or we could have just
added this full 20 that would have
worked well but we add the radius again
we'll get 65
so remember this right here that's 45
this whole length here that's 45
because this is what number we made up
at this point
and then we add 20 to get the from this
point of the circle to this point or two
tens to get two radiuses because two
radiuses makes one of the circle because
the radius is half of the circle very
important to know
and then we get 65. 65
is more
than 62.
thus we are pressing the button
we are now pressing the button that is
what all of this math does if most of
this math went over your head
don't worry too much about it you can
kind of figure it out on your own as you
play with this but basically
if a part of the circle no matter how
big the apartment if a part of this
circle we have
goes over the button
this right here that's the button
then we should say it's clicked
so that this is just for the ex
right
simple as that
now we also need to do it the other way
around
so if we go back here and let's actually
can we create a new
no i don't know how to create a new one
control n doesn't work okay that's fine
let's say we have our
this is our circle
and it's our button
so this button
now we need to do the same thing
but for if the circle does this
so we need to do the same thing
because we need to take note we should
not press this button we should not be
able to press it if our circle is here
and the button is here
or
if our button is here and the circle is
here
we should only press the button
when the circle
is basically on the button
a part of the circle should be on the
button but if a part of the circle is
not on the button no matter if it's to
the left or to the right we should not
click that button
only if a part of that circle is on the
button should we click the button
and oh okay it did make more okay good
to know good to know so now we need to
do the same but the other way around
so i'm going to just put that inside of
brackets to make it easier to read and
i'm going to say and start another pair
of brackets and just paste that in here
now we want to minus the cursor radius
here
and we want to say instead of more than
or equal to we can say less than or
equal to and i recommend if you kind of
struggle
viewing what we're doing right now if
you're kind of struggling seeing what's
happening
draw it out
drawing out math is probably the best
thing you can do because that's what we
just did and if that helped you to
understand at least the first part then
that means if you draw it out for
yourself then you will be able to
understand the second part as well
and here we can just add with so plus
with
self-serve if that is now this self.with
remember
refers
to the width of the button
so
let me actually draw this again to draw
so here we're saying
if the mouse x so here's the mouse and
let's list this mouse x right right
there that's where the mouse x is
so let's say x is equal to
32.
right
if that
is a less than or equal to
this button x right so this button x
right here it starts there that's where
the button x starts right there
plus the button width so it can even
plus the button voice so this is where
it's going to be this dot right there
that side that corner
if it is less than that
and we're minusing the cursor radius
because we want this point so if this
point
is less than this side right here then
this x
this x right there if it's less
then we want to do something so if
so let's make this blue
so if this part right here
is
past this part so if it's more than this
x location because remember x is just a
position
and this red part right here is below
this red part right here
then we want to call the button
this can be very confusing and i myself
got confused here but this math is very
important to understand because in all
future games this is how you can code a
button
anyhow so i hope you understood this
part if you don't you can still follow
along without any problem because
believe me i'm also trash when it comes
to math
cool now we need to do the exact same
thing or we want to do it for y
so here we can just change mouse x
to mouse
y
right and then we can do the same here
button x but button y
and instead of with we want to say
height
we still keep the cursor radius because
remember it's just a circle
meaning if we go from the center of that
circle
and we add
the circle radius whether it be
left right or up or down
then we'll get the edge of that circle
location
on x or y axis depending on which we
choose so it should still have the
cursor radius
so if it's more or equal to
the self dot button y
and
mouse y
minus cursor radius
is less than or equal to
self dot button y
plus self
dot x or sub height
then
and take note we're using height
with y and width with x
because with is left to right
height is top to bottom
just like how y is top to bottom and x
is left to right
that's why we use those two respectively
okay there we can now we know the button
is inside
or the cursor is inside of the button we
know that for a fact now
so we can just start executing stuff so
self dot func param so if the function
parameter exists if one was passed in
right then would you call sao
they want to call
self.funk
and we'll do pass in self.funk
parameter like that
else
we want to do the same thing
but this time we just don't want to pass
in a parameter so the parameter was not
passed then we don't care about it
and just like that we have implemented a
press operation for our button
all right
that was quite a long one too
we are almost at the end though so don't
get discouraged just yet
cool
now i'm going to create a mouse pressed
function so whenever the mouse is
pressed now you can do that within draw
with an update within load i'm going to
create my own entire function for it
which is possible with love 2d
i didn't do this in the tutorial because
i kind of wanted to keep it for this
tutorial so if you didn't don't notice
this from the tutorials i had don't
worry i did skip it for a reason
so you can just say function love dot
mouse
pressed and i find this to be a lot more
powerful than the one we had in the
tutorial
meaning this x
y
button
is touch
presses
so all of these gets passed in for us we
get the x position of our cursor the y
position of the cursor where the right
button was clicked the left mouse button
was clicked or the middle mouse button
was clicked i think there's probably
support for other
mouse buttons like the ones you get on
the side of some mouse and stuff like
that i just don't know how to work with
them
and then we have is touch so
basically
is it a touch screen you know it's a
touchscreen mobile support
so it is touch
and it presses so how many presses i
believe
so basically if they touched with their
finger and here's how many times they
touched or how many times they clicked
or whatnot we are not going to implement
touch screen support in this game
because i think that's i don't know i
just think that's something you could
probably do if you wanted to but it's
quite a lot of debugging especially if
you didn't have a touchscreen yourself
anyhow
we're gonna just say if not game.state
is
running
because remember we don't really want
the mouse to be able to click
anything if the game state is running
the mouse buttons shouldn't do anything
while the game is running
then
so if the game is not running then
you're allowed to do anything in here
because if
button
is equal to one meaning if we pressed
the left mouse button
so not the button that brings up this
one but the other button the one if i
click like this if we click this button
then do something
so if
game.state so if it's the menu state we
want to specifically
use the menu buttons
then go four
index
and we need a value
and we're going to say
buttons dot
menu state so we're going to loop all of
the buttons in the menu state that's why
we created it here because we're going
to look for all of this buttons inside
here you check if they have been pressed
that's why it's in the menu state only
if it's the menu state this is also to
save a little bit of performance
we're going to say
buttons
dot menu state
dot for that dot when you say position
index
so that should be
dot
so button stop menu state at this index
so let's say the play game button for
example and then we want to just say
check pressed for that button
and you want to pass in the x the y
and the x and y is basically the cursor
x and y that we're passing in
and in the player
dot radius
and a player radius is coming from
here there we go player radius which in
this case is actually 20.
so yeah that's the radius it's
half of the whole circle
anyhow so you pass that so it's going to
check if any of those buttons were
pressed so if i were to now run this
and let's try x again because that's
currently the only button that has
anything implemented
ah and we're actually getting everybody
worked
so
button.loo at 17 okay
button lua
at 17
um attempt to perform algorithmic on
field height angle value
so let's see here
height self dot height which is null
value oh probably just spout it
incorrectly there we go
actually i think height might be
spouting correctly i don't know i can't
grammar for the life of me now let's try
it again
and it worked our game exited without
any problem
cool now let's quickly work on the start
new game function and then we're done
then we can then we can
turn it off for today
so
i like to do that underneath
i don't know actually i think i'll do it
above load
and maybe i'll even put this mouse press
right here i'll put it above it as well
why not
and we can just do that boom okay
now here i'm going to create a local
function
and i'm going to say start
new
game right
and then it doesn't take in anything we
can just say start new game
then game dot
state
at
menu
whoops my man yeah at menu
right
then becomes false so we're setting the
menu state equal to false
and currently because we only have the
menu and the running state we're not
going to worry too much about other
states
but now we can set this running state
equal to true because
we're starting a new game so we should
start running the game
and in here
we can also
just create our first enemy as well so
this part right here we can completely
remove it and just move it up
so now here we just boom like that
now your start new game is pressed we're
going to insert a new enemy into our
game and we're going to set the menu
state to false and then the running
state to true
okay now let's actually just implement
that here so where it says nil
we can say start new game without the
parentheses take notice with other
parentheses because otherwise it's just
going to execute before it gets passed
in
and
yeah then one last thing
this is going to become more helpful
later in the game but we can just say if
game
that state
is
running so the game state is running
then we want to do this this is so the
enemies don't try and keep chasing the
player if the player is like in the menu
or the game is paused or anything like
that because believe me it's going to be
very funny but the player isn't going to
like that
that they can still lose
while in the menu or something like that
anyhow so we just say they're only
allowed to move
if
the
player or if the game stays running
cool now let's try and
play game
as you can see not only does our player
grow but the enemies now start following
us as well
that's pretty neat
so we did quite a lot in this tutorial
well done if you're still following
along
so basically
we created our first buttons we
implemented touch folders buttons we
implemented the
drawing the buttons
and then we implemented the actual
functions of the buttons
and that's that
so let's actually start with the enemy
let's actually try and improve the enemy
so first off i would like us to actually
now receive a
level now level is basically going to
allow us to say what level every enemy
should be
because we can have 10 enemies on the
in the game like just coming at you but
the problem is without the right
leveling method those enemies will just
be kind of the same thing will it be
difficult or anything like that
so what we can do is we can go here
where it says level and instead of
saying one we just make level
equal to level
and just in case we didn't pass in a
level but usually you would be passing
in a level but just in case we were not
we can just say
or let's say one
and you could also if you want to make
this underscore level instead of level
to make it a bit easier to understand
although i think this is perfectly fine
you can even rename this to be lvl
instead
all right
so that's all we're going to do here for
now we will be getting back to this
later but right now i think it's
perfectly fine
you probably want to know how we're
going to kind of get the enemies and
stuff to come in
so i'm going to show you an example of
what we will basically be doing
so here
i have
basically what we're going to be doing
so when we say play game we will have a
little scoreboard here that is going to
count
and then once this scoreboard gets to a
specific amount like 15
it's going to spawn another enemy with a
higher level the higher the level the
faster the enemy will be
a good thing you might want to do is you
might want to make every enemy a
different color maybe randomly generated
or something like that
and once the enemy touches you
the game ends we'll later on implement
an end screen or a game over screen and
whatnot
but that's the basics of what we're
going to implement so we need to
implement some sort of
point
system all right so here instead of game
we can actually implement it here
so the amount of points we have
we can make equal to zero at start you
could also put this inside of the player
here
so then the amount of points the player
has but you could also make the amount
of points there currently is in the game
so whichever floats your boat best
and in here we could say levels
and this will basically be whenever an
enemy spawns you can either have set
levels like i am doing now or you can
have randomly generated levels or levels
at every specific interval
something like that but i'm going to
just going to have four levels
five include the very first level
and these levels will basically just be
15 30 60 120 so if you have these points
so 15
60 and 120
like that
so if the player has 15 points then a
new enemy will spawn
if there are 30 points then a third
enemy will spawn because you have the
first enemy which is from zero to 14.
they have a second enemy from 15 to 29 a
third enemy from 30 to 59 and in the
fourth enemy from 60
to
119 and then the last enemy at level 120
and above
so let's implement the points
so here with new game we can just say
game dot points
is equal to zero so this is basically
whenever we start a new game we're going
to set the points to zero
and now with this enemies here we
actually want to do something but
different we want to go enemies
so we want to create an entirely new
enemies table so we're going to clear
the previous enemies table
and we can just say enemy
and then at level one
like that
that means we can remove that line there
because we have our enemy here this will
be the very first enemy at level one you
can do it like this or you can have it
split up into multiple lines
so right here where we do the love dot
update
inside of the
game state or inside of the if game
state is running this part right here
we want to just say
game dot points
is equal to game dot
points
plus dt
so this will basically increase the
points constantly but with dt so
0.016 or
0.032
however so basically about every second
you'll get one point
now when we go down to draw
we can find a way to actually display
this
to the user
so here and if game state is running we
can actually put it just above enemies
so the enemies can move over it
but you can put it below enemies as well
we can say love dot graphics
dot print if and this will print text to
the screen
i'm gonna say
math.floor
game dot points
and this will display the game points
but to the lowest value so if we have
3.14
it will display three if we have 3.5
it will display three if we have 29.99
it will display 29.
so it's basically like math.round but
just always downwards and never upwards
we can then
specify a font because with love
graphics print
you might notice we need to specify a
font
so let's just say love dot let's just
copy this
now we want it to be bigger than
something like that fps
because it has to attract more attention
than the fps so we can make this about
instead of 16.
in here we can basically
put our location so 0 10
and then we can tell it how long to
spend so love
dot graphics
dot get with
and then we can also just specify center
so all of this does a lot
but basically you can think of it as
displaying the text
at the center of the screen
i'll show you how this looks in a second
so let's actually try to run this and
see if it works so love dot
alright we say play game
and here it does so it's here at the
center of the screen near the top
and
yeah it just counts about every second
i believe this zero here is the x if we
were to make this something like 90
and we run it
then you'll notice it's a bit more to
the right
so the 0 is basically the x and this 10
is basically the y
cool and then this here just
specifically wanted to be basically
aligned to the center
nice
now before we get to the enemy i would
like to implement a better way to change
the game state because currently the way
we change the game state we have to
constantly go around and we have to
change a bunch of things manually which
isn't what we want we want to make it as
simple as possible so in the future when
we return we never forget about
something we might have to change if we
change this value here we or if we added
this here
all right
so let's say
local and we create a function we can
call it change
game
state
i can take in state
and here we can say game dot
state
menu
so the game state is menu
or we actually just make it state is
equal to menu so we basically say
make game state menu
so true or false if the state passed in
is equal to menu
so if we pass in menu here it's going to
make this value here
that
and we can do the same for all four of
our current states
so
paused
and here we can say
running
and then we say ended
so we never have to worry about changing
another game state because here it will
automatically make things true and false
as we want it
so for example here where we do this
instead of having to sit two three four
five states here we just call change
game state
like this
and we want to set it to running
like that
and that will just make our life so much
easier
since now whenever we change the game
state
we don't have to everywhere we want to
change it we don't have to constantly
basically be doing this
because now we have a function let's
make sure this works
so if i press play game it should start
the running state
and it does
alright
so next up we should maybe work on
getting if the enemy has touched the
player if the enemy has touched the
player the game should end because the
player has lost because that's the point
of the game
so what we can do is we can go here to
enemy.lua
and we can implement a new function
check touched
now this check touched
will contain a function
and this function will take itself
player
x
y so the player x and y position and
then also the cursor
radius
like that
and i did explain a lot of this in the
previous tutorials i do recommend you go
watch that if you have not where i do
explain a lot of collision detection
math there as well
so now we just basically need to detect
if the enemy is anywhere near the player
this is going to be some some
interesting math here so just bear with
me for a second
math dot square root
so is qrt for square root
and i'm going to create two brackets
here so i don't get confused with
mathematical operations and so lua knows
what to do first
self dot x
so basically the enemy current x
position
minus player
underscore x
so the player current x position
to the power of two
and i'll explain this in a second
you can say plus and then another pair
of brackets self dot y
plus i mean minus
player
underscore y
and we just say times or to the power of
two
less or equal to cursor
radius times two
so basically this math here will check
if the player is inside of the enemy
so
this is basically like the previous one
just kind of in one line to make it
easier for us you could split this up
into multiple lines again very similar
to what we did here inside of the button
check pressed
you could make it very similar to this
not exactly like this because you know
one is a square the other is a circle
but in hint here both of them are
circles
but this will basically in the sense of
our agreement drawing up here it will do
this
so this is the enemy
this is the player
whoa
now in this scenario so this is the game
scenario
it would be
false
now our math will basically check this
this is the enemy
this is the player
and that will return
true
so it will just basically check if the
enemy
or the player is touching each other
because if so
then they are
colliding meaning the player has lost
so yeah
if you want to know more about this map
i do recommend you do go maybe refresh
up on some mathematical
things you can do
with circles because this is one of the
things that works with that
alright so once you have that you have
your collision detection
now with your collision detection we can
finally do some coding to actually see
it do something
so
let's go here to the running state right
here
so instead of this for loop
we're going to increase a few things
here
to increase the amount of lines
so right here we can say if not
enemies at index
i and we're getting this right here
if not enemies at index i
check
touched
this check touched will just basically
execute this math right here to check if
the player is inside of the enemy
then once you have this you can just say
player
dot x
dot y
player
dot
radius
because this check touched needs three
things player x player y and then the
cursor radius which are all provided
here
this will check if it is touched so
while it is not touch as you can see
there because that has a knot so this
will check if it's not true so if this
does not call true if it's not being
touched
then
and in here all of our things will
happen
let's first code the else
because this is a quick one it's just
change
game state to
menu later on this will change the game
state to end it and what not but we
don't really have anything for those
states so currently it will just change
the state back to menu
and see this is why this change state is
so useful because now we just call this
and it will do all of the other
background stuff for us
now this enemies don't move here or his
enemy move we can move it there so the
enemy can move
so we can now say
for
i
is equal to one
in
game
dot levels
do
so we're saying
for i
becomes one in game with levels you
could call this something else even if
you wanted to because we have an i here
so you might want to call this something
like j or k or some other
value
any game that labels and game the levels
is right up here so it's 15 30 60 20.
so we're saying
for i equals one through that
we can go if
math.floor
it again this is to make sure we round
down
game dot
dot point and this is the points we have
scored up until this point if you can
remember
and we can say if that is equal to
game.levels
at index i
then we want to say table dot insert
and
enemies
one and then
enemy
and game dot difficulty
times
i plus one
so what are we doing here we're
basically saying
insert into the enemies table at
position one
an enemy
that has the game the difficulty so the
game difficulty is basically being set
up here so it's one
so in this case it's just going to be
one but if you want to increase the gain
difficulty then you can
times in this case is going to be one
plus one which is two but if this was
the but if this i increases this would
be two plus one which is three and this
will basically increase the enemy
difficulty or the enemy level
aspects go on we did implement the
leveling thing with the enemy in the
previous vid i think it's actually in
the two videos again not the previous
video so let's see here
at least a search level yeah there we go
so self.level
in the move
so we did implement working with level
so we didn't have to mess with that now
because we did it before
and then
this is both to avoid bugs and you kind
of tell the player you have done this we
give the player one bonus point so game
dot points
is equal to game dot points plus one so
we gave them one bonus point as well as
trying to avoid a bug
because otherwise this for loop is going
to run multiple times
because dt
is going to take a while before it goes
one full point because it's like
0.016 or 0.032
so yeah we have to be careful with that
so we give it one extra point so you can
also break out of the loop
there are also other ways to deal with
it but this is the easiest way i find to
go around it
now once you have that you can just save
your game over your code and let's see
if it works
play game
okay here is the first enemy
we wait until we get to 15 to see for
the second enemy
and here we go so now there are two
enemies
if we are willing to wait to 30 we
should see a third enemy that is even
faster
yeah as you can see there
and once one of them touches us we just
go back to our main menu
and yeah that is it for this tutorial we
just implemented basic
a basic point system
and we implemented
the basics of adding more enemies
let's start with fixing something up
first
currently we don't use fonts very nicely
because if we want a set font that we
might want to use over a large amount of
spaces this isn't going to work that
well
because we have to basically come back
here copy and paste or remember this
number
that is why i think it would be best to
create another table
and this table we can say it's called
local
fonts
now local fonts
will just contain a few fonts for us
so medium
and this would be of course a medium
sized font i'm not going to have small
or extra small fonts i'm just going to
go medium large and massive because
these are the different sizes that i'm
going to use
nothing is going to be really small
and i'm saying medium because the size
of medium is going to be 16 and if
you're a web developer you know the
default font size is basically 16 pixels
anyhow so we can say font is equal to
and i'm going to copy this font because
it's basically just going to be this
right here
so i'm going to paste that there
and then i'm going to say size is equal
to 16. we won't you really use this part
too much but it's more for future
reference because sometimes you want to
access the size of the font and not just
the font
so it would be good to include the size
so if you ever want to know like the
font size like let's say you're in
settings and you want to increase or
decrease the font size
then the player can maybe choose between
large medium and small
and you can tell them the font size is
16 and then it's 24 and then 60 or what
not
cool so that's just for future reference
mostly it's not per se you're going to
use or not to say it's going you're
going to use it
now i'm going to have two more fonts
here one called large
and in one called massive
so large will be instead of 16
and massive would be instead of 16 it
will be 6t
like that so now we have a fonts
table so first let's go down here to
where we
draw because this is mostly where we're
going to use the fonts
now we will we want to set the font to
its default whenever we draw
this is mostly just because if we do set
a font somewhere
then that font won't just stay there the
whole time and you'll notice when we get
to the endgame state that this right
here will become quite important so love
dot graphics dot set font so we're going
to set a default font for every
iteration
and it's going to be fonts
dot
medium
dot font
so we're basically saying
add
from fonts
medium
and then for medium
we add font and font is just this right
here that's basically the medium font in
fact we can copy this
and we can paste it
right here
boom
now it's fonts medium font so whenever
you draw this this will be the medium
size
this right here this would be the same
but instead of medium it would be large
so this will be a large font
all right and that's currently all the
fonts we really have if we run the game
we should not be seeing any difference
really
so as you can see phones still look the
same
if we say play game that's still the
same size and that's still the same size
cool
now i think it's time we start working
on the end screen the game over screen
so we'll need to create the buttons for
this screen so here with this
state right here this buttons
we can go here where it says menu state
and we can make it ended you can make
this game over or whatever you want to
call it i'm going to call it ended state
so now we can have game over buttons
now we can go to
love.load right here and we can copy and
paste this
like that and instead of menu state we
can turn that into
entered state
now the first one is replay so if you
want to replay the game so
replay
game the second one is the menu button
if you want to go to the menu so we can
say menu
and the third is exit game
exit game will contain all of the normal
values so love it ain't quit and just
exit game
this will contain menu
and here we want to pass in
change
game state
and the state we want to change it to is
menu
now taking it change game state was
declared right here where it just
changes the state to whatever is passed
in
and then of course
you want our replay so right here
replay for replay game
yeah we're gonna make it full replay
game
and in here we can just say start new
now currently we didn't actually ever
see the ended state so we'll need to go
here to update and we'll need to change
this
to
ended so from menu to ended this will
instead of making it go back to the menu
state where we see the menu it will make
it go back to the game ended state or
the game overstate and we can see the
game over screen
then we can go down
and we can copy this else
if c and like that
now this else if will be instead of menu
it will contain
ended
cool
now i'm going to go
love or let's just copy this here love
that graphics.setfont
because for the ended state we want to
set the font to be something a bit
bigger
so fonts dot large
and this will make the fonts a bit
bigger
this will allow us to basically
everywhere within the game
while it's in this state just increase
everything with size
then here we can go back up here and we
just copy these three names here
and we go back down and we can paste
them here
and then here we can just make menu
ended
so let's see
what we can see so when we run the game
what do we see
okay so we see this
it doesn't look great
we can definitely make it a bit better
for example instead of having it here at
the side
i think it would be better if we had it
here in the center
and we of course have to resize it a bit
just make everything look a bit better
so first let's try to center everything
because i think that would look best
so here everywhere where i say love that
gra or where i say 10
we can say
love dot graphics
dot get with
and we can divide it by 2.25
and this is a very specific
value here this value was actually
calculated while trying to find the
perfect way to center
our buttons
because currently we can set the button
x and the button y
and this process right here allows us to
make the button more centered if you
have a different aspect ratio for your
game so if i just quickly run this if
your game wasn't this aspect ratio which
i think is four by three
or it's it just actually looks like a
square it might be one by one
but if it wasn't the same aspect ratio
the same size
then you will have to change these
values here
or you might have to it's not
maybe you won't have to maybe you're
lucky
anyhow
and in here where we say 20 70 and 120
we can say
love dot graph
graphics
dot
get
height because this will be the y
position
we can then just
divide that
by
one
point eight
but that's only for the first one
for the second one we will want to make
that
1.53 because remember unlike with
x here where basically all of them will
just move here
oh they will now move top to bottom so
if you make this the same they will all
be at the same
y position
and if you're all on the same y position
they're going to be stacked on top of
each other you can play with this a
little bit if you want to to see what
the difference would be
if you didn't add that and stuff like
that and here you can say 1.33
cool
then for the last two ones which will be
the text positions
we can specify
10 10
and then here we can just keep that 17
and then here we can change that to
22 10.
this is quite a lot of changes so let's
first see what we have because currently
we did a lot of things so let's see how
does our things look
all right so that's already relatively
close to the center the reason why it's
further down to the bottom
than what it is from the side
is because we want to put our score here
in the complete center
so this will be below the score that is
why it does this
and the buttons work so if we go to menu
or they don't because we haven't
implemented clicking yet so never mind
that
all right so let's do the points let's
quickly draw that before we continue to
the button so love dot graphics dot
print f
and we can say math dot floor
game dot points so we're going to put
the game points for everyone to see we
can say fonts dot
massive dot font because we want it to
be massive
we're going to set
this to zero
then love dot
graphics
dot get height
and we want to divide that by two
because it's going to be kind of halfway
and then we also want to minus the font
size because remember
it's basically going to look like this
if i can open up my drawing application
it's going to look like this so this is
our font right
but you have to remember so let's say
that is the zero character
you have to remember fonts are actually
inside of squares just like images
so this is actually how the font looks
somewhat similar to this so when we do
that we're basically saying
this
now we have to minus the font size
specifically because the font still goes
down
so if we minus the font size
it will go from here but up until let's
say this point here
because that would be the half of this
font if we were to
circle it like that or something
this might be a little bit confusing to
understand so let me actually show you
so instead of minusing it we'll keep it
like this for now
and then we can say
love.graphics dot to get with to say
where it should bend and then we can
just specify it should be in the center
right once we have that we can do this
play
game and as you can see the one is right
there
and if you want this to be a bit more up
we'll have to minus the font
size
so
minus fonts dot massive
fonts dot
massive dot size
not the font but the size this time
because we want to minus it by 60.
now if we were to run this
boom
r2 is nice above the buttons
now what i would like to do is i would
like to go up here a bit
to where we were here and i like to
change all of these 120s to 100 instead
and in this 40s to 50s
and let me show you why because now look
actually a bit bitter
so if we could just go like this
as you can see it just looks a bit
better
and i don't think this end game looks
that great and i don't really want the
buttons to be too long and i want them
to all be the same length so instead of
exit game
they'd rather say quit because quit
won't be that long
so quit
and actually while we're at it let's
make this instead of a replay game
we make it replay instead
and this will make everything nice and
short so when we get to the game over
screen
everything fits into the buttons nicely
all right
and that is actually just perfect
next up we need to make the buttons able
to be
pressed
because currently the buttons have
nothing to check if they're being
pressed
so here where we say if the game status
menu we can say
else if
and then we can do the same thing here
where we say menu
as the menu we say
ended
and in here we can just specify this
but this time instead of saying menu
state
we can say
ended state
and everything else can stay the same
you could even maybe create a function
that will replace this for you so you
don't have to do this every time
anyhow if we were to now run the game
our buttons will work so if i were to
end the game here
say replay we can replay the game
if i say menu we go back to the
menu and then if i were to say quit
we exit the game
and that is basically all for this
tutorial
you will notice that the game is not
quite finished yet there's quite a lot
of things you can still do here and i
believe the best way to learn
is to do it yourself
i am going to bring out another course
which will cover some of the topics i'm
going to give as homework
so if you can't figure it out at all
once you watch that tutorial you should
be able to get a sense
of how to do it
so
let's first start with what we need
first of all
you'll notice if archie just moved this
to the side a little bit
we have a paused state here
but we did not implement that paused
state
implementing a post state is incredibly
simple and i will be doing that in the
next tutorial as well
but currently we don't have that paused
state
i want you to try and implement that
paused state it's very very simple
and it's probably easier than you think
it is
next up is the settings page
we have a settings button
but currently all it does is say
say this button has no function attached
this is a bit more complex and there's a
lot of ways you can implement the
settings button
i want you to try and do it first in the
next tutorial is going to be your
homework again but i'm going to give you
a kind of an example a sort of
hey you can do this
so you can try and do it here and i
recommend you do because it's quite a
challenge
and if you do it right then you have a
perfect settings menu
otherwise you can wait till the next
tutorial
where i will give you a little bit of a
push towards the right direction i'm not
going to implement an entire settings
page but i will show you kind of a way
to get started with it
and next up is make the enemies more
different
currently the enemies are quite boring
they're all circles
they're all pink and
that's it there's nothing special about
any of these enemies
in the next course i will show you a
basic way of how to make your enemies
more different
so stay tuned for that if you do want to
get the answers to this as well but
changing these enemies up to be a bit
more different like maybe making them
instead of circles
make them squares
that could be a great idea
maybe start a scoreboard as well
so let's say you can have a high score
and then you can compete to beat your
current high score
i'm going to show you how to do this in
the next course as well
but i would like you to try and
implement this here as well because it
can be quite difficult ooh that's a fast
one it can be quite difficult to do
so
i would recommend you try and do it on
your own first
and hello everyone if you're enjoying
this tutorial please leave a like and
subscribe for future tutorials
so in this tutorial we will be making a
pretty cool game
the game's name is asteroids
so here's an example it's a little big
let me just turn down the sound so
everyone can hear me
so here we basically have a new game
settings
and a quit option
and we can say new game you can start a
game it has faded fading text it has a
working high score it has a score and it
has lives you can shoot things
and you can go to the next level and
then there will be more difficult times
ahead you can crash
and then you'll lose a life
you can shoot things
now this may look incredibly simple
but it is pretty complex with a lot of
things working
inside of it
let me just go out of invincibility mode
and there we go then when it's game over
you have a fading game over screen
and if you have a high near high score
it will save that high score
and then boom here you go
so that is what we will be working on in
this tutorial for future reference if
you ever do fall behind you can go to
get up and the link will also be in the
description but you can go to github
webnet to
youtube project and then in here and go
to lua and then the live 2d folder
inside of the love2d folder
you will have an asteroid game folder
and in here you'll have all of the
tutorials and you'll have some homework
if you want to do it now what do you
need in a in order to start with this
tutorial because some of you might be
completely new
first you need to know lua
if we go to our crash course and
research it on youtube then here at the
top is my crash course steve's teacher
full lua programming crash course
you will need to follow this course if
you want to follow along of course not
all of the topics are necessary but a
lot of these topics are very handy to
know about
and once you know this it will be very
smart of you
to know a little bit about love2d
so love2d right
here and here we go now i recommend you
know at least this one
this one
and this one
and then i would also recommend you
follow the previous tutorial gamedev
tutorial where we created the save the
ball game
this tutorial covers some really basic
items from love2d
and if you follow the tutorial then this
tutorial that we're going to do now will
be a lot easier to follow along
first we need to create a folder for our
things
so i'm going to go to documents
going to go to my trash
and then i'm going to create a new
folder and call it
asteroids i don't know if how to spell
asteroids but i hope that's correct
cool
inside of this folder and you don't
necessarily have to do in your trash
folder i just have a trash folder for
tutorials and inside of this
folder right here you can create a new
file
and you can call it
main.lua
now once you have created a file you can
open up vs code in here
i wonder can i open up i can't open up
from here anyhow i can go here to my
terminal but you will probably have an
option
to go here and just right click and say
open in vs code or whatever code editor
you use
we can then just say code
blue
code to open up vs code here
and you should see something similar to
this
we can close this folder here because we
won't need it
now take note you do need love to the
installed and lua so if you don't have
those to install i do have a tutorial at
least on how to install lua
then here we have our main.lua
if you also use vs code you can get the
love to the extension
right here
and you can also get the
lua extension right here
and you also debug if you want but this
isn't necessary it will probably auto
download anyways
anyhow
now that you have that everything is
ready to go
let's just set up a basic project i
think for today we don't have to go all
out
so just
local
love is equal to require
love this is an optional step you don't
have to do this but it is optional
then we can create a function
and call it love.load
and it's just a basic love2td setup
i mean can create
two more functions
for
update i almost said delete here but
this should be a draw
now since we're starting off very basic
we're not going to do a lot we only want
to get everything up and running
and maybe make sure everything works
if i were to run this by saying lab dot
and you can also use the vs code inbuilt
terminal by going to terminal
new terminal and then you will have the
same thing as what i have you can just
say love dot here as well
this is the same thing as what you just
saw here i just like this one more
because it looks cooler
and then you'll see this
pretty neat
we can then create a new file by
clicking on this file icon here
and we can call it conf dot lua
and here we can just say local love
is equal to
require
love yet again optional you don't have
to import love
now you can say function
love.conf to set up the config file
pass in the app
we can say app.window.with
and you can make it any width you want
but i am going to make it equal to 128
128 no
1280 or
1280 and as for the height
app.window.height
is equal to 720. for some of you this
might be too big
so just for reference this is a 16 by
nine aspect ratio we're working with
as long as you work with the same ratio
you don't have to change too much
for example at 1080p
resolution this is 720p but 1080p would
be 1920
in width and then 1080 in height as an
example this would be bigger of course
if you want to go smaller it should
probably probably be around 480p but you
can google a 16x9 aspect ratio smaller
than this
and of course we want to set the title
app.window.title
is equal to asteroids
and then lastly we want to say app dot
window dot display
equal to
now
take note
not all of you will benefit from this
display i'm using here i have two
monitors the one on my left which you
cannot see
and then the one on my right which you
can see
however i don't want the window to spawn
on my left monitor which is probably
display one
i wanted to display on this monitor so
let's see does everything work and it
does it's
big
boy
and it has the asteroids title
and it spawns on this monitor so this
one here is optional these are also
optional but i recommend using them
because why not as for the window width
and height i recommend 16x9
smaller size if you want but if you
don't want to change the window height
and width
then you don't have to
first thing i want to do is i want to
hide my mouse
so when i'm here the mouse should be
gone and that's pretty simple
to do that we can go here and say
love
dot mouse dot set
visible and we can just go false and
this will set the mouse visibility to
false
now for future reference we are going to
do that in this tutorial but it will be
smart to set our mouse
x mouse
y
equal to zero or whatever you want to
here
so these will be two global variables
containing the mouse x and y positions
this is for a future reference so you
don't have to put it here now but i do
recommend you do because then we don't
have to worry about it
and then next up here in the update we
also want to set the mouse x and y so i
will actually just copy this
paste it here
and then here we can go
love dot
mouse
dot get position
and this will return the x
and the y position of the mouse both of
these are global scope so if you wanted
to you can go
underscore g dot and that would be
allowed
but for me here i'm just going to say
quick fix
and if you're in v is good you can
choose one of these
and i'll just go here disable
diagnostics for
lowercase in this file
or even in this workspace could work but
i'll go file
and it will add this where it doesn't
show that errors underneath these
and then last but not least before we
continue i would like to set the show
debugging
equal to true
and this
will basically
say if you want to see debugging items
right now we're not going to use it but
we will later
if we run this you can see i can no
longer see my mouse but if i move
outside of the screen you see here
there's my mouse but if i go in it's
gone
that is what we wanted
cool
now we can create the player
to do that
we can go here and create a new file
called
player
dot lua
i'm using a capital case p
just because i believe objects or at
least other files should use capital
case p unless it's the main files the
core file is going to be used by lua i
like the conf or the main
cool
now the player here will be an object if
you don't know how to work with objects
in lua i do recommend you go watch my
objects tutorial i have on this now you
can go local
love eagles require
and then
love
and if you want to you can copy this
and you can put it in here
take note that this diagnostics only
works if you're in vs code if you're in
a different ide slash code editor then
this may not work
now we can create a function
call it player
and player will take in whether the
player is busy being debugged so
debugging
so if we're debugging the player then we
want to see some extra information
and then at the end of the file we can
say return
player
nice
now some variables you might want to set
at the start
will be the ship
size
these will be constant variables that
will never be changed so they are
capital case
and we won't want to access them outside
of this file so we're not putting them
inside of the return
we can make this equal to 30. you can
change this but this will basically
determine the ship size
because this would be
from the left side of the ship to the
right side of the ship
then we can go local
view
angle
is equal to math
dot red
90.
to get an example of what this does
because it transforms degrees into
radians because we want to use radians
and not degrees
so to understand what we'll get here we
can go here and say lua
and then say math dot rad
and then 90
and that will give us 1.57
radians
so yeah we're going to use radians not
degrees just keep that as note so this
would be 1.57 radians
and it's all to do with math stuff so
don't worry too much about it
then here we can say debugging
is equal to debugging
or false so if we do not pass in the
debugging argument then by default it
will be false
that's what we are saying here now
return is what we want to get back what
we want to be able to access
within this whole thing here so x will
be the player x position which is love
dot graphics
dot get with divided by two so we want
the player
to be positioned in the center of the
screen once the game starts so that's
what we're doing here we can then do the
same for y and then while instead of get
with would be get height so now the
player will be positioned in the center
of the screen
then the radius
of the player and this will kind of be
like the hitbox of the player
so the circle around the player if that
circle is hit what happens
anyhow so the radius will be the ship
size divided by two and then the angle
would be equal to
vu angle so the angle by default will be
90 degrees meaning the player will be
facing upwards
how do i know that because the player
will be a triangle if you've seen the
demo of the game in the first tutorial i
showed you that the player itself will
be a triangle and moves around
and if the angle of the triangle is 90
in terms of degrees and the radians 1.57
then it will point upwards
cool
then rotation
will be equal to zero so this is if the
player has been rotated
then thrusting
will be equal to false if the player is
frosting that means we want to move
because he's frosting is blasting out
fire and stuff which we won't could in
this tutorial but we will code later and
then the thrust itself will be equal
to the x
0 and then the y
zero and i'll explain what all this
means later once we get to it
and then this speed
zero
cool
now this currently won't do anything
so let's draw the player to the screen
so underneath this thrust we can just
create a function called draw this will
be a function that takes itself
and then here we go
now local opacity is for future
reference
but basically this will determine how
visible the player is to the screen so
if it plays on the screen can we see the
player or not next up we want to say
love
dot graphics
dot set color and then one one one and
this means white
and we pass in the opacity which is also
one so it means it's completely visible
to draw the player we can say love dot
graphics
dot polygon
and in here we can type in a lot of
things that will draw the player first
of all we want to draw the player as a
line
not just something that's being filled
in so you can say line so it's going to
draw lines then we want at least two
items to draw that line so let's go
self.x plus and this will be a little
bit of math so
bear with me and we have four divided by
three and note i'm using two brackets
here this is just for me to know okay i
want to do the division first the
computer will know let's do division
first but i want to know as well let's
do division first because when it comes
to math operations and when to execute
them i am still a little bit junky on
that and you can say times self
dot radius take note
that this is not inside of these
brackets instead of this brackets but
not inside of these brackets because you
want to execute this first so four
divided by two and i think that should
be three and i'm going to explain this
in a second and then times the radius
and then once that has completed we want
to times that by
math
dot cos
self dot angle
now the 4 divided by three is mainly to
find the center of the triangle
next up here we can say self dot y so we
can copy that line say self.y keep
everything the same
and in here instead of saying because we
say sin because we want to go the other
way so let's
create the player and hope for the best
so then here we can say local player
capital p
is equal to require player and it should
also be a capital p because the foul has
a capital p then down here in the
loading section we can say player
lowercase p is equal to capital case p
player if you don't understand what i'm
doing i recommend you to go watch my
course on oop in lua and then we can
also pass and show debucking
so this will create this little object
of player
that we can use and get data from now
here we want to just see the players so
let me just draw player colon draw how
can i use this because right here we
export the draw function
it's inside of return and then it should
draw the player for us now if we were to
run this
do we get no we don't it needs at least
three
vertices to draw a polygon oof okay so
we'll have to do the whole thing
unfortunately but okay not a problem so
since this is a lot of typing i'm just
going to paste this here and then i'll
walk you through it so basically here we
have what we just coded
and in here we say self.x minus the
radius
right
times
2 divided by 3
times math cos south angle so first
we're going to times this because pod
mass if you want to make sure of that
you can do that anyway so we'll first
times these and then we'll add this to
it and it's going to be the same all the
way around for x and y the only things
that change is when sin and cos is being
used and yet again i didn't quite
understand this math it was a 1am thing
so just excuse me if i didn't quite know
how to explain this but you can play
around with it if you want to understand
it more i don't really want to
understand it more because it breaks my
brain not understanding it so scared of
understanding it anyways if we try to
run it now ah here we go does it quite
look like the player let's see what went
wrong oh you know what went wrong here
we should minus it my bad
now if we run this we'll get a triangle
cool if you want to actually test it out
for yourself and see how it looks what
you could do is you could run lua and
then open up a drawing application okay
now there is our x position under y so x
would be side to side as you know and y
would be up and down as you also know to
remember this you can remember y has
like this little finger goes like that
and you can add arrows here to specify
up and down that's how i remember which
one is x and which is why
anyhow so there's our center
then what we can do is let me just do
that so first we get our self.x and
let's say x
itself
is equal to
what is it let's make it 20
or 200 because that would be more
realistic
so 200
plus
and since we know this isn't going to
execute yet let's first go four divided
by three four divided by three that's
one point three three three so one point
three three four three times and then
the radius as we already know
is let's see here ship size that's with
15 because ship size divided by two so
the radius would be 15 so times 15.
so this right here is basically 20. so
that's 20. then we times this with math
cost and then the angle
and this is why
we used radians right here and not
degrees because if this was 90 degrees
then this would be way off so we are
using a radiance to give it a much
smaller value to work with because 90
would be pretty big compared to one
point something
anyhow so then we can say
dot cos
and in here we can specify the angle and
the angle as we know is math.rad19
so
math.red
like that okay so we got our values now
we have to times these two together so
19.9999
times six
point one two three two three three
nine i believe that will give us this
right here and then we can add our
self.x which would be 200 so this value
right here plus 200.
now that we have that
we can see where the next dot will be
drawn on the x-axis so here we have our
x and this right here that's 200 to the
x so that's 200. now the next one would
be 322.
so that would be even further beyond so
that would be like here or something and
not not downwards it just exports a
like it would be like here or something
there
and this is where this one is and you
can just imagine
that
these two
or 120 pixels from each other now with
the y it will position this one
downwards
so you can use this to kind of figure
out where everything goes if you were to
do the math like this this is at least
how i can understand math so if i want
to spend the time this is how i would
understand it so we can draw the player
that is good progress we can't do
anything yet but we can draw the player
nice
now we still have a debugging option so
let's quickly implement that
so right underneath opacity we can say
if
debugging
then and here we can say love dot
graphics dot set color
and you can make this any color that is
not white or black
so one zero
zero because black is the background and
white is the color of the shape so
making it a different color will make it
easier to see so in this case i'm making
it red and then love dot graphics
the rectangle and we want to actually
see the center of the ship this will
just help for debugging for when we try
and move the ship and the ship maybe
doesn't move but the center moves or
something like that and here you can
just say fill and then self
dot x minus one
self dot y minus one
two two
so this positions
it's in the center and i'll show you in
a second what this means so if we do
this
and you see we have a little red dot in
the center of our ship
the reason i said -1 for the x and the y
position
was because if i didn't
we'll be getting this and as you can see
it's a little bit off from the center
and we don't want that
and the reason for that is just because
of how we draw
so we add minus one
to avoid that
and then the two two is just the size so
if you were to change this to 4 for
example
then now we'll get a bigger circle
and i will have to change it more to the
side
because of the size here so this will
now have to become -2 minus 2.
so the more you increase the size the
more you have to move it back because
you have to remember if i were to open
my drawing up again
if we have a square
square
like that
this is the x position of the square
right here so right there that's the x
position of the square
and we are drawing a rectangle
inside of the
player
so we need to minus this to the x and
minus to the y
to bring this to the center of this
square
if you understand what that means
anyhow so let's just change back to one
into two
and next i want to draw the collision of
the
player so when we try and collide with
other things we can see where the
collision would affect each other so
love dot graphics dot circle and here we
can say line
self dot x self dot y we can say sound
that x and self.y because
the x and y of a circle is in the center
of a circle and not at this side of the
circle
and itself.radius so the radius of the
ship itself
if we run this we get a circle around
the ship now this circle right here is
basically the collision so if anything
touches that circle
it's touching the player you might think
this is pretty basic and it is moving
things and it isn't quite accurate
but believe me this does decrease the
amount of math we have to do and you'll
thank me for this later all right
now whenever you don't want to see that
you can just turn off the debugging by
passing in false here cool now
let's move the player
because currently the player isn't
moving at all and we can't move the
player even if you wanted to so let's
create a function and we can call the
function move player or just move both
will work perfectly fine
we can then say function that takes in
self
and then local
fps
so this will get the fps of the game so
this isn't the best way to say how fast
the player should be moving and we could
possibly change this in the future
to be a better way but for right now
saying the fps
will be the easiest way
so you can say love dot
timer dot get fps
and we're gonna scroll it down and then
we want to set the friction and the
friction will just basically say
how fast the player should stop moving
so let's go here and say
local
friction i will play around with this
because it's pretty simple
is equal to 0.7
now we need to set the rotation speed
of the player now i want the player to
be able to turn a full 360 degrees
so completely around within a second to
accomplish this we can say self dot
rotation is equal to 360 divided by 180
times math dot pi divided by fps
so first
yeah there we go so first it will
execute this and it will get the value
of this so
lua
360 divided by
that's two then it will divide these two
so math.pi
divided by fps so
pi and we can assume we'll be getting
60 fps so that's 0.052
so that's 2
times 0.0523
five like that and that should be at
times the symbol not an end
and they will get this value right here
now this value right here is basically
how much the player will turn every
second
cool
now let's actually use that because i
think it would be easier to understand
if we use it i didn't worry too much
there wouldn't be that much math in this
course it's just the first one has quite
a lot of math because of
because we're using a triangle and
whatnot so you don't have to worry too
much about the math we want to basically
say when the player should be turning
left and right so to do that we can go
here and do a quick fix to that and say
love dot keyboard
dot is down and we want the player to
turn left whenever they click on the a
button and you don't have to add these
extras but i like to add options and you
can say or
if they press the lift button on their
keyboard so that's like the left arrow
on your keyboard or
if they press the
kp six and that's the numpad number
c and that shouldn't be six actually
before so that's numpad number four so
if they're only like the numpad they
press four then the player will also go
so now they have a lot of options to
choose from you don't have to add this
mini i just like to
and you can say self dot
angle
is equal to self
dot angle plus rotation so every time
this runs
it will add this to the rotation so it
will add 0.1047
to the root to this right here that
should be south
to the angle
so the angle will change every time and
as we know the angle is in radians so we
need a small value which we got here as
you can see here we got 0.147 and we add
that to this and you'll see it working
in action in a second again copy this
and we can then go here and say d if
they want to go right and then write for
the right arrow key and then kp six if
they want to go right and then this one
will of course be minus cool let's test
this out
so if i were to run this and of course
we didn't do anything yet because we had
to go here into the main file and we
have to say player moves right here
player
move so it should execute this every
time this update runs which is like a
lot
60 times a second in fact
run this
you'll notice i can now rotate
so that's pretty cool
and it takes me a full second to do a
full rotation
now of course if your fps fluctuates
like you have 30 fps then the player
might actually rotate faster than a
second
so that's why they like using the fps
but for right now that's the easy way
out and we don't really use dt at the
moment but we can later
nice now let's add a movement so the
player can move up and down
now we're not going to add the keyboard
bindings for this in here
we're going to do it out here
the reason for that is because we will
be using that for more than just the
player
anyhow so then we can go
if
self dot thrusting
and we set that up here it's just true
or false so if the player is moving
or if the player is trying to move if
they press w the frost will be true
then
and here we want to start moving the
player so self
dot thrust
dot x and this thrust dot x is set here
is equal
to itself
whoa and then we can go plus self dot
thrust dot speed
and we get the speed from here which is
zero and it shouldn't be zero and i
don't think about it it should be five
you know you should give it at least
some speed so the faster you make this
the faster the player will move so the
higher this is the faster the player
will move
and here we can say
times math.cos
self
and this is just to kind of nerf the
speed and we can actually remove this in
a second
and then divided by f ps
and then we can copy that again and this
time for y
and then we still everything the same
but here we can go
minus and then we do syn and there now
currently won't do anything so let's try
to implement that
so right here
between the load and update we can say
function
love dot key pressed
and we can say key
and this will allow us to add a key
press
then we can say
if
the key
is equal to
w
or
and now we can add a bunch of extra
options yet again you only need to add
one i just like to give choice
and here we have three options
one that will be the up arrow on the
keyboard
and then kp8 for eight on the numpad
if it's one of those three
then player
dot
frosting
equals true so it will make the player
frost and if we play it we don't really
get anything
and the reason for that is because we're
not applying this thrust
because you we should apply this for us
to x position
so self dot x is equal to itself
plus self dot thrust
dot x so you should apply the x amount
of thrust to this so let's just copy
that and do the same for y
now if we run this
as you can see he moves but he just kind
of moves out of the screen first of all
and as you can see also just constantly
speeds
up that is because frosting is always on
now it'll be even worse if we were to
remove this right here
is that nerfs it a lot so let's go here
and now if we were to run this
as you can see he moves up super fast
and even optionally in the wrong
direction
but yeah so this just nurse it to be
slower and moves to the correct
direction
all right and you can play around with
that
next up we need to be able to slow down
the player
so else
then we can go if
and you could make this an else if if
you wanted to but
i like to just go outside in if inside
of it self dot
self
dot thrust dot x if that is not equal to
zero so the first x is still running
and the same with the y so or because if
the first x and y is not zero that means
frosting is still continuing and we're
going to go here also not zero and that
should be y then we should decrease it
until it becomes zero
so self dot thrust dot x
is equal to self dot thrust dot x
minus
friction
times self dot thrust
dot x so the higher this friction we sit
here as you can see there the faster the
player will stop
and of course divided by fps and we can
do the same for y cool now let's
implement that
because currently when we press the key
we set the frost to true
but it doesn't do anything after we set
the key we should actually tell it
to stop frosting at some point
so let's go here
so if the key instead of pressed we can
go
key
release and this means once this key is
no longer being pressed or being held in
we want to turn this to false
cool
now i can run this let's see
and as you can see
it moves much slower
and he actually stops so if i go like
that it will stop at some point
now just to give you an example if we
were to go here to friction and up that
to let's say 1.7 and then go
as you can see he stops a lot faster so
the player now just almost immediately
stops because the friction is so high
if you want to do the real space game
you can make the friction something like
zero
now
it will always just move forward and
this is how asteroid actually is the
player never actually stops
so this friction just says how fast the
player should stop moving 0.7 i found to
be a fairly decent value it's not too
fast and it's not too slow but any
around anywhere around that will work
cool
the last things we need to do
is we want to reset the color so if any
color changes happen we want to reset it
so love dot graphics dot set color
and then one one one one so it's all
visible and it's all white and then of
course
we want to actually just for debugging
purposes
show the fps so love
dot graphics dot print love dot timer
get
fps
and then 10 10 so it will print the fps
right here around the top
now if we run this
you also see your fps
comment down below what fps you are
getting and yeah that is that we added
the player and the player can now move
so we have this
oh gosh my bad that's a bug we might
want to fix
like there we go
you see the player moves
and the player stops at some point as
well
we should also at some point just
implement something here so the player
can't go off the screen
but yeah
and that's that
thus we are now
going to be working on
this right here
a little thruster that animates
and moves up and down basically showing
you that you are basically frosting
yourself through space
so we'll be implementing that today
at least it's not as much math or
massive blocks of code as in a previous
tutorial so no need to worry
first of all we can close this main.lua
we'll be focusing mainly on the player
cool
now i would like to add two more
attributes here to frost
first i would like to add
big
flame
and the big flame will basically
determine
when we change our flame size
we'll make that false by default
and then also flame
and then
2.0
and this will just help with the
animation of the flame where it goes
from big to small and from small to big
so that would just help with that
so first we need to actually draw
the flame
so let's create a function for that
so right here we can say
draw
flame
thrust
now you'll notice
in the code i will give you you will see
this
but i actually want you to instead of
going underscores
go camel case like this
i am not going to do this because i am
following a script and i can't really
change that script now it's a little
late
however you can still change it
why do we do this because this one here
is using camel case this here is using
camelcase this here is using camelcase
so we want to basically stick with
everything using camel case except for
of course
these constants
now i've already scripted it so we have
to use this but you can still change
this to be camel case
i just accidentally messed up
but that will be a function
and it will take himself
the
fill
type
so this will basically say how we're
going to fill
the thrust on the ship because this will
basically automate a lot of the drawing
process for us
and then as well as the color
now we can actually
take this
and we can copy that
and paste it here and of course add a
comma here
and we'll get to editing this in a
second
first we want to set the color so love
dot graphics dot set color
to color that was passed in
because we will change we will draw more
than just the inside of the flame we'll
also draw like the outside of the flame
so we'll need to set the different
colors and whatnot
and in here we specify the fill type
which can be either fill or line so when
we use this function it will either draw
a line or fill it for us
now this will change a little bit
so here we can say self.x
minus solve the radius because this will
have to be an upside down triangle
solve the radius
times
and it's basically going to be the same
in most regards
so 2 divided by 3 a little bit different
but still relatively the same
just instead of 4 divided by 3 we're
using 2 divided by 3 because now the
triangle tip will be at the bottom and
not the top
so we say 2 divided by 3
times
and we can take this math.course
self.angle
and paste that there
and we can say plus
0.5
times
math
dot s-i-n-self.angle
now you're basically throwing a
thing on its head so don't worry too
much
and we can copy and paste that so now we
have self dot y
and instead of minus this will be
a plus
so plus and we can remove that plus
there
then it's assaulted radius and this
should be times
not
that times
2 divided by 3 then math and instead of
cos
this will be s i n for a sin
and then this will be cos
so we're swapping those two
and instead of plus it will be minus
then we can
copy these two
as we can just copy the first
and paste it here
and this
should be downwards
then itself.x minus the
radius times and this time we want to
basically
sit the flame of the thrust
so right here
that will help with the animation this
will basically draw the flame a specific
size we can remove this whole part for
that
and in between these we can say self
dot thrust
dot flame
like that
and why did i do that let's copy that
and then here we can just replace
there we go
and this will be cos
not sen
we can then copy that and do the same
for y but yet again just invert
everything so
minus will become plus
and then we're good to go
after we turn close to sin
and then we can copy these two
and we can paste them here
now they will basically be the same
thing
but this time
we just go from plus
to minus and from minus to plus
there we go that should theoretically
draw or flame thrust but we haven't
tested yet and that's quite a lot of
math to draw a polygon luckily this
should be one of the last polygons we
draw not the last but one of the last
now we can go to draw
now we only want to basically show the
thrust when we are moving forward
so did we include yes we did include
frosting
so only when we move forward do we want
to
show the frosting so to do that we can
go
if
self dot frosting
then
and then here we can draw everything we
need
for the flame of course
now we need to check
is it a big flame or is it a small flame
because we can have two different flames
a big one or a small one
so we can go
if not self dot thrust
dot big flame
so we're checking if it's not the big
flame so if it's the small flame
then we say self dot thrust
dot
flame
and you can find all of these
right there
and we can make that equal to
itself
minus one
divided by
love
dot timer dot get fps to get fps is just
to basically
give us a bit of animation
so in this case it will be negative 1
divided by
60.
and this will just allow us to resize it
for the animation
and remember this draw will basically
also run
once every frame
so you just have to remember that as
well that's how we can get this
animation rolling
and let's leave that for there for now
and just say self
dot or not
not dot that killing
draw
flame thrust
first we want to say fill because we
want to fill it
and next we can draw the flame color
in this scenario you can even make the
flame color change depending on its size
that's actually a cool feature you can
add in the future but for right now i'm
just going to give it a static size or a
static color
so 2 5 5
divided by 2 5 5
then
1 02
divided by 2 5 5
and then 25
divided by 255 and this will give us
almost red color
now if we save this
i wonder if we'll be able to run it
attempt to index field thrust a nil
value
so let's quickly just
comment this out before we continue
and as you can see we have a flame it's
not really animating
but we do have a flame and that's what
basically what we are drawing
and it only appears when we're moving
forward so when we're frosting
so that right there if frosting
cool now let's draw
the outer line of the flame before we
continue to self
draw
flame thrust and instead of fill this
top we will say line
and now you'll notice why i did it like
this
and not just put it here because we're
going to use it two times so why have
that code twice when we can have it once
and then we can set the color and this
time just to give it some variety but
usually you should stick with one type
so if you're using rgb like that then
you should keep it like that but this is
just to show you you can have multiple
so one
zero point one six and zero
now if we were to run this
you'll notice it has a little bit of an
outline
not very noticeable but it does give it
a nicer feel
cool
now we can start resizing it and making
it feel pretty cool
and
here is basically where our problems
began
there should be thrust
like that so i kind of messed up the
spelling there
now if we were to just run this
you'll notice the flame just kind of
goes weird
because this resizes the flame that's
actually kind of cool
that's like a sword i like that
anyhow so
this basically resizes it to be come
smaller
because if we're saying big flame we
want it to become the bigger flame
now to make that happen we can go here
and say
if self dot thrust dot flame is less
than 1.5 so if the size has gone to
smaller than 1.5
then self.thrust
dot big flame because we want to make it
start giving the big flame why do i
constantly did i misspell this somewhere
no
frost there we go
and then
big flame
equal false so basically once we reach a
certain size we want to start growing
the flame so we're making big big flame
equal to false
i mean true not false
because we want to start changing the
big flame or to the big thing so it can
start becoming bigger so now if we start
flying
you'll notice at some point it stops
shrinking because we're not calling that
anymore to make it continue shrinking
because of this right here because we
only run this if this right here is
false in this scenario it's true and by
default it's false
now we need to do the opposite
to get this to grow again
so we can say
else
and there shouldn't be no colon this
isn't python
and now inside of this else we can copy
this
just paste it there
and now instead
of going minus 1 to decrease it we
should plus 1 to increase it and
remember we're dividing it by 60 so it
stays small because
1 divided by 60 is pretty small if we go
here
and 1 divided by 60
there you go so it will basically
increase with this amount
of course you could spit a specific
value in here but this will also make it
go
shrink depending on the fps
not the best way to do this i would
recommend instead using dt
but we can maybe try that later
and in here instead of 1.5 it should be
2.5
and then false
so once it's size reaches 2.5 and it
should be more not less than
then we should turn this to false and it
should start doing this one again until
the flame is a specific size the small
size then we change back to this one
and we're doing that toggling with this
right here
setting to true or false
and in here we're checking if it's true
or false and
executing depending on the size or
depending on if it's true or false
now if i were to run this
you can see it now grows and shrinks
now you can make it grow and shrink less
it's up to you how much you wanted to
grow and shrink
to me i think that's a nice amount to
ground shrink but you know everyone's
eye will be different and feel different
about it
now one thing i also want to do because
that bothers me quite a lot
when we move this ship
like this and it goes off screen
i can't get it back
unfortunately it is now gone forever i
don't know how to turn that ship around
and get it back the right way so
what we should do is we should implement
something to fix that
now to do that let's go all the way down
to right underneath this
and we can say
if
self dot x
plus self
dot radius
is less than zero
so self.x plus the radius
so let's actually open up my drawing app
here because this i can explain pretty
simple math
so here's
self.x
right here in the center of the circle
now the radius
would be from this part to this
so let's actually draw a bitter circle
so here we go and then there now the
radius will be from here to here
and you might be wondering why i'm
drawing a circle
the reason for that is
as you can see the collision detection
it's a circle this also allows us
to get
this right here
now if we say plus it's going to add
these and give us this position right
here so let me actually mark another red
this position right here
now when this position
goes off screen
so if this point right there
goes to behind this here so off the
screen
where we can't see this at all anymore
we want to make the ship
come out from this side so now it's
going to come back here so the ship will
start flying here
imagine this is the ship
because the ship's radius
no longer
on the x-axis can be seen so we can just
as well bring the ship in
if you want to make it more complex and
you think you have the guts to do that
you can make the ship start getting
drawn
once it has reached halfway or even make
the ship gets get drawn immediately once
it reaches in here but that's a map i do
not want to bring into this video
anyhow
so let's do that
so i can say
if already wait where is it f7 so self.x
and we now have to change it because it
went away here so we now have to make it
come back here
so that will be equal
to
love
dot graphics
dot get with
and we say this specifically
because remember the window plus its
width
is this part of the window so it's going
to be the end of the window
and then
we add plus
self dot radius
this just makes it look more natural
once we get here
because they will come in more naturally
instead of just poop appearing
but of course you can make this more
complex and make it work cooler
so let's see if that works
oh gosh that's a weird bug
anyhow here we go
ready
oof
gate with cannot call it
and that should be a dot my glasses
obscure my vision my bad
now if we try it
let's see
and there we go it looked normal
the reason it looked normal was because
we made it only start
appearing there once we've reached
with the radius so it will add a radius
to it and then it will appear so look
more natural but of course if you were
to remove this
then it wouldn't look as natural it
would just kind of plop into view so if
we go here pop it looks natural but it
still pops into view so it's not like
it's animated or anything it's just
pop
so it's not the same
anyhow so there's self.radius
now we need to make it do the same for
all of the sides so we did this side but
we need to do this side as well
so we can just say
else if
and we can specify self
dot x
minus
self dot radius
we're minusing this time
because
here we have our ship and here's the
port
now we're minusing the x so it's going
to go here
so
this is where we're checking now
and now we're going to check once it
goes out of the screen here
if this part is no longer in the screen
that we can see so in the window it's
going to start appearing here and the
ship will start flying here again
so it's the same thing but this time we
check for this side instead of this side
and we check for this side specifically
where it comes in here instead of the
other way around
with this map i highly recommend playing
with it because believe me it can
boost your understanding of a lot if you
play with it
and since we know this gives us the end
of the window we can just go if it's
more than this
and now we can just copy this self.x
and actually we don't even need to we
can just say self.x
is equal
to
negative
self dot radius because here we added
the radius
but now it should be zero
minus the radius so you could say
zero minus outer radius but that
wouldn't make a lot of sense since by
default negative radius would be so if
you say zero minus 30 that will give you
minus 30. but if you just said -30 it
will still give you -30.
anyhow so now we should be able to go
with both screen so if i go here or both
sides
there we go there we go this side
there we go
so that's pretty neat
we can do the same for y by just copying
and pasting
and then transforming all of this to y
instead of x
we can still add the radius because now
the radius will add it downwards and
upwards instead of left and right
and instead of get with we now have to
say
get
height
and this will basically do everything
for us now we go here
bloop
now i can turn it around
bloop now we can't go off the screen
which is nice
because we don't want to go off the
screen we want to keep coming back
now in this tutorial we will be adding
the game state
it's nothing you can really see
so i can't really show you an example of
it in game
however this will make our life in the
future a lot easier because now we have
something to manage the state of the
game instead of us having to do it
manually
so let's open up this main.lua
so we have it open
and let's actually just create the games
state
so let's create a folder called states
and inside of that
a file called game.lua
game.lua will contain our game state
currently it will not really do anything
but it will in the future do a lot
so we can say
function
game
and then we can just return
then it's out of here we can just return
we have nothing else we need to really
do
and we can just return a few things
first i want to return all of the states
we have in the game
this means we will have a menu state
which will code later a paused state
which will code later a running state
and an ended state
and we'll code in state later as well
where we have the running state
so we need to define those states
so state
is equal to
and then
menu can be false
paused can be false
running
for now can be true so it's going to be
the default state and then ended
which will then be false
so these are our fourth stage you can
add more states later on as you please
thanks to this snippet of code here it's
not too difficult
now what might become difficult is
switching between states such as saying
okay we don't want the menu state
anymore we want this state we want to
switch to paused or to running state and
later on switching that state to the
menu state all of these things they can
be kind of difficult to implement
so we are going to take the easy way out
and implement something that does all of
that
for us
so
change
game state
is equal to a function
and in the state we want to change to so
state
we can then go
self.state.menu
is equal to state and if that is equal
to
menu
so if the text menu is passed in then
we're switching to the menu state
and we can do this for all of the states
we have
for example polls running and ended so
here one two largest
one two three
and here one two three
there's probably a better way than to
implement it with a
string
but a string for our basic game is
perfectly fine
as long as you don't misspell something
you'll be good to go but you could give
it a default state if none of these are
true
but we're not going to worry about that
now that we have this game stake let's
add it to the game itself
so right here underneath player we can
add game
is equal to game
and of course we need to import game
so
local
game
is equal to require
and as you may remember it's inside the
states folder
so states
and we're going to go dot game we can go
slash game
this should import it into this project
now we can go down
and here with the update we can now
implement some of this state checking
so if
game dot
state
dot
running
then only we want to move the player
so you can move that in there and we can
move
this to the top
so now we have that so only if it's in
the running state can we move the player
so if it's in the menu state or if it's
in the paused state or the ended state
we cannot move the player
then the only other time
we might want to have a different state
for right now can be in the key pressed
so we can copy this if statement
and then
if
the game state is running
then do this
and then
if
the key
is equal to
escape
then we want to go game and then change
game state
to paused
and this will make it go to the paused
game state
now we need to be able to change it back
so let's go here and say
elsif
game.state.paused
and then we can just copy this so we get
the same key input and this can change
it back to running
so one of the things i left for homework
in a previous video was to implement a
paused state for the game
and i told you it would be really easy
to do so
and right now
we have implemented a paused state for
this game
so if you were part of the previous
tutorial
then now you should understand how to do
that if you didn't do your homework
so yeah this is how you would implement
a post state it's incredibly simple
now if we were to run this we can go
like this and if you say pause by
pressing escape then the player doesn't
do anything
and once we unescape the player will
continue
and then like this and later we can add
like some paused text
but
for right now it's fine
in this tutorial we will be adding text
to the game now that we have the state
implemented
so what we have currently is something
like this
so where we go like this and we can also
pause
like that
pausing isn't perfect but you get the
idea
now when we pause i want the user to
actually be able to see that they paused
because let's say accidentally press the
escape button and suddenly their game
stops working
they will think it's a bug but in fact
the game is being paused
so
we're going to implement that and here's
an example
let me just bring this over here
so let's go like this and then pause
as you can see there's no paused text on
the screen
and now we go like this
it's nice
cool
so that's an example of what we'll be
doing
now let's get started
so we already have a states folder
let's create a new folder
for components
and this folder will be used
specifically
for components that we might want to use
in the game
we'll also create another folder and
this one will be for objects
now the state contains the states is the
menu game those types of states the
objects will contain objects that we can
touch so the player is an object
and then the components the components
is basically like the text it's not
necessarily an object that we can crash
into with the player or something like
that
so yeah
now with the player we can move the
player to objects
there we go move
then here we want to say
objects
player
since now the player is in the objects
folder
we don't actually use the player here so
we don't have to worry about it there if
we run the game
everything should still work fine
cool
then the components we can create a new
file
called text
dot lua because it's text
we include this main.lua
and now we can start working on the text
so first let's local
love is equal to require
and just
love
now you can create a function
call it
text it will take in some data and then
it will return something
of course a table
and then at the end we can just say
return
text
there we go
our basic text object setup
now we need to think of properties that
text may have
so
let's actually split it up into a few
things here
let's go
parameters
now first i think all text will have
some text
which would be of like a string or a
text type
that will be displayed
and this text will be the text
to be displayed
and it's required
now you might ask why am i doing this
like what does this benefit us with
if i were to
hover over my text you'll notice now we
have parameters
text string
text to this takes to be displayed
required
this is called documenting your code so
if someone else in the future comes back
to our code here
they will be able to just hover over a
function wherever we use it and see what
it needs
so that's what i'm doing here if this
wasn't here
then as you can see we don't get any
description so that's what i'm doing
here
now this is quite a lot of we're going
to have to type so since i'm too lazy
i'm just going to paste this from the
already existing script code
there we go
we need an x for the x position of the
text so from the side of the screen
a y for the y position of the text from
the top of the screen
all of these are as far required
we also didn't want from here everything
is optional but we also want the font
size
the default will be p and i'll set up
this in a second where we'll actually
have some default versions if you know
html then this will help you greatly
and here are some of the options we can
use
we didn't have a fade in which will
allow us to fade in the text so let's
say if it's a game over we want the text
to fade in as well as the text to fade
out this is just the boolean so true or
false if it should fade in and or fade
out
wrap with
this is when the text should be broken
so this should be when
should the text break
the default will be the window width
but you can change this and you'll see
later where we can change this
then there's the align
so where will the text be aligned on the
screen it's like center left right
all of that
and in the opacity
basically this will allow us to
set a default opacity for the text so
the text should maybe be a little bit
see-through or something along those
lines
we can now implement that in here
so we want the text
the x the y the font size
the fade in
fade out
wrap with
a line
and opacity quite a lot you don't need
all of this
but i feel like giving as much choice as
possible is always a good idea
now here above return
we can set some of the default values so
you can also do this in return if you
want to but most of this will be useful
outside of it
so font size is equal to the font size
that has been passed in
or it will default to p
for a paragraph so paragraph size
we can then just create a space and copy
five times we didn't want fade in fade
out so
fade in fade out
wrap with
a line and opacity so all of these
so everyone that's optional
then we want to replace all of these
with those values
and of course these as well
and in the fade in would by default be
false
this will be false
this wrap width will be
love
dot graphics
dot get with
the line would be defaulted to left
so right here on the screen you can make
it centers it's in the center or you can
make it right so it's on the right
and then the opacity here will default
to one
now we also want to set some constants
first we can start with the text fade
duration because we won't use the fade
just yet but doing all of the setup
beforehand will save us a lot of time in
the future
but you don't have to do it right now
but i do recommend you still do it right
now if possible
local
text
and this is going to be a constant so it
will be all caps
fade
there for text fade duration we'll make
that to 5.
now we have the problem here of this
right here how will we set that
now we can do that by creating something
that can hold all of that so
local fonts
and here we can specify the fonts we
want for example h1 will be the size of
love
dot graphics dot new font
and we can make it something like 60
for like 60 pixels
we need to copy that
two three four five six seven times
then here we can just go h1 to h2 three
four five six and make this p you can
add more you can also use a different
structure i just think that to me at
least this makes sense since i use html
and in html h1 is the biggest text you
can have unless you're modified with css
but it's the biggest text you can have
and then p is like
regular small text just regular text
p is also about
16 pixels
and in h6 is usually smaller than p
h5 h4
h3
h2 and an h1
there we go so there's all of our text
sizes
we won't use all of them but they exist
if we need the variety from them you can
also give them different names if that's
what you're into
we also want to set if fade in
so if we try to fade in
then you want to give the default
opacity
actually a lower value
because if we want to fade in then the
default opacity should be pretty low
says we wanted to fit in if the default
opacity is one it's not going to fade in
it's going to pop in
so opacity
then gets overwritten to 0.1 so no
matter what they put in here if we say
it's fade in then we're going to force
it to fade in by making the opacity
0.1
cool
we have now done all of this setup so
let's use what we have here
first we can go and say text is equal to
the text that was passed in
x
but not that love
x is equal to x
y is equal to the y
and opacity is equal to the opacity
now
whilst i could
put all of this inside of here as well
currently i don't think i'm going to use
any of this
outside
of this text so i'm going to keep it
here since i'm not using it outside of
this text but if i do i can move this
for example the opacity that i moved
here i can move it to down here because
what's in return is things we can use
outside of this right here so we can't
use this or this outside of this text
function
however we can use all of this outside
of the text function
now we can also set our default colors
for the text
so colors
is equal to
r which will be one meaning basically
full red
g will which will be one
and then b which will be one so red
green blue
and since they're all one this also
means that by default they are white
so the text will be white on the
very dark black background
now we want to also be able to set these
colors at any point
and you could move these colors here if
you don't think you use them outside of
this text function
but here we could go set
color
equal to
and we can create a function this
function will take itself
red
scroll down
green
and blue
then here we can say self dot colors
dot r is equal to red
self dot colors
dot
green
is equal to green
self dot colors dot blue
is equal to well is equal to blue
so now if we use the set color it will
set the color to whatever we pass in so
we don't have to type this out every
time we want to set the color
and now for the last function that we'll
implement and then we'll wait a while
before we try anything else
is the raw function because we still
need to draw the text to screen that's a
function
function takes itself
and now we basically need to say what
text we want
i'm going to call this tbl
text because the text will later be
stored inside of a table
and also index
and this table is what we're also going
to pass in here with the index of what
we want to use
you'll understand this in a second once
we use it
we can then go if
self.opacity
is more than zero they want to do a
bunch of things
else
if the opacity is not more than zero
then we want to say table dot remove
and we want to remove from tbr text
the item at that index
that should be t
basically this is for our fading stuff
so once it fades out we want to remove
it from the table because if it's still
in the table let's say after two hours
of playing the game that means
everything that had was text is still in
the table two hours later and every
table requires ram and the more ram you
use the worse the game will perform so
if the user plays the game for let's say
10 hours then by hour 10 their game will
probably reach like
5 fps or something
but yeah and we can just return
false
because that means there's nothing left
to draw
otherwise we can return true because
there's still stuff left to draw
okay
now here we can start with the drawing
things
we can leave the fading stuff for later
so let's first go love dot graphics dot
set
color
and here we can say self
dot colors
dot r
as will give us red
self dot colors dot
green and in self dot colors dot
blue
and of course self dot opacity
and it will set the color of the text we
currently want to draw
then you want to set the font of the
text you want to draw so love dot
graphics.set font
and then we can pass in fonts
and then add the font size so the font
size we can find right here which will
be something like p or h1
and we pass that in here to get the font
size we'll play a little bit with this
to kind of get the idea of what it does
then we want to say love dot graphics
dot
print if
specifically printf because of how much
it allows us to modify
how much we can like just do things our
way
like customization
so first we want to specify the text of
self.text and then self dot x for the x
position
self dot y
for the y position
the wrap with
and then the align
so as i said you don't have to make a
lot of these things
things you need to pass in
that's why they're optional
you could just hard code him in here but
i wanted to make it
more robust
i think that's the word
then also after we have done all of this
we want to change the font size back to
p so we have a standard font size
everywhere
now that we have this
i think we can try it out
and then once we have tried it out we
can implement the fade in and fade out
we won't use it yet but we'll implement
it
so
let's go here instead of game
and let's create a draw function inside
of the game
draw
is equal to a function
self
and also faded
i'll explain that in a second
so first we can say if
faded
then
text
and this text is what we need to import
so we can actually just go here to main
copy this import
go here
paste it
but now we can say text
and text comes from components
slash text
and we should just say dot dot and then
a slash to specify go back one directory
so one folder since we're here we want
to go back one folder and then jump into
the components folder
that's what this means those two dots
means go back one folder
also we can just say local love is equal
to require
love so yet again it's not required to
specify this it's just optional but
unlike specifying it anyways
and then down here we can say text
and we can pass in a bunch of things if
we hover over text
then unfortunately we don't get any of
the documentation we wrote this probably
still needs to import all of that but
for now it's fine
so the text we want to display is going
to be
paused
then we can say zero and that will be
for the x and then love dot graphics
scroll down a bit
dot
get height
and we can just say times 0.4 and this
will kind of position the height
in the center of the screen we don't say
0.5 because you should remember that the
very top of the of the text
is actually where the text gets drawn so
if we put it at 0.5 it's actually going
to be drawn underneath the halfway mark
instead of in the middle of it
here we can specify the size for example
h1
we can specify false and false for the
fading and then love dot graphics dot
get
with
and this is for the word wrapping
and then where to align it to and in
this scenario center
if we run this or if we not run this
everything can go and say draw
now if we run it we won't get anything
because we need to actually now use this
draw inside of main
so down here if we scroll
we have a player.draw
but now we can actually use our states
to our advantage so we can say if
game.state
dot running
or if the game
dot state dot pause so if it's one of
these two states
we want to draw the player
as well as game
draw
game.state.paused
so we are passing in this
the reason for it is because
game.state.paused
is a true or false value
so currently if we go here
then we are trying to get a true or
false value so if it's true
then draw this
if it's false don't draw this we'll
expand on this more later but for now
this is fine
all right so now we're saying draw and
it will basically execute this right
here
and if the game state is not paused it
will not draw anything inside of here
because faded will not allow it to
it's faded because we're going to change
it later but yeah for right now we can
just say love dot and see if it works
okay now let's go and pause
and there we go we get paused
isn't that absolutely amazing
so that's pretty cool
let's make the text a bit smaller
let's go instead of h1 we say p
if we run that
then the text is now super small so we
made it able to change the text size
by literally just changing one line
let's change that back to h1 to make it
nice and big
now this is more for the future
currently it won't benefit as i lost to
type this however in the future it will
definitely benefit us to time to have
this
so let's go here underneath opacity
and say
if
fade in so if we should fade in
do something
else if
fade out so if we should fade out
then because we don't want them to both
happen at the same time so we're using
an if else statement so if fade in then
we first do fade in and then we can
change fade into false
and then do fade out because we don't
want two different if statements you
want one if statement that just has an
else if so if we want to fade in it will
fade in but it won't try and fade out at
the same time
then we can go self
dot opacity is equal to self dot opacity
minus
and here you can say one y is a little
big though because our opacity is a
range of zero to one so by saying -1
will immediately go from seeing text to
not seeing text so we can divide that by
text
fade duration so this 5 right here
so depending on how much you make this
the text will fade slower
and here we can also just divide it by
love dot
timer
dot
get fps
there we go and this will nicely fade it
for us
so it looks nice once it fades out we're
not going to use it in this tutorial but
we will use it in the future
then here in the fade in we can check
the opacity because if the opacity
is more than one
that means we have faded in so we now
want to fade out if possible
so we can check if
self
dot
opacity is less than one so only if it's
less than one
then increase the opacity
else if it's not less than one that
means it's more than one then you want
to set fade in
equal to false
now that we have set fade into false
here that means fading will be false so
this will not be triggered so if fade
out is true then we'll fade out the text
then here we can say
self dot opacity and it will actually
just be the same thing so let's just
copy that
but this time instead of minus it will
be plus
and now we have implemented fade out and
fade in
cool
now we have added the text and we can
use this text in a lot of the parts of
the game and hello everyone if you're
enjoying this tutorial please leave a
like and subscribe for future tutorials
so currently if we pause we have a
paused
text
if we unpause this no longer there if we
move around
we can move around but the game is still
pretty boring because currently we can't
do anything we didn't have any enemies
we just fly around we can fly off screen
but we'll just come back so that's no
fun
so what are we going to do
well of course we should add the enemy
we should create the enemy and the enemy
should of course be the asteroids that's
the whole reason the game exists to
avoid the asteroids
so let me show you an example of what we
will be doing today
we can move this here
there we go we have an asteroid
we can't really do anything with the
asteroid yet but we have an asteroid and
this is the idea we want to be able to
create multiple of these guys without
any problem you also notice the red
around the asteroid just like with the
player that is the hit zone so if our
players rid around it and that asteroid
raid touches each other then boom the
game ends
and we'll implement that later yet again
as the circles are not super accurate
but the game itself isn't going to be
super complex either if you want to give
yourself an extra challenge you can try
and make that more accurate than a
circle
awesome
now one thing i want to do before we get
into actually coding the asteroid is i
want to add a new feature to the game
so i'm going to remove this text here
go into player
and i want the player to now once we
draw the
player i want it to take in
faded
like that
and once it takes and faded i want us to
decrease the opacity of the player
so here we can say if
faded
then we want to set opacity
equal
to
0.2 you can make it lower or higher
depending on what you want
now because we have this faded right
here
we can now go to main
and here we can just pass in if the game
is paused if the game is paused we want
to fade out the player
so let's run that
and just see that it works
so pause
i don't see much of it oh wait we don't
pause pauses this button as you can see
the player fades out so pause the player
still there just fade it out
we want to implement this for the entire
game
so where everything fades out once you
pause except for the debugging stuff of
course
cool now that we have that we can also
implement it at different places
so let's create a new object
this object will be called
asteroids
you could call it asteroid but in the
script i made it asteroids accidentally
so now we'll have to stick with the
scripts but we can say dot lua
and now we have an asteroid but you
could call it asteroid that would be
perfectly fine
we can then say let me just close this
as well
local love is equal to require
love
i just love saying that i don't know why
we're gonna say function
and
asteroids and we can just return
an empty table
and then return
asteroids
we have created our basic asteroid
object
now first we'd want to take in the
asteroid
x position
the asteroid's y position
its size
it's level
so depending on the level will also
depend on some things that asteroid
might have
and then
debugging
now here we can say debugging is equal
to debugging
or false
so basically it's going to be either
debugging or not debugging
next we want to set things such as the
asteroids vertices
this is basically how many
edges
the asteroid will have
we'll play around with this later so i
can actually show you an example
so this scenario or in this case we can
just say local
asteroids
and of course you can make it something
different
if you don't like 10 specifically you
can make it 11 15 50
5 whatever you choose i'm going to make
it 10 because i actually found that that
looks pretty good
then we can also set the jaggedness
and the jaggedness is basically just
saying how round
the asteroid should be the more jagged
the less round and the more epic it
looks but also the less accurate
our collision detection will be so make
sure it's not too jagged unless you're
going to upgrade that collision
detection
and then we can say asteroid
jag for jaggedness i'm not going to
spell jack
jagged i don't know how to spell that
but it's 0.4
but you can make it more or less i found
0.4 looks pretty good
then you can go local and then put the
asteroid speed
speed and that is equal to math dot
random
why are we saying mafta random because
the asteroid speed itself should be
random
or am i incorrect
because if all asteroids are the same
speed the game would be less fun
but if this asteroid on the left moves
five times faster than the asteroid on
the right then that would be pretty cool
just as an example
meaning put in 50 so it gives in a
random
value till 50
and you can say plus
and level times two
so depending on the asteroid level
will add to the asteroid speed so let's
say it's 50 and the level is five so
there's 50 plus 10.
you could increase this level to
something like three or four and that
will also make the leveling system much
more difficult but i'm going to keep it
low for now
cool and we'll come back to this here at
the top i'm currently just going to go
to return for now
we're going to specify x is equal to x
so the x that's being passed in
y is equal to y
oh no dot love oh gosh
that was supposed to be a comma
and then we can say the x
velocity
this means how fast
the asteroid will move on the x-axis so
from left to
right that will be equal to math.random
and now we can say
times
asteroid speed
so that's the one we did right here
times
velocity
now velocity will determine if the
asteroid goes forward backwards up or
down
so an x and x axis it will go either
forward or backwards on y axis it will
go either up or down so let's quickly
create that so let's go here
let's say local
velocity
is equal to negative one by default
then we can check if
math.random
and here we can specify
it's less than 0.5
because map to random will give a value
between 0 and 1.
then
and we want to say velocity
is equal
to 1.
so it's negative 1 but if master random
is less than 0.5 then we're going to
make it one
and this will decide where this is going
to move this way or this way
we don't have to worry too much about
this now we're just setting it up
now you may have remember before we
continue here
that
in my lua tutorial i did cover
math.random and i did cover how it's not
always
random
so to make sure that the player doesn't
get the same game every time they boot
up the game so the same asteroid is the
same
way the asteroids move everything we
should make it more random before we
continue here because i might forget
about that
meaning go to main
and here we can just specify
right before the load right before
everything
math dot random seed
as we'll see the randomness and say
os.time
and this will make everything more
random it will seed it to make it less
predictable
cool
now you can go back to asteroids
and you can copy this x velocity
and you can make a y velocity as well
for up and down
and it can have exactly the same math
so it may not move the same speed up and
down as it's moving left and right which
is what we want
now we need to set the radius of the
asteroid because in the end of the day
the asteroid is pretty much just going
to be a circle
so we can say radius
is equal to
math dot seal for math dot ceiling so
always go up
and then asteroid size divided by two
and this will give the asteroid's radius
cool
i'm going to leave all of this here for
a second and i'll come back to it a bit
later
let's draw
this asteroid because i'm not really
sure if we're getting everything right
here so let's go function
self and also if it should be faded
because if we pause the game
then we can yet again say local
opacity
if that is or that is equal to one but
if faded
then opacity
is equal to 0.2
then you want to set the color to not
white but kind of like a grayish white
because when i think of an asteroid i
don't think of it as a pure white blob
just flying to me in fact i think of it
as a bit dark actually
so let's make it like a grayish color in
this scenario since the background is
pitch black we can't really make it too
dark because then the player will see it
so you'll notice it's not pure white as
you can see here by these numbers
you can tweak these numbers to kind of
fit your need for what you want the
asteroid color to be
but yeah that this will determine the
asteroid color
now next we need to determine the
asteroids points
now the points basically just say where
the asteroid is going to be when we draw
the polygon we have a bunch of points so
you may have remembered when we draw the
player
so
local
points
let's go here
is equal to
and here we can specify a table
and then say self
dot x
plus self dot radius
which is right here
times
self dot off set
now offset is just so we can get a
little bit of an offset
so the game or so the asteroid which is
like a circle if you remember with the
player it needed a little bit of an
offset so the
center dot can always be in the middle
if you could remember what we did so if
we go here and say love dot
then you see that little circle that
little red dot in the center of our
player that had to be on an offset which
was i think like -1 and -1
because it wasn't quite in the center of
our triangle and in this scenario we'll
have the same problem
so we're setting it offset
now to generate the offset
we can go up here
and we can say
local
offset
is equal to
an empty table
then we can say four
well not in pairs four
i
becomes one
two
and
two where
to where specifically are we going to
set this offset
well that depends on the amount of
vertices we have
so in this scenario we have 10 vertices
but
we don't want all of the asteroids to
have the same amount of jaggedness right
we don't want that asteroid to have five
points and then the one next to it also
have five points we won't want to have
two and want to have ten and once we
have four we want it there to be variety
so let's create
a more interesting
vertice but you could if you wanted to
just put it here put this here like that
that's perfectly fine but i wanted to be
a bit more random
so here we can say local
vert for vertices
is equal to math.floor because we also
want to go down but you could make it go
math.cl
in fact that might even be better i'm
following a script but you could make a
method still and that would work
perfectly fine
math.random
because we want to get a random
value
so just right here
so you pass that in there and just say
plus one so we don't get zero
plus
and we paste that android vertices in
there again divided by two
and this will give us a nice random
value
which will also determine how
less round
r
asteroid is
so how many points it has edges
now here instead of saying this specific
just always 10 value
we could specify
vert
plus one
and now we can insert an offset and this
will always generate offset at the
correct location
there is a table dot insert
and then the list and value
in this scenario we want to do offset
and
math.random and i'll explain this in a
second
times
asteroid and let me just scroll down so
i can autocomplete that
times two plus one minus asteroid jack
the thing is i can't quite explain this
math here because you can't visualize it
that really sucks
but once we see this asteroid we'll be
able to play around with this i can
explain what's happening
but take note before we continue that
this right here
is not the same
as saying this
they are not the same just take note of
that for some of you might want to do
that
but there we go
and we can play around with this later
so i can show you an example but for
right now let's just leave that like
that so we have this
vert and offset
and i can get the vertices
like this so vertvert
and then
offset is offset there we go
so now we have both of these that we can
use here
so back to points so now we have
self.offset which is basically
everything we just did
and now we need to specify at what index
because there will be multiple
because if you could see here
we are forwarding through this and
inserting for every item we're inserting
a new offset
or a new item for that offset the new
location
so now here with the points
we need to specify
and i'm just going to say one so the
very first one we have
times and we'll later modify this to be
a bit more interesting
math.cos
yet again i can't quite explain this yet
because we can't see it so we don't
really know what we're drawing here
but i'll show you in a second
you can solve that angle in there
and then with the next one
we can just copy it
and instead of saying x
this will be y
keep everything the same and instead of
cos we say sin
and now we didn't have this angle though
you may have noticed that
we can quickly generate something that
will give us an angle just like with our
player how we have an angle we can do
the same here we just say
angle
is equal to
math dot
red for radians
and then
math.random and we just say
math.pi you don't have to worry too much
about the math we're doing in this
game div course
the more important part is that you can
see how everything fits together to
create something interesting
in
so if the math goes over your head don't
worry there's a lot of games out there
that you can build without all this
complex math and in most cases you can
do what i do and you can just literally
copy math from online because i watched
a lot of tutorials and i looked through
a lot of documentation and i was like i
don't understand any of this i copied
paste
test and it worked that's what i would
recommend you do as well
if you're not very good at map if you're
good at math and just do this may of
course coming out soon at some point
so stay tuned if you want to improve
your math
cool so now we have our points
but we still need a lot of the other
points as well so this is just the first
batch of points because if you remember
we need
at least
two more here in order to complete it
into a full triangle
so we can create a for loop
and then for i becomes one oh that
should be i
i becomes one to
self dot vert
minus one so the amount of vertices
minus one
do
and we can just say table
dot insert
we can specify
that we want to insert into points so
this one right here
and then what we want to insert
for now i'm just going to copy this and
modify it because it's quite a lot of
typing
because math
so it starts with x plus cell the radius
times the offset but instead of saying
1 we say i plus one because here we
specified one but now we want to go two
and three and four and five
if you wanted to you could just specify
that i should be two here from the get
go
but this works perfectly fine as well
and then we can specify math.course
self.angle
but now we need to add a bit of extra
mass so we can close
this polygon we're drawing because
remember a polygon should close if we
just drew a triangle
with like just three angles they're not
going to close itself we need to make
sure it closes
for example if i were to open up my
drawing app here
if we just drew this one two three
that that's not a triangle is it
this is a triangle a triangle closes
itself so we need to add some extra math
to
do this at some point
or here or here but not this this is bad
because it doesn't close itself it just
stays open so we need to do some math to
do this
like that
so now here after the angle we say plus
i
times math dot pi
times 2
divided by self.vert
there we go
that should be divided
awesome
we can then insert another one and we
can just skip over the math for now
because there's a lot of math here which
you don't necessarily need to cover at
the moment
and we can just specify why here
everything else will stay the same
except instead of cos we'll have sin
cool now we can actually go about
drawing
what we have so we can actually display
it on the screen and see what we're
working with because currently we're not
drawing anything
so we're going to say
love.graphics.polygon
and now we just specify
that we want a line
oh gosh
i want a
line
and
points because we generated the points
right here it's inside of a table
we did the points and now we're passing
in the points so instead of doing what
we did with player
where we just passed in the points like
this as you can see here the math is
pretty much similar
we did this instead and generated the
points for us because
asteroids won't all have the same amount
of points unlike the player which only
has three they might have 10 or 50. we
have no idea and we don't want to draw
each one of those out by hand because
that's going to be a massive pain so we
use a for loop to do it instead
cool and let's just add some debugging
in case you want debugging
so if debugging
then love dot graphics
dot set color
one
o
o so red
and you can also specify love dot
graphics
to draw a circle
we can specify we want a
line
and then we specify self dot x to give
it a self x position and a y position
and then you just specify the radius
and there we go so this would display
the hitbox of the asteroid
now i still want to implement movement
but for right now i think this is fine
let's just go to main because i want to
see what we draw you can probably hear
my voice how excited i'm getting to
seeing what we drew
let's go down here to draw
and now we actually need to generate an
actual asteroid
however i am wondering if doing it here
would be a good idea
i say we should rather open up the
game states
and we should implement a function that
could benefit us in the future
for example what if we had a function
that says start
new
game
and that's a function that takes itself
and the player and i'll explain why in a
second
and this every time starts a new game
when we tell it to so let's say the game
ends because the player died or when the
player says play game then this will
trigger and it will restart the game
so you could say self
and then change the game state
to
running
because we're changing the game state
back to a running state since that's
what's happening
then we are creating a global
scope
very important to remember this a global
variable called asteroid
so underscore g dot or just plain out
here asteroids
just lowercase a
this is a global scope variable meaning
it can be used anywhere inside of this
file
or actually anywhere inside of this game
now because we're going to import this
file later we're going to use this and
it's going to generate this global scope
function or this global scope variable
this isn't the best way to do it take
note
in fact i might even recommend you do
asteroids here and say asteroids
and in doing this or finding even a
better place to do it than here
but for now this will work fine
we make that an empty table take note
it is global scope you will get confused
if you do not take that as note
then we specify the asteroids current x
and y positions
so
you could do this without needing to put
a variable but i'm going to use a
variable just to keep things simple
so local
asteroid x position is equal to
math.floor
math.random it doesn't need to be random
you could specify a specific position
for example we could go here and say
table dot insert because we want at
least one asteroid
asteroids
and then what index
and then what value and in this scenario
asteroids
object
we can go up here and you can copy this
and change from text to
asteroids
change from components
to
objects
and then here instead of saying text we
say asteroids and this will import this
asteroid object which we are using here
and then we specify
the x and y so you could give something
like 60 100 that's perfectly fine
then 100
for the
i believe that's the radius
if you look here we go up here
now that's the asteroid size so
depending on the size or depending on
what you pass in there the azure will be
bigger or smaller
the level which will in this scenario
just be self.level so it will level up
depending on the game level
and then true for debugging
now you could do this but it's boring
because we want asteroids to start up at
a different location every time we start
up the game
so what we could do is we could make it
random and that's what i'm doing here
and we say love dot graphics dot get
with because it's the x position and it
can appear anywhere on the x axis
same with y
but this time instead of saying with we
say
get height
and we pass in the asteroid x
we pass in asteroid y
we save that
and now we can go here back to main
then on the game load
when we create this game we can say game
colon
start new game and we can just pass in
the player
now currently we're just passing in the
player this is just for future reference
we don't have to worry about it too much
now
but we are passing in the player because
later once we start a new game we want
to position the player in the center we
want to give the player more hp
and so on and so forth so by default
that means we'd want a player we could
also specify and push in some asteroids
in here if you wanted to as well but
this is fine for now
now be remember
asteroids is a global scope variable so
don't get confused about what we're
doing here because remember it's a
global scope very important to take note
of
so for
and we can say underscore because we're
not going to use this this is the index
we're not going to use it asteroid
and asteroids
global scope remember that you might get
confused so maybe make it somewhere more
global or more local instead of global
but for right now just remember this is
global scope because you will get
confused if you don't remember
now you can say asteroids
or asteroid and it just say draw so
called the draw function for every
asteroid we have so if you have multiple
asteroids then this will call it for
multiple asteroids
and just pass in
game dot state
dot pause so if the game is paused
so if it should be faded out or not
let's run this and hope for the best and
ooh
asteroid 8
can we perform on local level a null
value
that means we may not have passed in the
level
do we actually have a level here yet
no we actually do not have a level here
yet my bad
okay so let's add a level we are
currently at level one we can start
there
now if we run this
where's the asteroid i do not see the
asteroid
let me draw it again
i do not see the asteroid
oh you know what i think this could be
the reasons let's remove that 60 i think
i just forgot to remove that
let's try and run it now
and in here we need to specify the size
so i got so confused of all of these
things but yeah now i think it should
probably yes there we go
so now we have an asteroid
and let's maybe spawn another
that's pretty cool
we can of course have multiple asteroids
let's just maybe make a four
and then we can just copy this
for every asteroid x
and then copy this for every asteroid
bar just so we can have some of an idea
of what we see
now if we run this we'll have four
asteroids that spawn randomly
cool and they all look different and
that's kind of what i've been doing this
whole time with all this math.random
this one has one two three i can't
actually show my cursor but yeah
so you can see they have different
amounts of
like spikes
and the the spikes also look way
different
compared to each other
let's play around with some of the math
just so i can show you what i meant
if we go here
to
the asteroids of course
if you were to change this to 90 for
example
then now as you can see they're like
super spiky
so if you the higher you make that the
more spiky they can become that actually
looks kind of cool
but if you were to make this something
like two
then
yeah you need more than two to actually
be able to draw polygons let's make it
four i think that should be enough
then there you go then they all look
kind of plain
and in here of the jaggedness you can
see how jagged it should be so if you
make it a nine
then it will be like super pointy and
super cool looking but
as you can see you have the red circles
the hitboxes are not very accurate so
unless you're going to do some extra
math there to make it accurate i do not
recommend making this too high
i did pretty f4 but you could put it
somewhere else like let's say at five
should still be perfectly fine
yeah it's still mostly perfectly fine
not perfect
but yeah and then let's say you were to
make it 0.1
then they'll basically all look super
round
and you make it a 0.0 i wonder what will
happen would we crash
no but it would look pretty much very
round
and then the more vertices you add for
example let's say 19
then now it'll look like a normal circle
because there's just a bunch of
little
lines being drawn
and of course if you were to make this a
nine again
then now it will look super weird
so that's kind of what these were so if
you were confused i hope this also
cleared it up for you
astro speed we're going to work with in
a second and here's the offset but you
don't have to mess with right now
but if you want to you could and you
could like remove some things here and
see what offset will does we'll do so if
we select 10 for example what will
happen then
as you can see not so great
and of course if you wanted to you could
say fill instead of line
and that will give you like a filled
version but then i would recommend
choosing a color a bit more gray than
the grayish white color we chose because
then it just looks weird so i'd
recommend something a lot more gray if
you want to go something that's not line
because it currently it kind of looks a
little bit faded compared to uh ours
and of course if you pause they'll all
fade out a little bit
and on pause pause
like that
cool and that's the drawing section
completed
some of you might want to take a break
right now i'd actually recommend it
but if you think you still have the guts
to go for it
then let's implement the movement
so here we have a nothing starting game
but in asteroids
here we have the draw but the draw is
now completed for now
so we can now go and say
move and move is a
function
takes in self and dt
dt because we actually want to start
implementing some good ways to move our
objects without using fps because as i
said fps is not a great way to specify
how fast something should move
use dt
and remember dt is the time between this
frame and the last frame so it's usually
very small
and it's self dot x is equal to self
dot x
plus
self
dot x
and we can say bill for velocity
and that's right here so that will
basically with every move it will move x
to where it currently is but plus its
velocity
and then just say times dt to make a
move at a consistent rate
so if it's 30 ps or if it's 60 fps it
will get from one point to the other
point in exactly the same time
and you can do the same for y
but it's time for y velocity
cool
so that will move it
now we can go to main
and we can go up to update where the
game state is running
and we can actually just copy this
paste it here
and this time we can call this ast
index
but you don't have to in fact you could
possibly just keep this underscore
because we're not necessarily going to
use it although we might in the future
so i'll keep that there because it
didn't make sense to able to access the
index from here
but as for future reference you could
make it underscore for now
instead of draw we say move and we pass
in
dt
where do we get dt
dt gets passed in from update
so update takes in dt thanks to love2d
we take this dt and we pass it in here
if we run this then now it moves
which i think is kind of cool
right again that will move a different
direction
move it again
now it's incredibly slow move it again
now you'll notice as well oh gosh i
closed my terminal
but you'll notice as well when i get
back to everything
that
love dot
if we run it
then it can go off screen just give it a
second
my player can actually go with it off
screen just to show you something
you'll notice my player comes back
but once the asteroid leaves the screen
it never comes back
we don't want that
so what we can do is we can go to player
go to move player
copy this
go to asteroids
and then just
paste this here
and it will do the same thing as with
the player it will make sure the
asteroid stays on screen
so let's run this and make sure it works
and it's going to take a while to get
off screen now
there we
go all right give it a second you can
also put some extra math here to make it
appear sooner on the other side but i
think this is fine
and there it goes it now appeared
and just like that we made sure that the
asteroid never goes off screen forever
cool and of course if you want the
ashrae to move faster you could
upgrade the speed here
for example let's just go plus
nine
for an hour uh let's go plus
10 actually i think that would be pretty
good
and now we'll move usually much faster
but it's still random
so let's maybe go here and just make it
a default
150. let's see that should make it move
pretty fast
yeah there you go
so you can just upgrade that to make it
move faster or slower
i maybe say increase this times two to
maybe times five or times four times
three depending on how difficult you
want to gain to be this is something you
can tweak to make the game your own to
make it something that's just more than
what we have
and yeah
that is that
in this tutorial let's add the lasers
you know because when you have a
spaceship you can go pew pew pew and
that should be destroying the
asteroids whilst we'll not be
implementing the destroying of the
asteroids yet we will be implementing
the lasers themselves
now the lasers are much easier than you
might think they are they're basically
just dots on the screen that move around
so there's not a lot of complicated math
in drawing them it's just a little
circle or square that moves
so to give you an example of what we
will be doing
let me just go here
and start one up
all right so here is the example
if i press space it shoots an asteroid
there is limited amount of asteroids
allowed on the screen
so if you have too many asteroids on the
screen it will remove some of the
previous asteroids
but yeah
currently if you shoot
an asteroid
it can't
because the lasers cannot destroy
anything yet
and i might have said asteroids earlier
i mean there's a limited amount of
lasers that can be on the screen not
asteroids a limited amount of bullets
all right it's that simple
let's first create a new object
and we can call it
laser
dot lua because this is an object
because it's the laser is a bullet
then right here we could just remove
that and we could say
function
laser
then we want the x position the y
position and then the angle
it's shooting at because the player
might be at a specific angle and we want
to shoot out of that angle so the player
is looking upwards we won't shoot
upwards of the of that angle
anyhow then this will return
a table and we can just return
laser
and there we go
now first we want to set the laser speed
so sitting this will determine how fast
the laser moves so how many pixels per
second
in our case i think about 500 pixels a
second is perfectly fine
to some of you that might be a little
fast so you might want to turn it down
or to some it might be a little bit slow
but it's up to you so local
laser
speed is equal to 500
so in pixels per second
we can insert the x equal to the x that
was passed in
the y equal to the y that was passed in
now let's first draw what we have so
let's draw
that's equal to a function
and this function will just taken self
and fade it as well so if we pause it
also fade out just like everything else
and we can say
local opacity is equal to one
if
faded
then opacity is equal to 0.2
then love
dot graphics dot set
color
and you can make this red or green or
whatever color you think a laser should
be
but
i'm just going to make it white
but you can customize the game
and make it red green blue purple
whatever color fits your eye the best
you can make everything colorful and
much more playful
and we can just also pass in the opacity
since we are literally just using a dot
we can use a point so just like a point
on the screen
luckily love2d already has this built in
so we can just say love dot graphics
dot set point size
and this is how big the dot will be i'm
just going to say free but we'll play
around with this so you can figure out
what size is perfect for you
then we can say love dot graphics dot
points
and now we can draw the point on self.x
and self
dot y
and we forgot to require love but yet
again it's optional so local
love is equal to require
love there we go
nice
we'll add this later but for right now
let's just see how everything looks if
we put it on the screen
alright so let's go to player because
here is where we'll be adding lasers
we can go to the top and add a new item
we can call it lasers and that will just
be a table that's empty because we can
have multiple lasers
so we'll just have a table that can hold
all of the lasers for us
we can then scroll down
and maybe right above the draw we can
add a shoot laser function
this function will allow us to shoot a
laser
and that's it
this could be inside of lasers or a sort
of game or where what not but i feel
putting in sort of plays player makes
the most sense because if you say player
and then colon shoot laser it makes so
much sense but if you say just laser
shoot laser it's kind of weird so if you
say player shoot laser then you know the
player is shooting at laser and if you
add an enemy like maybe a spaceship and
a spaceship can shoot lasers
then yet again you can just say
spaceship or enemy colon shoot laser you
can follow the same structure and it
would always make sense
cool
now for now let's just go
shoot
laser and that can be a function
that takes itself
and here we can just
go table dot insert
self.laser
and then
create a laser object
and we need to import laser
so you can say
local laser
is equal to require
and then object
laser i don't know this dot syntax works
but if it works let's use it
but if it doesn't work you can use a
slash
i'm going to try this dot syntax because
my ide constantly auto completes it like
that for me so let's see if it works
now down here
where we do this we can go laser
and then it needs the x axis
and the x-axis will basically be the
same
as our player but we'll tweak this a
little bit just to get it right let's go
self
dot x and we'll tweak it so it's fine
like this
self self.y
self.angle
cool
we'll tweak it more later because this
won't necessarily work that great yet
but i just want to get it on screen
now if we go to main
we can go maybe right here to where it
says this
key release and we can say
or actually let's leave that for now
let's go here first
and we have a few things we might want
to do
to shoot so there's a few things that
the user can press if they want to shoot
first i think space is a good item to
press
then as well as down like the down arrow
key
and then kp five like that is the five
on the numpad i think that's also a good
one
and in here we could just say
player
shoot laser
and it will shoot the laser
now also want the laser to be shot if a
mouse is pressed so let's say if the
right mouse button is clicked we want
the laser to be shot so they want to
play with their mouse they can
so let's actually do that so we can say
function
love dot mouse pressed
and this takes in quite a few things so
first it is x
it is y
it is the button
that has been pressed
is touch for example if it's a touch
screen
and presses which is also for if it's a
touch screen
i believe this x and y is mainly for the
x and y position on screen
so let's click here and that would be
like 50 50 x y
now here you can say if
button is equal to one and this is their
lift mouse button i think
then you can see if
game.state.running so only if it's the
running state
player
colon
shoot laser and that will shoot laser
cool but currently if we're trying to
shoot the laser we won't see anything
because we are not drawing it
so let's get to player and let's put the
draw also here
so every
object can basically contain its own
version of the laser so if you have
multiple lasers on the screen then every
object will handle their own laser so
let's go here to draw let's just do it
at the very bottom
so four
and we can just say underscore because
we don't need the key
laser
in pair
self dot
laser
and we can just say
colon draw
and then faded
and is faded
is basically what's being passed in here
just like that
let's see if this works
okay space
and there we go
currently they didn't move because we
haven't put anything there
but now
we can create a bunch
of cool
little lasers
and we can
not
use our
mouse button
and the reason for that would be let's
see
ah that should be
state
like that
now we can use our mouse button as well
cool so these are our lasers as you can
see they're just little dots on the
screen
there are only little dots because if we
go to lasers we're using points
if we were to increase this to let's say
30 then it will be massive dots
as you can see
so it depends on how big you want your
lasers to be some people would like them
to be really small
although then it's kind of difficult to
see them oh gosh where's my player
nah there we go
as you can see it's very difficult to
see them
so i think free is about a good size but
you could go up to something like five
or even higher depending on what your
preference is
35 is a little big for me personally i'm
going to go free because that just looks
perfect
cool
so let's implement the rest of the
things
into our
laser
class
so next up we want to move the laser so
we can go move is equal to a function
this function just takes itself
now just the lack of the player we need
velocities x
and y velocities
so
we can go here and we can say
x will for x velocity is equal to the
laser speed
times
math dot cos
passing the angle that's the angle we
got here so the same angle as the player
divided by and then love dot timer
dot get fps yet again it would be better
to rather put something like dt here
just because it would be safer
but i don't think it's that necessary
for a game this small but if you plan on
making this game much bigger then you
could definitely implement dt here
next we can do the same for the y
velocity
but this time instead of
sin
or cause we can go sin like that now we
have the x and y velocities
we also at some point probably want to
remove
the laser from the screen
and how we determine that
is based on whatever you want you can
base it on time for example if it's been
on the screen for five seconds remove it
or something like that
i however
i'm going to determine that based on the
distance it has traveled so let's say it
can only go one and a half way around
the screen or around the window
something like that so we can just say
distance for the distance traveled and
we can make that equal to zero
cool
now we can continue to this move
function here
and we can say self dot x is equal to
self
dot x
plus self dot
x
velocity
we say x velocity because remember
that's how fast it moves
on the x-axis
cool
and then we do the cell same for y
nice
now we want to keep this on screen
so we can actually just go here and we
can copy this
you could possibly
make this a function
and you just reuse the function
constantly because we're copying and
pasting this the whole time so it would
actually be better to create a function
and put this in
but that can be your homework if you
want to walk the extra mile
now for this right here we don't have a
radius because remember we're just a dot
on the screen we are no longer a circle
we're just a dot
so here we have the self radius
we can just remove that
so like that
delete
now should be self dot x less than zero
we set x to the width
if it's
and there's not the radius of a minus so
let's just also remove all of those
there we go if it's more in the width
then we want to set it to zero and not
the radius because we don't have a
radius so we're going to set it to zero
because remember zero would be this
point right here where the window starts
same here the y is zero
would be this point right here where the
window starts on the top
next up we want to say how far it has
traveled
so the distance it has traveled
so self.distance
is equal to self dot distance
plus
math dot square root
and here first we could say self dot x
velocity
to the power of two
plus
self.y velocity
to the power of 2
and this will just get us the distance
it has traveled
from point a to point b
there's a
part here
cool you could use some different math
if you want to but this works perfectly
fine
nice
now we have the laser and the laser can
move
now let's move the laser
so i'm going to do that right here
inside of
this player
so right at the bottom
and we can just move the laser from here
so for
index
laser
in
self
dot
lasers
we can then say laser colon move and
this will move laser
now if you were to run this
the laser should move oh gosh it's
moving but it's shooting it
in the wrong direction
okay so we did some wrong math
but now the lasers they do shoot so
let's just go back to lasers and see
what we got wrong
oh and right here this should be
negative
because it's going to move in a slightly
different manner now it should go out of
yes now it goes out of the top
cool now that
that is fixed we can have a ton of
lasers on the screen
i think that's actually pretty cool
now
never do you really want this many
lasers on the screen you want to limit
it so we have to basically
tell the lasers to destroy themselves
once they're completed with all of this
once they're done
so let's go here to the player and
implement that so let's go to the top
and we can specify the amount of
distance the lasers are allowed to
travel
so you can say local
laser
distance
can also call this max laser distance if
you want
and i'll make that equal to 0.6
so they can basically move
0.6 the width of the window before they
get destroyed
so they can't go the whole width but
they can go 0.6 of it
you can change this to
make it them travel further or
less depending on what you prefer we
also then specify the max amount of
lasers
on the screen
and that can be 10 you could make it
more or less depending on how difficult
you want the game to be
when you implement maybe levels you
could make that let's say on the the
most difficult level you can only have
like three lasers on the screen at once
cool now we need to implement something
that will destroy the lasers so i'm
going to copy this right here
and instead of shoot it will be destroy
and this is very basic we can just say
table
dot remove
and we can say from self.lasers
and then the index
so now here we can also just take in the
index
so it will remove the laser at that
index inside of the table
now we remove the laser so down here
there we go
here we're laser moves
we can say if
and i'm just going to do this instead of
some brackets but you don't have to i
just feel more comfortable if i do that
love dot distance
love that should be laser laser dot
distance
if that is more than the max laser
times
love dot ooh
love dot graphics
dot
get with and let me just fix this
so if the laser has traveled 0.6 of the
screen width so that's what we're doing
here
so 0.6 of this screen width if it's more
than that then we want to remove it
we can go here and say self
dot destroy laser let's pass in self and
index
the index that we're getting here so
this will be the index where this laser
can be found
which we're using here to destroy it
right there
now if we run this
then as you can see the laser gets
destroyed
if the laser moves too fast
you can make it slower if it's too slow
you can make it faster we can only have
up until 10 lasers on the screen
but we haven't really implemented the
whole 10 lasers thing just yet
because we can definitely shoot more
than 10 if i had to guess i'm going to
i'm not going to count that but let's
make it
free so we can actually see the
difference now if we were to run this
as you can see
there's definitely more than three
so what we can do
is we're going to shoot laser and we
limit it so if
the numbers in self dot
laser serve the amount of lasers
is less or equal to
max lasers then only do we want to
do this whole insert thing
otherwise just ignore it don't allow us
to insert another laser so we go here
my bad
and we run it
here we currently only are able to do
four
because this is less or equal to
so you could make it less instead and i
will be more accurate
as you can see only three at a time
now if we were to change this here to
let's say 10 then boom bob your uncle we
can only shoot 10 lasers at a time we're
limited now
so you can see there's like a little
wait period once i've reached that
amount
so you can tweak that to make the game
more challenging or easier depending on
what you prefer
cool now one last thing is let's make
sure all our buttons
can shoot the laser okay closer down
works space works
the button number five on the numpad
works and
the mouse works okay so if all the
buttons work that means we have done our
job correctly
we have now implemented shooting lasers
in the game
in this tutorial we'll be adding
collision for those lasers and it will
be pretty cool now i have to show you
this let's just move this here
if we go here and we shoot
it splits into two shoots again it
splits again
and
shoot it again now it's gone
and this is a very customizable thing
that have popped up here so you can make
this more customizable and maybe break
up into more pieces maybe move faster
maybe be bigger or smaller
and once you shoot it up nothing happens
but we can implement that later
isn't that incredibly cool
also something you might notice
if we were to go here
and we were to shoot
you'll notice it's a little explosion
animation thing
where it has a little bit of color once
it touches
the asteroid
nice
now i'm going to remove the whole
debugging thing
not from the game but just from our
visual standpoint
because
currently i don't think we need it but
if you do get stuck and some sort of
error occurs
turn on debugging and see what's
happening because especially when we do
collision detection which our debugging
is exactly doing showing us where the
collision happens
then that is when it's most important
but i'm going to disable it but i'm
going to make sure that we can re-enable
it easily again later
cool
so
let's create a new file
just say new file and this can be
globals.lua
now these are going to be variables that
are going to be
global scope like massive global scope
everywhere this can be used and that's
the point of this file
so whatever we put in here we can use
anywhere within the game
so let's first do asteroid size
and let's make that 100. we'll be using
this asteroid size in multiple files so
it makes sense to put it here because
we're not going to attach this
specifically to an object
this will just kind of be there it will
be able to be used whether that file
uses the asteroid object or not
and you want to have show
debugging
you can make this all capital case just
like with this asteroid size
but the difference is we don't want to
change this asteroid size
in the game it's a constant we don't
want to touch this
except if we're getting the value but we
don't want to set a new value we don't
want to change that to 150 while the
player is playing the game we could but
we don't want to
show debugging however we might want the
player to allow them to show debugging
so like if they go into the settings
they can turn debugging on or off if
there may be a developer or is
interested in that sort of thing
and we can make that equal to false by
default but you can keep it true if you
still want the debugging information
now one last thing i would like to do is
do our distance calculation math here
and this will just calculate the
distance between point a
and point b
we can say function
calculate
distance
x one
x two so this will or this can be y one
as well we can do x one y one x two x
two or y two now this will be the x and
y position of the first item then we
want the x2 and the y2 so this will be x
and y position of the second item we're
trying to get the distance from you
could put this into like your own little
tables instead
but i think that's overkill so let's
just do it like this
we can then return just a simple math
function so math dot square root so
squirt and then first
we can go here and say
x 2 minus x 1
and then to a power of 2. you could
split this up into multiple lines
don't get me wrong you could split this
up into multiple lines and why not let's
actually show you how it will look let's
go here and say
local
test
x
and then we can go here
and you can move that
like that anyway here we can go local
this y
for the y distance
difference and it will be the same thing
but this time we will have y instead of
x like this so remember it's the second
y minus the first y
so it's where you are going to
minus where you are
that's very important to take notes off
and then in here we can just say
this x
minus i mean plus
this
y and this will give us the distance
between x and y so this math right here
not between x and y but the distance
between those two values
x 1 and y 1 and x2 and y2 or yeah
all right and that is the basics for
this right here
so that is how you calculate the
distance between x and y
of two items
and now we can close that because we
don't need it anymore and also it seems
like this dot notation works since my
ide auto completes that i'm just going
to leave it like that so you just use
this instead of slash from now on but in
the
game code that i'm going to provide you
if you ever download the code it's going
to use slash and not dot
cool so let's remove the debugging stuff
from our
objects
and stuff so let's go here and to the
player
and here where we take in debugging
we're not taking that in anymore it's
now global scope
and it's called show debugging instead
of debugging so
debugging
right here so instead of debugging we
can say show debugging because it's
global scope
and you don't have to
because lua will automatically know
but i would recommend you go require
global
like that because right there so you
want to require that is this isn't
required to do this is an optional step
but i do recommend if you're going to
use global stuff here
then you can close player
now here in main where we
pass in show debugging we can remove
that and we can actually remove this
debugging as well
now let's first go to the laser because
that's where a lot of the things are
going to happen
we're going to add a few new things
we're going to make them like states so
first will be the exploding
state and this can have three values
it can have a zero for safe
a one for up for exploding so if it's
currently exploding and then a two for
it done exploding
and it also in explode time
and this will hold how long it has been
exploding so if you wanted to be on the
screen for like one second then this
will allow you to keep it on the screen
for one second
cool now let's go to move right here and
let's first check if it's exploding
so if
self dot
explode
time
if that is more than zero then we know
we are exploding because otherwise it
will always be zero
but if it's more than zero that means
you're currently busy exploding
so self dot exploding
is equal to one
what i actually recommend you do is you
set some sort of state to help you of
this for example
local
exploding
enum or something like that and it will
be a table that is like
not
exploding
and it will keep zero and then
and that will keep one
and then i think it was the last one for
if it's
done exploding like done exploding
that's equal to two i'd actually
recommend you do this instead just to
keep things simple for you and for your
future self because if you're going to
continue working on this then having
something to manage it is the smartest
idea you can have
however once this course is done i'm
done with this project as well
so i'm not going to add it to me it's
not necessary
while we're here let's set the explode
duration
explode
and i'll just set this to 0.2 you can
change this later depending on what you
think is the better time to explode so
the more you make it the longer it will
be exploding
now we need to implement a function
that once we
want to explode we can so we can go here
and say
explode
is equal to a function
and just takes in south and this will
just explode in quotation marks our
laser
now we don't we're not going to mess
with the explode time just yet currently
we just want to remove everything
but for right now we can say if
self dot explode time
is more than explode duration then end
self.explain
is equal
to two and it will just make it explode
and it will kind of allow us later to do
some exploding animations
next up let's maybe go to
asteroids so we can go here we can open
up asteroids and we can implement our
stuff
first let's take out debugging we didn't
need that anymore and now we should have
something that wants to debug but can't
there we go
and we can change this to
show
debugging and we can require globals
like that
and boom now that that has also been
done
we can now go to game.lua
and here it goes asteroid and it adds
this we don't need that extra one
anymore because that was just for
debugging debugging is now global if you
turn debugging off everything will have
debugging turned off if you turn it on
everything will have it on you don't
have to individually go change which one
has debugging and not
so now let's go to the player.lua and
then go to the way button where we are
at
so right here we are getting the index
and laser
and now we want to check if the laser is
exploding
so for right now none of this really
matters we can just go if
laser
dot exploding
so if the laser is exploding and we're
going to make sure if it's 2 then we can
just say self dot destroy laser and this
destroy laser if you can remember from
the previous video it just destroys the
laser very simple
this is going to become a bit more
complex in a second but i just want to
get the idea out next we can go to
lasers and when we go to explode we can
just make it disappear so we can just
actually for right now remove that we
don't need that we just hit the
exploding
tutu now once it explodes it's going to
set the exploding two two so we should
also go here
and say
if
self not self
laser
dot distance so the distance it has
traveled if it is more than the max
laser distance so actually this right
here so let's actually just go here
instead and let's just go and add and
because it already has the first part
so if it has to travel the distance
of the max it can
and the
laser dot exploding is equal to zero so
only if it's not currently busy
exploding
then we can explode the laser
so we can just go here and change this
to explode
and this can now be laser
colon explode
and it doesn't need anything this
destroy laser however needs self and
index
so we will now actually see if it works
we'll move this explode up
so if it works it should ex or it should
disappear once we run it
shoot it's gone okay so it does work
we can now just make it work better
because as you can see they do disappear
all right now that we know it works and
it disappears
let's upgrade what we have
so if this explode we can then say
self.explode time
is equal to
math
dot seal
to make it go upwards explode duration
times and here we can just say love dot
graphics dot
get fps
and it should be timer
dot get fps yet again i would recommend
we actually use dt
but in this scenario it's not too
important
and we can divide it by 100
and this will basically say
how long
it has been exploding for then we can go
here and say if
self dot explode time
is more than explode duration
we can just put that there and exploding
is equal to two then
now as we know if the explode time is
more than zero so if explode time is
more than zero it will sit exploding to
one for us and then it will be busy
exploding and we can draw things here
like it is busy exploding like some nice
things now the nice things i do want to
draw is maybe like a yellow and an
orange explosion animation type of thing
and it will just appear once it's busy
exploding so let's go here where we draw
everything and we can just say if
self dot exploding
is less than one so if it's not
one or two if it's zero
then we can just do this what we've been
doing this whole time
otherwise if it is busy exploding we can
go else
then we can say love dot
graphics
dot set color and this will be of the
outer explosion so the bigger
explosion
and we can just say
one for complete red then
104 divided by 255
and then no
blue and you can also pass in the
opacity in case they're pausing and we
can set the color for the inner
explosion so the smaller explosion
inside to give an example of what i'm
talking about let me just go here
if i shoot
as you can see it's paused but as you
can see there's like a little
orange part and then inside of it
there's a yellow part
and that's what we're currently doing we
first did the orange part we're now
going to do the yellow part
and let's actually just copy this lava
color
and yellow would be a bit more
greenish two three four
and she gives it like a yellowish color
we're gonna go here and say
love dot graphics and we can draw a
circle
dot
circle and you could of course make this
way more complex and cooler but i think
this is fine for now
fill
and then
self dot x to give the x position of the
laser and then self dot y
to get the y position of the laser and
then we want to make it a spatial size
we first just make it a seven that's
about that's not very big
but
the bigger one and we can just get times
one
the bigger one however will be times one
point five
so it will be a teeny weeny top bit
bigger so around ten whilst this one
here
this one will just be seven you can even
remove that if you want and just have a
seven there
but this would be seven and this would
be almost ten maybe ten but yeah you
could make this more like two and you
could put this in a variable to make it
a set size and you just add to it but
yeah it's up to you you can change this
so it's not math it's just a number that
you put in there it's up to you
now let's go look here if we run this
then at 62 instead of our laser
we have a problem
it's right here
and this should not be and
this should be
times my bad
and now if you run it we should not be
getting any errors
cool they're not going to quite explode
as we want just yet because if it
doesn't hit anything we don't really
want that explosion animation to happen
it should just disappear otherwise it
would be kind of weird if it just
randomly
flew and then boom it exploded
then that would be bit weird
cool let's go to player
so first this laser move we don't always
want to move laser if it's busy
exploding
the laser should just stop moving
otherwise it's just going to hit an
asteroid and keep on moving which is a
bit weird but could be cool if that's
what you want so we are already doing
the whole explode thing here so let's go
here to where we say exploding is equal
to two and let's add another if
statement
above it
and this one can be if it's one i mean
not two but if it's a zero so if it's
zero then we just want to move because
then it's not currently exploding so you
can just go like this but yet again we
sit with the problem it can move and it
can explode on the same time so you can
just go here and say
else if so either this one else this one
but if it's not zero or two it's not
going to do either of these so if it's
one it's just going to stand still and
it's not going to remove the laser from
the screen because here it removes the
laser from the screen and here it moves
the laser but if it's one it's busy
exploding and showing us that orange and
yellow so we don't want to then move it
or destroy the laser just yet
all right
now let's go to main
and here maybe an update
i'm going to
hide this
we can now go
and go for
and we don't need the index we just need
the laser and we can just say player dot
lasers and here we go
laser
colon or we don't need to expose it
first we need to calculate the distance
so
if
and then we can use calculate distance
which is coming from that global file so
require globals
so that's required distance
and then go laser dot x laser dot y so
this is the first one this is where we
are
and then we need to go or then we need
to add where we're going so the asteroid
asteroid
dot x and the asteroid
dot y
and this will calculate the distance
between the two
if it is less
than the asteroid dot radius
so if this right here
is less than this radius of the asteroid
so if it has entered the radius of the
asteroid basically
then we want to
laser curl and explode then we want to
explode the laser
let's see if that works
and that's going off screen
and there we go
pew and it is although it's not doing
much it is there
so we
give it a shoot shot again as you can
see now if it enters or almost enters
depending on how
the circle is positioned then there we
go
now if we were to turn on debugging here
so if we were to rub globals again
and we were to make debugging true
we could see where the
laser will explode so the red circle is
where it will explode
so it won't necessarily explode on this
part right there it will explode once it
hits the red circle
cool
now once we do this
we need to
also
destroy the asteroid so let's go here to
asteroids and we can add another
function
right underneath move
you can also call this explode i'm going
to call it destroy because you're
destroying the asteroid but it's not
necessarily exploding so destroy is
equal to a function
and this takes itself
the asteroid
table
so this asteroids table will be provided
to us
it is to basically get the asteroid you
want to destroy you could put this
somewhere else so you don't have to make
it part of the asteroids in fact it
would make sense if you didn't make it
part of the asteroid but it also makes
sense if you do it's up to you if you
make a part of the asteroids or not
but then we also want the index of the
one we want to destroy
and then we want to take in the game as
well so the game state i'll show you one
we'll need all of this in a second
first let's just remove it so table
dot remove
and then from the asteroids table
the index
so these two are passing in so let's
quickly remove game for now
when if we have this
we can then go here let's let's include
game it's not that big of a deal adding
it here then here we can say asteroid
colon destroy because if it's here then
that means
the laser has penetrated the asteroids
we need to destroy it and we can say
asteroids
then the ast index that we're getting
here so this is the table and this is
the index
and you can just pass in game as well
game which is right here if we save this
then the asteroid should also be
destroyed once we hit it as you can see
it's gone i'll do it again
and then my player is gone very annoying
bug
i go here
shoot gone
now we want to split the asteroid up
into multiple
smaller asteroids
so let's go here to asteroids
and where we say destroy we can then go
local
min asteroid
size and this will be the minimum size
an asteroid can get and you say math
dot seal and you could put this right
here you could put it
like up here that will also be perfectly
fine i'm just going to do it here
because why not and we can say asteroid
size to the current asteroid size we
have
divided by eight you can change this to
fit you however you think would be best
then
if
self.radius
if it's more
then
min asteroid size
we want to
basically split the asteroid in half
so table dot insert
asteroids table so into this table right
here an asteroid
object
with the position of self.x so the
current asteroid exposition
self.y
solve the radius
and then the game dot level
let me go here and say self dot radius
if we go up here to draw
or not draw but
here we're taking an x y
the size and then the level
and here we could
make another one
and now we have two new asteroids
now if you wanted to you could make this
go you can go another step and add
another asteroid but only once one of
these asteroids has been destroyed so
then it splits up into three smaller
asteroids so once the second smallest
asteroid has been destroyed you split it
up into three so the big asteroid
that splits into two is your smaller
asteroids and then this will also split
into two but you could make it split
into three if you're not too lazy
however i'm going to leave it as is
because i'm fine with it as is
if we run the game
and we shoot
there we go now it's split into two
there we go now that's also split into
two but you could make it split into
three if you think that's better and it
will be more challenging
we go here we shoot
now there's two and then you can destroy
the wrist
and then here we go and the pvp
gone
and yeah
that is the basics of adding collision
detection to our game
now we're not going to implement quite
everything just yet we're going to
explain the basics of destroying the
player but a lot of the things that
we're going to also implement will come
later along with different parts of this
tutorial so things will maybe be coded
out for the future sake as other things
will just
be lit
for
later yeah so to give an example of what
we'll be doing
we go here
we fly
boom
there we go
so first
let's open up the globals i want to add
another item here
so destroy
asked for asteroid
now
you could put this inside of the
asteroids object and i would i would
encourage you to do if you want to
however this global object will make it
a lot easier to manage this
in the future since we will be doing
using this destroy asteroid in multiple
files cool
next up we can open up the player
and it will be a lot like our
laser
course with collision
but it won't just be for the player so a
lot of the things will stay the same but
just a bit modified for the player
for example
local
explode there for exploded duration and
that would be free so this is how long
in seconds and the scenario three
seconds
then we can go here
and we can say
explode
time so how long it has been exploding
for so we'll make that zero
exploding so if it's currently exploding
we can make that false
and unlike with the lasers we don't need
a third item in exploding it can just be
either exploding or it's not exploding
we do need a third one
since in usually what will happen is
if it has finished exploding
unlike with the laser where it just
disappears and you know you can just
shoot another laser
here if the player has exploded
then once the explosion finishes we'll
start a new game
or not a new game but just we'll put a
player back and we'll respawn the player
basically
and we'll do that in a future tutorial
cool
now first thing we can do
is we can close this
we can close this
and we can draw the player exploding
so right here before the frosting
because we don't want to frost or move
or things like that if the player is
exploding so we can say if
not
self dot
exploding so if it's not currently
exploding
then we want to do all of this
and here we can just say
oh we can just end for now it's fine
and we can invent this
so
if the player is not currently busy
exploding allow the player to thrust
forward and to move around and whatnot
however
if the player is exploding then do
something else so draw something else
and this will be very similar to our
laser what we have drawn here
so this right here so we can actually
copy that it will just be modified a bit
and we can paste it here
so first we want the
largest circle
to be just pure red just to give it more
intensity because
the
ship itself is much larger and much more
complex
than a laser so you want the ship's
explosion to also look like it means
more because it does mean more than the
laser the laser explosion disappears
faster and it doesn't it only has like
two colors and it's very small
here we want it to be rather large
and to have more than two colors to show
hey this is some big thing that exploded
here
this can stay the same
however this time we can use
self dot radius instead because
we now have a
radius to work with instead of just a
dot
same here we can say self to radius and
then just times one or we can remove it
and it doesn't have to say times one at
all
then here we can say one five eight to
give it a nice little color here
and then if we were to
copy this paste it here
and in here we can say
two three four this will be the smallest
one and it will be
0.5
so you can see how they scale in size
now that we use times and now you'll
understand why we use times to help it
scale without us having to do much and
this is how it will look once it
explodes we'll take a look on how that
looks
in a second
currently let's actually just allow the
player to explode
so let's go to the move player section
i'm just going to hide this draw
in the move player section
this whole part here
we can just say if
not
self.exploding
so if the player is not currently
exploding
then we can do everything
and then paste that in there
and you can just invent
and there we go
so if the player is exploding
now you can see if the player is
exploding we're going self
dot exploding is equal
to
self.explode
explode time could you please
autocomplete there we go
if that is more than zero so this will
return true or false if the explode time
is more than zero then the player is
exploding
cool
so this will only execute
if it's not exploding
however take note that we don't want to
actually stop
the laser so this whole section here for
the lasers
we can move that to underneath the end
of this if statement so there's this one
right here
it does not hold the lasers the lasers
can still move and stuff if the player
explodes the player explodes but lasers
are not affected by it
we can then save
and then finally we can implement an
explode function
so as a function takes itself and now we
can just say self dot explode time
is equal to math
dot seal
and then specify explode duration
times
love
love dot timer
dot
get fps
there we go
so this will explode the player for us
we can then go here to globals
not globals my bad we then go here to
the main file
and here where we have an update
we can go to when it's running
so right here when it's running then we
have our move player first
then we do our asteroid stuff
then here in the asteroid stuff we can
go
if
not so the player
is not exploding
so player
dot exploding so if the player is not
exploding
we can copy this line of code for the
laser
like that we can paste it here
and this will allow us to check if the
player has collided however we don't
need this for loop so we can just remove
that on indent
we have a calculate distance but this
time instead of the laser
it's the
player so the player x player y
and then player explode
and in here we also want to go and then
instead of saying asteroid destroy
you want to say asteroid or
destroy asteroid is equal to true
and this is in our globals file destroy
asteroid
if this is true we want to destroy the
however we don't need to set that here
we're only setting it here if the player
specifically explodes into an asteroid
and you will understand more about why i
did this in the future
or why we are doing this
then here we can say else so if the
player is exploding
then player dot explode time
is equal to player dot explode oh gosh i
can type
player dot explode
time
minus one so it will decrease if the
player is exploding
then after this for loop we can go
if
so if we want to
destroy
the asteroid
then you want to sit destroy asteroid to
false again because we're destroying the
asteroid
and then
we got asteroid
colon destroy
and we just actually copy this little
asteroid destroy thing because it's the
same code
now one reason why we are doing this
right here and not this here as well is
because here there are multiple lasers
that's going to try and destroy the
asteroids so if two lasers
collide with this with different
asteroids at the same time we're going
to have a problem because what is it
going to do destroy asteroids is true
so what
if you understand what i mean here
because if two
lasers collide against two separate
asteroids but a destroy asteroid is true
it is going to be incredibly confusing
anyhow in there we have our asked index
and we have our game and then here we
can move the asteroids
now let's run the game and see if we
explode
boom
and yep
the rest of the asteroids are moving
however if we go and we fly against an
asteroid
we can still see our player we don't
want that we don't want to see our
player
so we should go here to player and you
should make sure
we got the if else statements correctly
so if not exploding
then it everything is just held in
i mean this is for the moving it's not
for the drawing okay let's go to draw
now let's see here
if not exploding then we can do
everything in here
however if the ship has exploded
then let's see here what's happening
all right i see
so here we already have a bunch of
things but this is only for the thruster
we need to include everything as well i
kind of missed all of this so let's just
go like this
and we can just
cut
and we can go here
and we can just say paste
so now we'll not only just not draw the
thrusters but will not draw anything
else
while we are exploding so if we go like
this
and now if we were to try and hit an
asteroid
we can't see our player anymore
and there we go
we've implemented
collision detection for the player
and hello everyone if you're enjoying
this tutorial please leave a like and
subscribe for future tutorials
in this tutorial we'll be adding lives
to the player so once the player
explodes instead of the game just ending
they have a few more lives they can spin
before the game is completely over
so let's get started with that
first
i want to give you an example of what we
currently have so if we were to go here
and say love dot
what we currently have there goes our
asteroid off screen so it should appear
out about there somewhere yeah and boom
we explode
and we just kind of continue
just very boring
however when we explode that shouldn't
happen or when we hit something that
shouldn't happen in fact this should
happen
so this is an example of what we'll be
doing so as you can see at the top our
player lives are there
when we hit an asteroid
the player lives they go red they
disappear and we start in the middle of
the screen again
and we can use up all our player lives
until we are no longer there
once we are no longer here
then
game ends the last asteroid does not
explode once we hit it that is to
prevent a bug but you don't have to
worry about that bug because i'm fixing
it here for you anyways
but let's get started
so
first we want to now take in the num
lives
so how many lives the players should
have
then down here we can just say
lives is equal to num lives or by
default they can be free so if you don't
pass in a number of lives it will be
free by default
next up let's draw the player lies
so maybe right here underneath draw we
can say draw
lives
this is a function
that takes in self and faded
cool
we can copy a lot of things from this
player draw
so if you do not mind i am going to copy
basically everything from here because a
lot of this code is copy paste from
what we already do in draw because first
we set the opacity
depending on if it's faded the opacity
will change
and in here
is where it fades a little bit from what
we do
usually against what we
want to do
we'll still keep a lot of this for
example this right here we want to keep
this
so let me just delete this part here and
this laser part as well
we can keep this polygon
and this
color we can remove the debugging
because we will be doing debugging on it
and we can also remove all of this
and now we have a bunch of the code
already given to us because we have
already coded a lot of this
nice let's just indent this to a
there that's much better
now
first we want to see what color our
lives should be because if we go back to
this example i have
and i can just move it over
and as you'll see if we have three lives
then it's white the same color as the
ship
if we hit an asteroid then it becomes
yellow
and if we hit an asteroid again where we
only have one live lift if i don't miss
the asteroid which i did again
my aim is terrible
and now it will be red because hey you
should watch out buddy you only have one
live left
and that's what we want to do here so we
want to set the color depending on the
amount of lives the player has
so first we can say if
self.lives is equal
to two so they have two lives
then
we can copy this right here
paste it there and we'll modify it in a
second
then we can say else
and this will also contain an if and
then else so we're going to go like this
and then we can just copy this and
paste it here
and we can remove this
now if they only have two lines left we
want to make it one one and in 0.5 and
this will make it a kind of a yellowish
color
if they have one life left then we want
to make it red but not completely red
just a little red
so it will be red and then 0.2 green and
0.2 blue
and in here if they have
three lives so if they have three or
more lives in the scenario because
there's a two and a one if you want to
add like five lives you can maybe add
more colors or you can just make them
all white until it hits two and they
will change color
anyhow if they have one will be red and
if they don't have two or one if they
are free it will be white
and in the draw lives we need basically
to get the x and y positions or to give
it a default x and y position
you can make this like a more globally
state one like put it here or even put
it here it doesn't really matter too
much in this scenario i just want it
here at the top of the screen so i'm
going to do an easy
local
x
pause
y
plus
is equal to 45 and 30.
so x would be 45 and y would be 30. so
45 from the side 30 from the top
then we can create the for loop so 4
i and one
to self
dot live so the amount of lives we have
and we want to basically draw free lives
so you can just plop that in there
because the lives are the same shape as
the spaceship
and we can go
if we are exploding so if self
dot
exploding
then
and then
if
i is equal to self dot lives so the
amount of lives you have so we don't
want this to happen if we have more less
lives on the screen than what we
currently have or more you know
they want to basically make the
heart completely red
so
love dot graphics dot set
color
and then
one zero
zero so basically once we explode then
it should change the color of the
spaceship
to pure red until the explosion is over
in which case it will switch to
whichever colors are here
cool
the on here since we can't just draw the
spaceship on the same position or at the
same position
everywhere we need to specify a few
things here to make the
the lives go in different locations
because if we don't
then the lives here there wouldn't be
three lives like i i wish i could show
my cursor here but there will be like
three lives there
there will only be one and
two others on top of it
so we need to specify where to position
it so instead of self.x here
we can go
and say
i so the current index we are on or the
current position
times x position and this will
give it its wanted x position
and then as for the self.y since the y
will never change unless you make it go
in the x direction instead of or in the
y direction instead of an x direction
then the y will never change so why
pause
but if you wanted to you could make the
heart
go from top to bottom instead of from
left to right it depends on what you
want personally i think going from left
to right is perfectly fine
but once you have done that
then
boom
we are basically ready to go
now we also need to remember
that we don't want these to change angle
with the spaceship you could
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
if you make a change angle with the
spaceship
then that it could
kind of make the player a little bit
confused about like while he's playing
and suddenly he sees the spaceship
hearts moving as well it could be cool
but it could be very distracting
personally i think it's too distracting
and i'm going to remove it but you don't
have to if you think it's a cool feature
instead we can go here select all of
these
and remember this
view angle we created here at the top
that is the default angle or spaceship
is always at so we can just specify
view angle instead
so now it will always face 90 degrees
and never change but if you want it to
change then you could then again 100 do
that
i just don't care to make a change
cool
next before we continue i would like to
go to globals
and make sure this is here
just to make sure that is there so if
you forgot about this just put it there
nice so next up we can just go to
the main
file
and let's draw our lives so let's go
here
and we can say
player
colon
draw
lives
i know if the game is paused so game
dot state
dot paused because if the game is
supposed to want it to be
faded and here we go that shouldn't be
an end symbol my bad that should be
eight times
okay now let's try it
there we go so now our lives are right
up here
as you can see
so that's nice
currently if we hit an asteroid
nothing's going to happen we're just
going to kind of die and respawn and
then hit them again and again again we
don't want that to happen anymore
because we now have lives we want the
player lives to decrease and the player
to restart from where he was where she
was
so
let's go to the top
and
let's see and this is not the right file
we go to menu and here it says explode
time and then what the explode time does
we can go and say
if
player dot explode time
if that is equal to zero
then we want to go
if
player.lives
minus one is less than zero meaning if
the player
doesn't have any lives left
then game colon change game state to
ended because the player
amount of lives minus one is less than
zero meaning they have like negative one
lives left
then end the game
and we should make this laser equal to
because
yeah just because
but you could make it less than one if
you wanted to
because this city player has one life
left now they hit an asteroid now one
minus or now the player lives i mean
changes to zero and zero minus one
that is negative one and that's less
than zero
so in return it should change the game
state to end it because the player has
zero lives left then we don't want the
game to continue
and then we can just say return because
we don't want this to continue the loop
or to continue to continue this loop
nice
otherwise just always go player
is equal to and then
a new player
and in the player
dot lives minus one
and there we go so now the player will
always have one less of a life
once they hit this or once they finish
exploding
and i should save without formatting
now if you run this
and let's see what happens when we hit
this asteroid
we lose the life
and we start back at the screen
the reason we started back at the center
is because we create a new player and
when we create a new player
the player by default is in the center
of the screen because that's what we
hard coded here in a sense we basically
said hey once we create a new player put
them in the center x and y and that's
what's happening here we're creating a
new player and storing that player in
the old player variable
so don't get too confused here we're
just creating a new player object
storing it in here but it kind of has a
lot of the old player stuff
by that i just mean the lives
so yeah now if we hit an asteroid we go
we lose a life now we have less lives if
it's another asteroid we lose life
let's hit another asteroid here
and there we go
now the game has changed to ended state
okay meaning it's basically over
now i still want to do a few more things
before we continue
so here if destroy asked
we can now go
if
and then else
now instead of the else we can now put
this
and in this if statement can check
player.lives
minus one if that is less or equal to
zero
then
we want to go
if
player dot explode time
is that is equal to zero as well
then we want to set this
here as well
so basically if the player lives
is less or equal to zero
basically the same check we did here
however this check will not execute
quite as quickly because this one will
execute after this check so this check
may be false then this executes where
this check could be true but it executed
after
that so see this executed after just
right here so after the check so player
lives here could still be two then we go
here and then player lives is one
because remember code goes from up to
down
they're doing the same thing here but
now it's here at the bottom and since
it's going up to down it will trigger
this
and we check if the explode time is
equal to zero
then just do everything as normal
however
if the explode time is not equal to zero
then it just don't do anything at all
the reason for this is once we basically
finish the game yeah once we basically
get to the last asteroid and we hit that
asteroid for player
it can cause a few issues
and this will just cause or this will
just fix a bug in the future
but you don't have to worry too much
about this just put that there
save our game we run our game and now we
fly
we hit
we respawn
we wait for our targets to come back
we fly
we hit we respawn and now for the last
one we fly
we hit
it doesn't get destroyed immediately and
that is exactly what we want because
that could cause errors because let's
say that's the very last asteroid before
we go to the next level and it wants to
go to the next level once we hit it
but once we hit it we and we have our
last life there it's not going to be a
good match
because let's say we only have one life
left and there's only one asteroid left
once we hit that asteroid and we lose
our one life it wants to go to the next
level and this is in the future once we
implement levels
but if it wants to go to the next level
and we just lost our last life that's
going to cause a few errors and so we
say if we hit against an asteroid with
our last life
then it's game over then we don't get
that point or anything like that
in this tutorial we want to add a menu
to our game
so to give an example of the menu we're
going to create
we go here
we have our little player circle
we have a quit we have a settings and we
have a new game if we click on quit it
will quit the game
settings will be your homework so
clicking on settings will do will not do
anything
and then clicking on new game will start
a new game
then let's go here
and then once we reach our last life
it will give us a game over screen but
we have yet to implement that but once
we finish implementing that then after
the game over screen it will take us
back to the menu screen and that is what
we want to do
okay but this tutorial is going to be
pretty long so we won't be doing the
ending screen just yet
so first
let's go here to the game.lua file
and let's go to the top
and here where it says state
i want to change all of the other states
to false
and the menu state to true so by default
the menu state will be true
meaning once we
basically
start up the game it will give us the
menu state not currently but it should
give us the menu state
cool
next up
let's create a new component so
component new file
and then
button.lua
and this will be the buttons we want on
the menu screen unfortunately the menu
screen is legitimately just buttons so
we have to do this before the menu
screen
we can just say
local
love is equal to require
love and in local text because we're
going to need text to display the
buttons
is equal to require
components
there are components
dot text or slash text depending on if
dot text doesn't work for you you can go
slash
both of them work for me
we can now create a function
and call it
button it will take in quite a few
things so we'll get to that and then
return
button
so let's get everything already ready in
here let's just say return and then
there
now a button will take a lot of things
first once we click a button we want to
execute a specific function for that
button
we don't want to implement that function
inside of the button itself because if
we do that then it could cause a little
bit of a problem with us needing to
basically for every scenario coded by
coder function so it's better to pass in
a function and then to execute that
function on button click
so we can say func for a function we
want to take in
also the text color of the button
the button color itself
the width of the button
the height of the button
the text on the button
where the text should be aligned to so
the text align
the font size and i know this looks like
a lot at the moment but believe me we'll
go through all of them slowly
the button x position
the
button
y position
the text on the buttons x position and
then the text on the buttons y position
cool
so now we have the basics of a button
here
now first
let's say
local
btn
text for the button text is equal to an
empty table and we'll get back to this
in the future
then our function is equal to the
function passed in
or if there's no function passed in we
can then say or
function and we can just remove this and
or we can just not remove it but just
bring it to the end of this statement so
one liner function
print
and we can just print
this
button has no function
attached
so basically if they save
or if they click the button and they
didn't add a function to it it will
print out to the console hey there's no
function attached to this button you
can't click it
next up i want to position the text of
the button
now if you remember from the previous
tutorial or from the previous game we
made
where if i were to go here as you see
our buttons
they have a little space here but if you
could remember from the code we wrote
for these buttons is that the text in
the button
is positioned relative
to the button itself
meaning if we position a button here
then and we say the text is
10 pixels to the right then it's going
to be inside of the button by default 10
pixels to the right
meaning the text isn't going to be 10
pixels from the border of the screen
it's going to be 10 pixels from the
border of the button
if you can't quite remember what we did
here i do recommend you maybe go back to
the files and just go check on how we
created that button and maybe that will
bring back some flashbacks
but it's not a big piece of code we have
to write for that so let's quickly do
that
so if
text wise if the y position was provided
then
ptn
and in text
dot y
will be equal to text
underscore y
plus
button y so plus the y position of the
button
because it needs to be the amount we
give it plus the button otherwise you'll
have to manually calculate if you wanted
on the center of the button where the
center of the button would be relative
to where we already have it so we
anyways have to do this later on if you
want the ticks to be inside of the
button
and you can still make the tick outside
of the button even with this method here
you just use minus or just massive value
depending on what you want to do
anyhow let's continue because it's a big
file
then we can hit it again again just go
like whoop go like this and then do this
but without this
now you have a choice here
and let me just go back to y here
you have a choice you can either do this
if else statement
or you can go here and say y
is equal to
and then
button y
and you can remove this part here this
will work just as well
so it's up to you what you want to do
however i'm going to use this else
statement here
you're going to copy this
and now you can do it for x
and in here you can just change this
to x
and there we go we have just as quickly
added our x and y positions for the
buttons
or for the text on the button
now let's go here and we can just say
text color
is equal to text color
or if they didn't specify text color we
can just make it
white so r is equal to one
g is equal to one and
b is equal to one
like that
and we can do the same
for button color so button color is
equal to button color or and we just
copy this one here
however the difference will be
is that by default the button color
should not be white
because the text is already white so if
they don't enter the text or the button
color you want to make sure that the
text is still visible since the button
would now be black
you can swap these two if you want to
but yeah
and we can go the width of the button
is equal to the width we enter or 100
and then the height of the button is
equal
to the height we enter
or 100
the text
is equal to text
or
and you don't have to specify or with
any of these i'm just doing it for in
case i want to leave something out there
in case you might want to leave
something out in the future the more
customized this is the more things you
can later on leave out
anyhow and then no text added so new
text was added we can just put that
there
or you could force it it depends on what
you want
the text x position
is equal to the text position passed in
and we're not using this text position
here quite yet but you will see in a
second where we use that
or we can make it the button x
or if you didn't specify at all we can
just make it zero
we can do the same for the y text
position where all the x's are just y's
and you can go here and say
the button x position is equal to the
button x position or zero
and in the button y position is equal to
the button y position
or zero
cool
and then finally we need to use a text
component
that will put the text on the screen for
us and we already have a text component
that's been imported right here
and every button will have its own text
component so we can just say text
component
is equal to text
and then we can just pass in all our
values
so we can say text
btn text dot x so here we use the button
text
but here we specifically
use the x and y given to us
and you can of course do the same but
for y
and as you can see also our
documentation is here which is very nice
and this is some documentation we did a
while back so here we go and
as you can see we did a bunch of
documentation and now the documentation
appears as i'm trying to edit this
so that's pretty neat so now we know we
need the font size and the font size is
passed in
and then also whether we want it to fade
in which is false we don't want it to
fade in unless you want to add some
animation
fade out is also false
the width
and then the text
align like that
and then finally for the opacity we can
just pass it on we don't want to change
the opacity
however if you have buttons in your game
you want to make this a dynamic value so
very value passing as a variable and not
just one so it depends on what you want
to do if there's buttons in your game
and not just any menu so when they pause
and you want it to fade out when you
pause then making this an actual
variable would be better
because you can change the variable
later
let's draw the button because i actually
want to get the button on the screen
so draw is equal to function
self
and we just add in our comma
then here we just say love dot graphics
dot set color so the color we want
the
button to be
and we can go self
dot
button color and then just specify
red
and we can do that for all of the colors
colors we have so let's
do that
and there we go
now the color will be set to what we
want the button color to be
then we can draw a rectangle so love
dot
graphics dot rectangle
and you can just say fill this rectangle
or don't fill it it depends on what you
want but i would like to fill it since
it's a button it makes sense to fill it
self then the button
x
self dot
button
y
self dot
width
and then self
dot height
and it will draw the button for us
next up we need to do the same
but instead for the button we need to do
it
for the text and we also want to reset
the color back to white
so here we can go here but instead of
button color we now go text color
and you can just say self dot text
component
dot draw just colon draw instead
and this will draw the text component
for us because it already has its own
draw function
cool
now that's the basics for the button
we'll be getting back to this a little
bit later in the tutorial i just want to
get the button on the screen right now
next we can go and we can create a new
file
in the states folder called
menu.lua because the new state we have
and you can require love so
local
love is equal to require
love
local
button and it should be with capital b
is equal
to require
components.button
and then we can say
function menu
takes in
nothing yet
and then we can just return
a table
and we can return menu and this will
return the menu for us
now we can just take in the game and
we'll get to y and then the player and
we'll also get to y
next we want to draw the buttons and the
buttons are pretty big so local and
let's just draw one for now
buttons is equal to
and then here we say a new button
the function we have let me just say nil
for now
because there's no function
then the text color which can be nil and
then nil again or the button color the
width can be love dot graphics
dot
get width
divided by three and it will give it a
nice
see rather smallish width
and then the height can just be 50.
the text can say new
game
it can be aligned in center
i need to make that okay see
the text size can be h3 or the font size
the button x position can be love dot
graphics
dot get with
divided by three and it'll kind of make
it a little bit in the center
and i love that graphics that gets
height and this is for the y position
and this can be
times
0.25 and it will kind of make it go
a quarter way down
okay so these are buttons we have we'll
add more a little bit later
so here we can just say
draw as a function is equal to function
taken self
for
and then underscore
button
in
buttons so for every button we want to
draw it
we just call
button colon
draw
cool
we have just created our menu
we'll get back to this a little bit
later
we can go all the way up to load
and now we don't want this start new
game anymore because we don't want to
start a new game as soon as we start to
or as soon as we boot it up we want to
go to the menu first so you say menu
is equal to
menu game
player so just passing these two into
the menu so the menu has to be below the
player and the game
now here in the love the mouse pressed
we can just add a global global scope
variable
we can go here else
and just say clicked
mouse is equal to true so if the mouse
has been clicked we'll use this later
but we don't have to worry about it now
let's just say it exists
then you can go down here and where it
says if game state is running we can go
all the way to the bottom
and we can go
else if
game dot
state dot menu so if it's the menu state
and you say clicked
mouse is equal to false by default
and we'll get back to this a little bit
later as well
and finally here in draw
else if
game dot state dot menu
and you say menu
colon
draw
now when we run the game we should be
able to see a button on the screen
okay it was the first attempt so
oh okay we haven't imported menu yet
that makes sense so we can just go here
say
local
menu is equal to require
states dot menu
there we go
there we go so we have our first button
it just looks like text because the
button color itself isn't a different
color
we could if we wanted to change the
button color
to be something different so here is our
menu
where we set the button color
which would be this one
we can go
r is equal to
g is equal to
one
and in blue is equal to zero
now this
should
give us a yellow button
so there's the button i just made it the
same color as the background to kind of
made it more mystic so you know so it
kind of looks like there is no button
but there is actually a button let me
just say nil back here again
and we have just created our first
button
now let's draw our cursor or mouse
because we go here we can't really see
our mouse
so you can just go
if
not
and in game
dot
state
dot running and we're not putting this
inside of this menu checked state here
we're putting it inside of a not game
state running
the reason for it is
because
we sometimes you want to see the cursor
even if the game state isn't necessary
running for example on the game over
screen we might want to see the cursor
in the
settings screen that's maybe another
state depending on how you code the game
you want to still see the cursor
in the paused state you still want to
see the cursor so it depends on what you
want to do here here we're just saying
if it's a running state remove the
cursor because we already have the
player on the screen we don't want the
cursor as an extra annoyance
and we can just say love.graphics.circle
and we can specify
fill
mouse x
mouse y
and a 10.
if you want an extra nice kind of
challenge you can draw the
player cursor
the same way you draw an asteroid so
then the player cursor is an asteroid
that can be pretty cool or you can make
the player cursor like the spaceship as
well but then you move it with your
mouse
it depends on what you want personally
for me this little circle here
that's all i need as you can see here so
it's a nice little circle
that just serves my cursor
now let's finish implementing the button
because it's a pretty big thing we gotta
implement but we did the biggest part so
it's not that big of a deal now
so first i would like to add a function
to make it easier to change the button
color
now i want to wait to make the button
color not only settable outside of
setting the button color
on create but to also make it easily
setable anywhere in the game so you can
say set
button
color
you can do function
we take it self read
green
blue
then here we say self dot
button color
and i'm just going to copy this because
this is quite a
thing to type out
we can go here
say that is equal to
and we just say red green and blue
respectively
there we go now it's very easy to set
the color we just say set button color
and you specify the number we don't
necessarily need to specify the rgb
anymore
next we want to do the same but for the
text color so i'm going to copy this
paste it
and i said i'm saying button color we
can say
text color
red green blue but instead of button
color we can say text color
easy
now bloated raw we can also get
or set a few methods here to get the
position of the button and the position
of the text
so get pause you could also make this
get button pause it depends on what you
want to do
but saying get button pause will kind of
work with all of these like set button
color set text colors things get button
position would be smart
pass in self and we can just return
self dot
button x
and self dot
button y
we're just separating by a comma so
we're getting two values from this
function
two of them
not just one so take note of that we can
then go
get text
pause and we can actually just copy and
paste this to be honest
so get
text pause
and instead of button x and button y
we say
text x and text y
cool we have just implemented a ton of
functions that could be useful in the
future
only two more to go
i also want the function that once we
click
the mouse like
once we click
it should
basically execute the function we have
passed in here
so down here
let me just say click
is equal to function
takes itself
and we just say func
so it will just execute the function we
have
doesn't do anything special that's all
it does it just executes that function
cool and then the last one
is just
check
hover so we're going to check if we're
hovering over the button so the cursor
is currently hovering over the button
that is equal to a function that takes
itself the mouse x position
the mouse
y position
and in the cursor
radius
then we can just do this i just paste it
in but i'll explain it so you first get
the mouse x and then plus the cursor
radius and i have explained this quite a
few times especially in the first
tutorial where we did the balls
basically if they circle where we have a
circle but we want to add the radius to
that circle in this scenario since the
button x is here we want to add a radius
to it both ways
that is why the button x here has the
plus radius and then the button x here
as the minus radius
if you haven't seen the previous
tutorial where we did build a game where
we like play around with balls
then i do recommend you go watch that
tutorial because it is quite a good
intro to this tutorial as well so i
don't have to re-explain this right here
because that just does everything the
same as what we did with our player back
then so we just check if the mouse x and
y
is above a button x
or and y
if it is we return true so here's the x
and then here is the y checking if it is
we return true otherwise we just return
false
cool and that is all there is for the
button
next is the menu let's finish up here
so let's go here and create a bunch of
functions we might want to do so
local funks is equal to a table
first we have our new game so this is
when they click the new game button that
is equal to a function
and this function just goes game
colon
start new game
and we pass in the player and that is
why we need the player and the game
passed in
we also want a quit game function so if
they click the quit button which we'll
put in a second so quit game is equal to
another function
and then love dot graphics dot
crap exactly event
my bad dot quit
and this will quit the game for us once
we click the button
cool
now we have our two functions we want to
use
this button here i'm going to copy and
paste it three times
first here with this nil i'm going to
pass in funcs
dot
new game
take note however i'm not passing in
brackets i'm not doing that i'm just
passing in the name
no brackets take note of that
and here at the bottom one you can just
say
funks
funks dot
and then quit game yet again no brackets
okay then with this button here
we can change the text here to settings
for the settings button
and since all of the buttons will be
positioned below each other
the x-axis so this git
width part right here can stay the same
but since they're pushed below each
other we can change this right here to
0.4 and that will mean that that will
make this button here
a tiny bit more below
this button right here which is the new
game button
and in here of course we can say instead
of new game we can just say
quit
and instead of 0.25 we can say 5 5.
nice so we have just created our buttons
and the functions that go with them
now let's see if they get drawn
and there we go
new game settings quit
now we need to do a few checks so once
we like hover over a button we wanted to
change color to red
and if we click a button we want to
execute a specific function
so let's go down here and first we can
say focused
that will be in empty string
and then we can create a function called
run
and this function
just takes itself and if we have clicked
we're gonna get the local position of
the mouse so mouse x and mouse
y
which is equal to love dot
mouse
dot
get position
as we return both the x and y position
and then we can go for
name
and
button in
buttons so the buttons we have here
meaning check
if
button
and then check hover which we have just
implemented
you can pass in the mouse
x and then the mouse
y if you wanted to you could have just
made this mouse x y already implemented
inside the chair cover but here i just
pass it in because why not
and we can pass in 10 and this will be
the cursor radius we have i recommend
you make this a variable instead that's
maybe global or passed in or something
like that because if you ever want to
change the radius of the cursor then you
have to come back here and change it as
well so i recommend you make it like a
variable and maybe pass it in here
or something like that anyhow so if
the cursor is hovering above the button
we can just say
if clicked
and we get clicked passed in here
then button
colon click so we want to execute the
button function we have
and it's
itself.focused and this is
basically if the button was not clicked
in a sense but it's not inside of an
else
is equal to name
or we make it equal to name and you go
button
and then set text color
to 0.8
0.8
0.2 and it should also be 0.2
as we'll give it a nice reddish color
when we hover over it
else we want to say
button set
text color
1-1-1
currently this focused we are not using
it we'll use it a little bit later but
it is there for once we want to use it
cool the menu has now been coded
but we are never executing this run yet
so we need to go and execute this run
now it is pretty simple we can just go
here to main.lua
here we say mouse clicked is false
we can just say
menu colon run
and then mouse clicked
or click mouse
there we go
and just like that we have implemented
the menu that was like the last line of
code
however we hover over we were not
getting anything yet so something might
still be wrong
however the buttons work so if you go
here click quit it works if you go here
you say
new game it starts a new game so the
buttons work
however the color is not changing yet
and right here
where we have this love graphic set
color this should actually be
self dot
text
component
colon set color
which if we were to go to the text
component here it has a function
called
set color where it sits the color for us
as well
so it has its own color function
we're going to take this what we have
here
and we can paste it in here
that is why it didn't go the color we
wanted it to go to
now we have our button colors as well if
we click on settings that will do
nothing but just print out some text
if we click quit that will quit the game
and then finally if we stay new game it
will start a new game where we can crash
and we can shoot
and what not
all right that was a pretty big tutorial
well done if you sat through the whole
thing
so in this tutorial i'll be telling you
all how to install lua rocks on windows
now as far as i know there are three
ways you can install lua rocks on
windows
the first way you can do it is by
getting the executable the dot exe file
downloading it and then just using that
however
it doesn't work for me so i'm assuming
it also doesn't work for a lot of you
another option is is to compile it from
a source meaning you have to take the
source code for lua rocks and you have
to compile it yourself which i don't
want to do and i doubt that anyone else
would want to do
now the third option
is to use windows subsystem for linux
so this is basically where you have a
type of linux on your computer
and i'll be showing you how to not
uninstall or set up windows subsystem
for linux i'll show you how to
work with everything you need to do in
order to
install everything you need to use for
lua rocks
now to make sure we know how it works i
created an example
which we can use if our full screen this
so here we have a main.lua and this file
sits here
right here so there's main.lua and
there's text
json which is these are my documents
now here we just read the file
as you can see here just in the
dashboard we read a file
and then we take that file which has
json inside of it you don't need to know
what json is you can just copy and paste
this into your own text.json file
anyhow then we decode it into a lua
table so we take the json and we convert
it into a lua table
and then we access the content inside of
it and we're doing all of this using the
lunar json module which we installed
through lua rocks
so let me give you a walkthrough on how
to set everything up
first you need to enable windows
subsystem for linux or wsl
you can just say
turn
windows features on or off
if you click on that you should be
prompted with something such as this
just scroll all the way down until you
see this windows subsystem for linux if
it is not checked then check it so mine
is currently checked because it is
already turned on so you need to check
yours if it's not already turned on
then you can say okay and it will
install it for you this will take a few
minutes so just give it some time
after it has installed it you want to
reboot your system so it can complete
the installation you want to go
power and then restart it's going to say
it's updating but all it's actually
doing is installing windows subsystem
for linux
now once your system has rebooted you
need to install ubuntu
luckily you can just go to the microsoft
store so microsoft store
right here microsoft store
and in here you can just search for
ubuntu i've already searched for it ah
there it's gone
two like that
and then you can just scroll down until
you see ubuntu
18.04 lts you can click on that
and here it will say get you just click
on get and it will download and install
ubuntu for you
once this has been completed
you can just scroll down here and you'll
notice this right here so this is the
command you use to start this ubuntu
system
now i'm going to copy that so ctrl c
and then we want to open up either the
powershell or command prompt so either
command prompt or powershell i'm going
to use command prompt so i can look cool
open that up
now to make sure you look like a real
hacker you have to say color
o2
there we go
now what you can do is you can start up
your windows subsystem for linux by
right clicking right clicking will paste
whatever you have
inside of your clipboard in this case i
copied this so it pasted this
and this will start up ubuntu for me
now if it's your first time starting up
ubuntu with the windows subsystem for
linux
then you'll have to enter a username and
password
this can be anything you want just keep
it simple so you never forget it then
once you're here it's pretty simple
first you want to sudo
apt
update
like that
press enter it will ask you for your
password you say you put in your
password and it will commence to get all
of the latest packages it has
then you want to say sudo
apt update and this will update your
linux system you have
now i just did an update so i don't have
anything to update but it will prompt
you yes or no to update all of your
packages just say yes once you've said
yes it will update your linux system to
its latest version
now that you have this you want to
install lua and lua rocks
so you can just say
sudo apt
and just for in case you don't know you
can also say apt cache
search and this will search the
repositories for what you need in this
case if i say lua 5
then here refers that everything i can
download now you can choose between lua
5.1 5.2
5.3 and basically 5.0
i want to get lua 5.3
so i'm going to say
sudo apt
install lua 5.3
and i also want to install lua rocks
i can just say lua rocks
once you do this it will ask you to
install it you just say yes i already
have it installed so it's not going to
do anything
now once you have this installed you can
start executing your code
so make sure
that right here
you have this code and this json file
make sure you have these
because this is the example we're going
to use
now currently i am not inside of my
windows machine i'm inside of linux
so to get into my windows machine i can
go cd and then a forward slash
not a backward slash but a forward slash
this will take me to my root directory
if i say alice it will show me all of
the folders i have inside of this folder
you can just go into
cdmt for mount
and in here you'll see all your drives
you have
so i have the c drive and the v drive
to show you an example of this if i open
up my file manager
go to this pc
then this is my c drive as you can see
there's c and here's the d drive
now the c drive
we can go here and as you see there's
the c drive to go into that c drive we
can say cd
c
and then a forward slash
now we want to go into users
and then here we can just say cd
users
and take note i'm using a capital case u
here because this users also has a
capital case u
then here is cherise the brain you can
go into that that is my current user i
am who i am
then here we can also go
cherise the brain
then here to find where my things are
yours might be instead of documents
inside of desktop instead of downloads
instead of music wherever you put your
files you have to go mine is inside of
onedrive
so here i also have to go into onedrive
onedrive and you can press tab to let it
autocomplete for you
and in here you'll notice we have a
document folder
if i go into documents
then you'll see i have a lua folder
and this is where my lua stuff are
now i can just go here and see
cd documents and then lua
and press enter now if i say al is i
should see a main.lua
and a text.json so right here main.lua
and text.json
now once you are inside of here you'll
see these two here
to run this lua code you can just say
lua 5.3
and then main.lua if i run this i get
jack and that means i executed the code
inside of this main.lua
to see what inside the file i can say
cat which means read and in main.lua and
you'll notice it's everything i just had
inside of vs code luna json requires
luna json
and in all of this now one thing i did
forget to tell you is how to install
luna json because i've showed you how to
install lua rocks
to install luna json you can just say
sudo
lua rocks
install
luna json
and let me just resize it a bit so
everything's on screen
oh so here we go sudo lua rocks install
luna json and this is how you install
any package in lua rocks you just say
sudo
lua rocks install luna json
you press enter
and there we go so now it should be
installed and now of course if you try
and run it
it will run your things
to uninstall a package from lua rocks
you can say sudo
lua rocks
it should be remove
luna json and this will uninstall a
package now if i were to try and run
this code
it will tell me it doesn't know what
luna json is because i have uninstalled
it
and then yet again to install it again i
can just say sudo sudo lua rocks install
luna json and just like that
you can use lua rocks now take note
whenever you want to run something you
now have to run it inside of your
windows subsystem for linux meaning this
right here you cannot run it from
windows not as far as i know at least
because luna json and lua rocks are both
installed on linux now and not on
windows
this is to me is the easiest method
around this lua rocks installation issue
we're having
today we will be
implementing the user score system
then
say in starting a game you'll see we
have now
two score systems there at the top
once we blow up an asteroid with the
score increases
go here we blow up the asteroid
increases and in here we no longer exist
so you just boom
and let me just
boom go
now when we go back in i think the score
is no longer there we'll implement that
later but the idea is once we have the
score implemented the score should stay
as it is
and then we will have a high score and a
current score
the high score will be implemented in a
different video it's not that complex so
we'll probably do it near the end
cool
and just as a comparison this is what we
currently have
move this up here
we say new game
as you can see we don't currently have
any score to speak of
which is unfortunate
so that's why we'll be implementing it
right now because that's one of the
things that really makes a player more
happy to see is if they play a game like
this and they have a score and they try
and beat their score every time they
play the game
now
let's go to our
globals.lua
now i'm going to assume you have lua
rocks installed
if you do not have lurox installed i
believe you can just google
lua rocks
and there we go and then you can install
lua rocks lua rocks allows you to
basically just install extra packages or
extra files for you to use in your
program so let's say you want to
work with mysql which is something you
use to work with databases then you can
go to lularocks and you can download
this mysql package and now you can work
with mysql
in lua or if you want to make a chat
then you can get this lua socket
which allows you to basically chat or
create a chat app
i'm going to assume we have this already
installed
and if you don't you can just quickly go
and install just pause the video go and
install it it would be probably as
simple as it was to install luba if not
easier
now if you have it installed
make sure that you have the following in
your path you need to have lua rocks in
your path so this should also be in the
installation if it isn't you just have
to implement or add it
you say dollar then in brackets
lua
rocks
path
dash bin
and this will allow lua rocks to work
and you have to add eval
here at the front before this so if we
just copy this
then you have to go eval
and every time you want to use lurox you
have to do this what you can do is you
can say
you can go into your bash rc
and this runs every time you start up
your terminal
and let me just run that again
now if we go down here
and actually it's at the way bottoms let
me just
on
full screen that
so here we go there
so this is inside of my
bash or c file which runs every time my
terminal starts up so every time a
terminal starts up we make sure i can
use lua rock so i recommend you do the
same if you're on linux
now once you've done that lua rocks
should work
now to install what we want to install
we need to type lua rocks
install
and then
luna
json
this package will allow us to work with
because i want us to save our file
in json format and you don't need to
know json i'll explain it along the way
a lot of people would actually prefer if
you were to encrypt the save file but
i'm not going to go through all that
effort it's such a basic game that could
be something you do on your own but you
might want to encrypt the save file so a
player can't spoof how much they really
got for example let's say they really
only got
5 000 points in the game
then you might want to
encrypt the files so they can't just go
into the json file and change that five
thousand to fifty thousand
but that's out of the scope for this
tutorial so we can just say install
and let's see here and i do not have
write permissions
i'm just going to go sudo
and then try it again
you might want to use dash locally if
you have the same problem i'm just going
to go sudo just to keep things simple
now once you have this installed
you should be good to go
now let's go up here and we say local
luna json is equal to require
luna
json
and we can use it just like with love
because we've installed it
so now we have this option here to use
now we can create a function and this
function will be called read json it
will read a json file for us
and in here we can just pass in the file
name because we might have multiple json
files we want to read so this is just
for future proofing
you don't have to necessarily add a file
name here but just in case you add
another file that you wanted to read
then it easily reads that file for you
now i recommend having all our files
inside of a specific
folder
so right here we can create a new folder
and we can call it src for source
content this can be like your audio
and
your files and your images
and whatnot
in this case we can just say
data that should be a folder data folder
inside of the source folder because this
is where all our data files would go
preferably encrypt your data files
because this is usually things users
should not be tweaking
and then here we can just say
dot json because this will keep the save
file or the saved data
and then all we have to do is we have to
use these curly brackets
and then we just have to say
hi
score
like that or if you want you can also
use an underscore like that but
preferably don't use a space that's not
very good so use an underscore or a
capsule case
but not a space
and you can just say zero and this will
be the score the user has
save that and you don't have to open
this file for now for a long time
cool
now that we have that file
we can specify
the file we want to read so the file we
need to open
so local file is equal to io for input
output dot open
and we pass in the file path so you can
say src
so that would be this src file or folder
then you want to go into the data folder
so slash data
and then slash because you want to
access this save dot json
again then just go dot dot file name
and in dot dot because
you might not want all of your files to
be in dot json format you might have
multiple formats
dot json
now this is just how the javascript but
because this is saying read json
you can just as well
not add this here and just let them
enter json
but because i just want to enter the
file name for example
save i just say that then it will
automatically add this.json
for me as you can see here
the end result will then look something
like this
and all i had to do was end and just
save here and it will produce this
and then of course here we just have to
specify we want to open it up in read
mode
below that we can say local data is then
equal to file
colon read and we can just say we want
to read everything so
star and then all this will read
everything inside of this file
and we can say file code and close
because we don't want the file to stay
open
and in return
luna json
dot decode
and we can just say data
now once you've done this everything
should be
still working fine if you want to test
it you can still run your code of love
dot and make sure everything starts up
which it should
cool
now next up we can go to this game.lua
file because we now want to add the high
score to the game because we can now
read this json file we have
but
we want to have it
display the score here
now this json.d code here before i
forget basically just converts json so
this right here to a lua object so lua
table
now down here we can say score by
default is zero
so by default when you start the game
you get zero as the score this is the
initial score for the
game now here at the top we also want to
import save
data
because now we want to read this file
that is json file then we want to pass
in the save data into this game here
if you want to you could
load the high score and all the safe
stuff inside of this game here but for
me it's better to rather do it outside
of the game
just to keep things simple so if you
might have different functions you want
to pass the same data in you don't have
to make multiple functions in each one
of those you can just pass it in here
but we'll get to that a little bit later
you can say high score
is then equal to save data dot high
score and this here is just a table it's
just going to contain a high score for a
moment
if there's nothing there we want to say
or zeros it will default to zero
next we want to go but down here to
where it says draw because you want to
update the draw
then go up here and say local opacity
is equal to one
then if
faded
then here we just want to set the
opacity to 0.5 and i can just work off
of the opacity so we don't need this if
statement here anymore
we're going to just unintent this
actually this can still be inside of
faded why not
because this should only be displayed if
we're currently faded because only if
we're faded we're being paused that's
the only time currently the game is ever
being faded out so this can still stay
in an if statement i don't think about
it and because this should be above
everything else it should be at the
bottom of this drawer if it's at the top
everything else is going to be above it
so it should be at the bottom
we're going to go text to create new
text we want to display
and you can just say colon draw
then this text we want to say
score
and this will be the default scored
player c like when they start up a new
game
coil in space and then add the self dot
score
then you can position it
negative 20
and
our living as position i can't actually
remember what is everything inside this
text here what are we doing okay so
first
oh yeah so that is positioning for x in
the y position cool okay then the font
size that will be an h4
we can say false
and false and the false and false is
just for this fade in and fade out
because we didn't want it to fade in or
out
then you want to wrap with the line and
the opacity
so the wrap width will be the width of
the window so loud.graphics.getwith
and you can say
right
and then
faded
and opacity
or
0.6
this is a little bit weird but basically
if it's faded
then show the opacity we have
otherwise just default to 0.6
and i believe you can actually go here
into the lua virtual environment and
just test it out
so let's say we have x which is equal to
true
and we have
1 which is equal to
let's say 0.5
and then
which doesn't exist
so you can just say 2 is equal to nil
now if
x
and
or
we get 0.5 because 2 does not exist
but if we were to say 2 is equal to 1
then we get 1. so if x is true which in
this case if faded is true
and this right here has a value inside
of it
then display this one here so opacity
otherwise if this has no value inside of
it
and this is false
then display this
so that's for that now we can copy this
and we can do the same for high score so
here is a high
score
and now here instead of dot score we can
say dot high
underscore score
we can then make this zero
yet again 10 because it's going to be
the same height you can make it h5
because this shouldn't be the main
attraction the main attraction should be
your score so it's going to be a little
bit smaller before we go that right
should be a center
and we can also change the 0.6 to 0.5
cool and that should draw it
so let's just
save
and then let's run it and see if it
works
because that should theoretically draw
it
ah here we go
attempt to index local save underscore
data nil value
you know why it's giving us that
it's giving us that because inside of
the main.lua
if we go up here we are not passing a
value in here
so we don't have a high score i'm just
going to say zero for now and let's run
it and see what we get
now we still get a value or still
problem
and my bad this should be a table
high score there we go
and that should be an equal symbol there
we go
now it should finally work
new game
now we have a high score which a little
bit faded out because remember the main
attraction is actually the player
and the asteroids and the score is also
a little bit faded but it's bigger
because you might want to see your score
more than what you see your high score
all right
now one thing before we continue this
right here quite unnecessary because
all we need to do is we just need to
get the data from globals and we are
already acquiring globals
so we need to do is let's say
it can be maybe like the second thing it
does
local save underscore data is equal to
and we're going to say read json
and then
save because we want to read this file
and you can just take this save data and
pass it in here
or if you really want to save space you
can just do whoops my bad you just do
that but i like doing this just to make
more readable
now let's make sure that works because
that should read the file for us
and then once it has read the file we
should see that value so let's
go up here and just run it
okay high score is zero let's keep a
look out for that if we change the high
score to
900 what do we get do we get the same
output or did it change because it
should be changing
new game and there we go now we get 900
so we have successfully created a save
file and read from that save file
then last but definitely not least we
now have to modify the asteroids a
little bit
because when you blow up an asteroid
your score should increase
so let's go right here
and we can say
if
self dot radius is more or equal to
asteroid size
then so the radius is more equal to the
basic asteroid size
of course that's a little bit big so we
want to go divided by two because
asteroid sizes from left to right whilst
radius is halfway
then
game dot score
is then equal to itself so game dot
score
plus 20 and game now has a score on it
if you go here you can see there's the
score
plus 20.
we can then go else if
and we can go self dot radius
is less or equal to
the min
asteroid
size
then we can do the same thing as this
but because this asteroid will
theoretically be the smallest asteroid
you can get we want to make them get a
lot of points for destroying the small
asteroids because they can be difficult
to shoot and they multiply so they can
also be very difficult to dodge at the
same time
and finally for the medium-sized
asteroids we have we can just say else
copy this and instead of 100 we can say
50.
and then this isn't something that's
going to really affect us too much now
but we can also go if game dot score is
more than game dot
high score
then we want to say game dot high score
is equal to game dot score
now this right here is basically
whenever the player plays and their
score is higher than the high score they
have then the high score will also
increase
along with their normal score can't you
tell them hey you are getting a new high
score good job
and this here will of course just add a
score and we're already drawing the
score to the screen so we don't have to
worry too much about that
we're gonna just say love dot to run it
move it so everyone can see
start new game
shoot you'll notice both of these the
high score and the score
increases
because the score is higher than the
high score and of course the more we
destroy
the more
we gain
now take note of this last part we added
here if we make the high score
let's say 100
then if we go back here
we say start new game
and we shoot an asteroid
as you can see the high score didn't
change but the score did
and the high score won't change until
our score is higher than the high score
then you can see the high score is
starting to change
cool
and that is implementing a basic save or
score system for our game
so to give you an idea of what we'll be
doing
here we go we say start new game
just wait for that asteroid to come back
and then one last time for our last
help right here at the top our last life
we crash
oh gosh missed it completely
and then we get a nice fading game over
screen
and
it fades out
and after it fades out we get new game
so first of all i would like us to go to
this menu file right here or not menu i
meant to say main
and here at the bottom
where we say game dot state of menu and
game dot state are running and paused
what not we want to add one more else if
we want to go
else if
game dot state
dot ended so the game state has
ended then you just say
game
couldn't draw
because it has to now draw the game in
that state but game will already know
what state it is
cool
now currently this wouldn't really do
much if we were to run the game we
currently have
and we were to test it out
here we go
oh gosh i missed it
ah this one has a bad
collision
then as you can see we just get a dark
screen we don't really go anywhere
nothing's happening because the game
overstate doesn't really have anything
to draw yet
so let's actually add that we can open
up our game state
and we can start here at the top
underneath high school we can add screen
text
and a screen text is just a table that
will display the text on the screen
once we
go to game in that state this will
remove it and that and whatnot
then we need to add a another variable
here saying game
over
showing and this is for the animation so
we know when the game over is showing
and when it is not showing so you know
when to switch from showing the game
over state screen to showing the menu
state screen
so that can be false by default
next year in change game state
we can go if
self dot state dot ended so if the state
has ended
then we can call the self
game over function
now this game over function is what
we're going to create now
basically it's going to do all the game
over stuff for us
so let's go here
and say game over
that's a function which takes itself
and first we can set up the screen text
that it takes that should be on the
screen
so self dot
screen text
is equal to a text component
which contains the game overtakes which
will fade in and out you could also
maybe do the same and then also display
the high score and the player score also
fading in and fading out
or what not something along those lines
that could also be a very smart idea
however we're going to keep it simple
and just do the game over screen just
game over and then poof done
we can say zero
love dot graphics dot get height
times it by 0.4 to kind of get it in the
middle in the center because you
remember
how fonts are used
it's not necessarily starting in the
middle of the font as well it starts
here at the top so every letter has a
top point and it starts there instead of
in the middle so you just take note of
that
it can be size of h1 because it should
basically take all of the attention it's
the most important and say true true
love dot graphics and then get
get with
and then center
now if you're wondering what any of this
means you can always just go back to
this text file right here and just look
at what all of these mean
you'll notice or fade in and fade out
right here is now set to true nothing
else is basically set like this so the
first time we'll be really using this
fade in and out functionality
then after we have done that we can just
say self dot
game over
showing and we can make it equal to true
because it's currently showing the game
over
if it's not showing the game over and
the game state
is ended
then we should know that we want to
switch from game state ended to game
state menu
because it's not showing game over
screen
and the state has ended so there's no
point in showing it anymore
now currently this won't do too much
then right here instead of the main.lua
we can just reduce the amount of lives
the player currently has
so player and it takes the lives so num
lives and you just make that one
now if we run it we should be able to
see our output
that should work we say start new game
we uninstall live.exe
and boom that is all we get so not
really anything just yet
so let's go down here
because currently i didn't really think
about it but this doesn't really draw to
the screen so we put the text there but
we never actually drew the text
so this could do that instead of this
draw function and let's go right
underneath faded
we can then say
for
index
text
in pairs
self.screen text
and we can say if
self
dot game over showing
then
and now here we want to draw all of the
things while the game over is showing
so self dot game over showing
is then equal to text
colon draw
self dot screen text so it's going to
draw the text that should be on the
screen
and then we can just say index
if you're wondering what's going on here
we can go here to text
if we go to draw we take in the table
text and then it's current index
you'll notice return true or false
that's how we know if we're supposed to
show it or not if it returns false it's
not currently drawing anything to the
screen
if it returns true it is drawing
something to the screen
and if you plan on adding more things
here you just modified as a teeny bit
so it can be
able to do this more dynamically because
currently it's good for one thing but if
you have two or three things it's not
going to be that great
anyhow
then you can say if
not self.game over showing
then so the game over is not showing
then self
coded
change game state and we're going to
change it back to the menu state
and then otherwise is the game overstate
isn't showing
then you can just say
else
text
draw
self dot screen text
and an index so this will basically
start it off it will start to draw
so yeah that is about that which we'll
need i don't think we'll need any more
let's try and run this and see what we
get
if we just drag this here so everyone
can see start new game
and end
then we start getting a fading out game
over screen
thanks to everything we have already
implemented and why did so much work at
the start of the game
we didn't have to do a lot now because
we've already implemented fading in and
fading out
and that is for the game over screen and
love 2d
so in this tutorial we'll be
implementing
new levels as well as making the player
invincible
now after this tutorial the game is
going to be a little bit broken but we
will be fixing that in upcoming
tutorials so don't worry too much about
that
now to give an example of what we'll be
working with if i or what we'll have by
the end of the day
i just move this here
now when we start a new game
you'll notice the player blinks and if i
try and
go into this asteroid here nothing
happens that is because of our new
invincibility we added so when we start
a new game or when we were in the player
dies then they finally become invincible
and they cannot be hurt for another
while
and this is very useful because let's
say you have
20 asteroids on the screen it can be
very difficult to avoid them immediately
once you respawn
so if you're invincible for a few
seconds not only does that give you some
time to clean up the screen and also
make sure that you just don't
immediately die once you respawn
now to make sure that this works if we
crash in here we'll actually explode
then now we can try and crash into
things again and we won't
as for new levels we can just shoot
these asteroids
and
i'll show you all the new levels
and one more right here right here
there we go so now we have level two and
there are now two asteroids on level
three there will be three asteroids
level four four asteroids and so on
but it becomes more challenging because
each asteroid explodes into multiple
more asteroids
so it will become more challenging
depending on how everything goes
now a bug you might encounter here
is let's say you die at level two here
so you gave me a second
let me
there we go if i crash against something
it tells me it's game over
but once this game over screen leaves
and we want to start a new game
then you'll notice
we're kind of still in the middle of the
game but not the same game it's it's
kind of weird
now this is normal we are going to fix
this in fact if you want to you can try
and fix this yourself before the next
tutorial but it's just normal because
we're going to play around with some of
the code and it's going to cause this to
happen
okay so let's try and implement that
let's go to our state and open up our
game state
and let's see here
where are we now we are now at draw okay
then here in start new game we're going
to add a few new things
so at the top we want to go
if
player dot lives
so the player lives is less or equal to
zero
they want to change the game state to
ended
so this will kind of fix a few bugs
but also make sure we don't just start a
new game because every time we
level up we basically start a new game
so if their lives is zero or less that
means the game has been or should be
ended
so let's go here and we say
self colon and then change game state
to
ended else
if that's not the case if they still
have lives left
then their game state
should be set to running this means it
won't be going to the menu state for
example
to the paused state it will go right to
the running state
and now we can remove this one right
here because we don't need that anymore
then we want to say how many asteroids
we want to spawn
so we can say local
num
asteroids
and that can be equal to zero
and here we have our asteroids
and now let's say they do level up we
want to display the level on the screen
even if it's level one
if we run this
new game it says level one so even if
it's level one we want to display this
on the screen
we can then say self dot screen text
is equal to text
and in here we can just pass in all our
required parameters
so first the level we are in level
that should be level
with a space and then concatenate that
by adding these two dots and saying self
dot level
so getting the current level say zero
love dot graphics dot get height
and you just times that
by 0.25 so it won't be quite in the
center of the screen it will be a little
bit above the center of the screen
and we can just add a comma there
we go and say h1
for the text size
true
love.graphics.get with
and then finally we want to position it
inside into the center of the window
okay so currently we also have another
problem we have to look out for every
time we start a new level there's a
small possibility
that once we start level
the asteroid might appear on the player
so we don't want the asteroids to spawn
on top of the player we want asteroids
to spawn anywhere around the player
so to get this we want to create an
infinite loop
and this infinite loop will basically
determine
when and where everything should be
spawned
so let's go create a for loop first
and exit 4i becomes 1
and until i
is
num
asteroids
so the number of asteroids
plus self
dot level
then we want to go local and in the
asteroid exods we have here
and we want to say
local
asy for asteroid y
i do believe since we're not really
putting anything next to it next to them
we could possibly
just go like this
and it should be fine
but just for a convenience sake i'm
going to do this
and then at the end of this for loop we
want to insert into the
table just like we usually do
however this time we won't need to
specify a specific size
we can specify the asteroid size
because then we have our specific
asteroid size we want to spawn
we're going to remove this
and in between this local and this table
insert we want to create an infinite
loop that will reposition the x and the
y
until it is no longer on the player
so we can say repeat
until
and we want to repeat it until the
calculate distance
from
player
x
and player y
and you want to say the asteroid x and
asteroid y
and if that is more
than the asteroid size
times two
plus the player radius
so we're checking if the distance
between the player and the asteroid
is more than the asteroid size
times two plus the player radius so it
means if the asteroid can currently
damage the player the player was not
invincible
then you want to regenerate
this
aesx and asy
so let's just put that here
and let's just put that in there as well
so it will run at least one time
and then you will try and figure out if
it should run again
and will continuously rerun this code
until the asteroid is no longer
on the player so if the azure is no
longer on top of the player
and this isn't really required but i do
want to just go on top here
and say
require
globals
because we are now using a function
that's inside of globals but it's not
really required
okay cool so it's not really a guarantee
we're going to see this change
because we haven't really seen it in the
past so it's not really guaranteed we'll
even see it now but if we run our code
it should work and nothing should be
broken
let's go like this say start new game
okay and as you can see everything still
seems to work
but now the difference is the asteroid
will always spawn a relatively far
distance from the player so that they
have a little circle they at least have
to themselves
okay i also see here we only have one
life left
but that was for development we can
remove that later that's really required
now
next up we can open up the player so we
can add the invincibility to the player
so we're going to know how long the
player can actually be invincible
depending on how many times it has
blinked and this will also indicate that
the player is currently invincible
if i were to just show the example again
you'll notice the player blinks and at
least to me as a gamer it says hey
this player is currently invincible
nothing can really touch it
and once the blinking stops you're also
no longer invincible
so here you can see how many times you
want it to blink so local
local usable
links
and this will be the amount of blinks
you wanted in my case i only wanted to
blink ten times
but then times two we're adding two to
it because of how fast the blinking
is compared to how long the player is
going to be invincible
okay so let's go
down a bit
then let's go right above the lasers
and we can say invincible
is equal
to true so this is if the player is
currently invincible if we cannot touch
the player
let's make that invincible not even
permissible
and here we can see
invincible
scene and then we can make that true as
well
this is if the player is currently
grayed out or not so you'll notice we go
from white to grayed out from white to
grayed out this will save the players
currently grayed out
and here we can say time
blinked
and we can make that equal to the
current usable blinks
so this is the amount of times the
player can blink while immortal
cool
now let's actually
implement the
design for all this so let's go to draw
flame thrust
and let's see here
right above everything we can create an
if statement
and we can call it self
dot
invincible scene so if we currently are
in the invincible scene state
then it is a table
dot insert
into color
0.5
and that's being passed in right here so
the color
and we're just basically setting it
to 0.5 which is half its opacity
we're going to enclose this function
again and we can go to draw and this is
where most of the things are going to
happen
let's go here into the else or not the
else but the if statement here
and right underneath debugging
we can implement if the player is
currently invincible at what should
happen
so if
self dot invincible scene
then you want to say love
dot graphics
dot set color
one one one
and then faded
and opacity
or 0.5
so this will basically give us our
default faded slash opacity we want or
we'll just default to 0.5
cool and in here we can just say else
and we can copy this line paste it here
and we can just actually we can just
move this line up we don't need to copy
or paste any lines
and then we'll have this instead
next up we can close this function and
go down to maybe the move player right
here
we didn't want to take in dt
and this is the time between the last
frame and this frame for anyone who may
have forgotten this will allow us to
calculate when the player should blink
we're gonna then say if
self dot invincible
then
let me create end here
self dot time blinked
make that equal to self dot time
blinked plus
actually minus
dt
[Music]
times two
so this will first take the dt times it
by two
and then take what we have our current
time length and subtract it from there
we can then go on every uneven blank
and make the player fully visible so in
every uneven one for 1
3 five the player will be fully visible
and not grayed out
to do that we can say if
math dot seal
pass in self dot
time blinked
and then modulate by two and this is an
easy way to see
if something is an even or odd value
so in this case if something is an even
value it will be true here because two
modulo two is 0 4 modulo 2 is 0
3 modulo 2 would be one because there's
one left
you're gonna just say self
dot invisible scene
make that equal to false
otherwise we can say
self dot invisible scene and make that
to true
then we can sit the if the player is
invincible and make it false
if the time blinked has
ended so if
self.time linked
is less or equal to
zero
so if the time blinked has ended and
there's no longer
any reason to blink let me just say self
dot invincible
and make that false
otherwise if the player currently isn't
invincible we can just hit self dot
time blinked equal to usable blinks
so we're basically resetting it
and itself
dot invincible scene becomes false
that's about that for the player
and i don't believe it will be working
just yet so if we run it the players
will most likely not be thinking yes
because we even haven't passed him dt
yet
okay to pass in dt we can go to the
main.lua file
and right here where it says move player
we just pass in dt which is provided to
us
by love2d
and in here
where we say
if not
player.exploding we also want to now go
and
not
player dot
invincible because if the player is not
invincible we are allowed to calculate
the distance and make sure that the
player is or is not exploding
but if the player is invincible we don't
want to do that
cool
and let's see here
right before this elsif we can go
if the
number of asteroids
is equal to zero
so if there are no more asteroids left
we can increase the game level so
again.level
is game.label plus one so it's going to
increase by one and in game
start
new game
and we can pass in the player and that
will basically generate us not only a
new player
but
a new game
for the new level
great now we save this file
and we run it
say start new game now the play will
blink if we try and hit something
we can go straight through and you'll
see the level fade in and out
now when we destroy this asteroid
it should increase the level because
there will be no more asteroids left on
the screen
can go here and just
there we go so now it's level two and
the asteroids also spawned very far away
from us so there's no chance that once
we go up a level and azure will spawn
directly onto us
cool
let me just increase my life here so we
can make sure if the player does
end live we can respawn without a
problem
let's go here and run one
start new game
okay we can go through this asteroid
we're going to shoot up this asteroid
and go to the next level
they will let's try and go to level
three just to make sure that all
labeling systems work
thanks to how we built the game
implementing levels is fairly simple
it's auto generated so come on you can
do it come on there we go yes now
there's level three if i hit something
okay then my hitboxes aren't the best
okay now we're invincible again and we
can fly right through stuff without
getting destroyed
until we are no longer invincible where
will explode if you try and touch
something
cool
and that's the gist of it
now one thing i did want to show you but
i kind of forgot in a previous tutorial
it's kind of to show you an example of
how we created the spawn before we get
to the actual video
is if we were to go to the
i believe it would be anywhere like in
the game or something just uh we will
just spawn the amount of asteroids
yeah so here is the gnome asteroids now
when we play the game if i go
live dot and we start the game
new game then as you can see the
asteroid spawns far from us but how do
we know in the previous tutorial what we
implemented really works that the
asteroid will never spawn on top of us
well when we go
here and we change this to maybe 100
asteroids
and we run it again
new game
as you can see we have like a little
radius around us
where it wouldn't touch us
same way if we were to start a new level
it will spawn them all around us instead
of add up so if we make this 500 for
example
and then we run it
then as you can see there's a little
radius where they won't spawn on top of
us
also i believe that level 500 is
impossible
if someone plays this game and they get
to level 500
then
please show me how you defeat it because
that would be very interesting
all right so yeah that is just what i
wanted to show you just to make sure you
know that what we implemented actually
works
so first off one thing we have trouble
with is if we actually start the game
right now
and we just wait to un
immune ourselves
oh wait we can like start a new level
and whatnot
okay now here explode okay that's fine
let's continue
okay now explode again now we have one
life left and now then i can show you
what i mean
all right so now when i crash into this
asteroid
which i just missed
and it says game over now when we start
up a new game you may have remembered
this bug from a previous video
every new game then we kind of continue
flying off where we left off
so we just continue if i die here then
it's just going to spawn me back at this
exact location in the next game
therefore we should create a reset game
function
so let's go into main.lua
and right above the love.load and this
could also be in globals if you wanted
to or you can create a utils.lua file or
whatnot
but here we can say function
reset and this will just reset
everything for us
and then here we can just say end
so first we can read the save data so
local
save data
that is equal to read json
and then you just put in or
save the json or in this case just save
we don't need to specify json
underneath that we can then create our
player
and that will just spawn a new player or
create a new player object with free
lives we then go game and we can create
a new game object
save
data we just pass that in
and then create a new menu object which
is equal to menu
and you can just pass in the game
and the player
and then
destroy asteroid we can make that equal
to false
now this destroy asteroid you might have
forgotten about it but if we go to our
globals.lua
and we can actually keep this here
then you'll notice
here destroy asked
just so you know where we are coming
from and here we're just making it false
again in case you may have forgotten
where this is
then after that you basically have
created
a reset function
so what we can do now is we can remove
this
as well as this right here
i can you can just say reset
because this player game and menu
and destroy asteroid are all global
because they don't have a local in front
of them
so they can still be used once we use
this reset
so now we're going to reset the game
once we start it
and whenever we die we want to reset the
game again
to do that we can go down to where
update is
and scroll all the way down
until here where it says game.state.menu
then we have our menu run click and then
our mouse clicked which is false
then here we can check if not
reset complete
and this is a global variable
but actually we want to make it local to
this file but global in the file so we
can go up here
and we can just
say local
reset complete
and we can make that equal to
and you might want to make this
underscore complete or like this
depending on how you name it when i
scripted this video it was probably like
super late at night and here i have like
underscores and here captain camel case
you should just stay consistent but i
did this late at night so i'm not
consistent anymore
anyhow this will tell us when we want to
reset the game once we're in the menu
state
if it's true we can just call reset
and then reset
complete is true
then here we can say
else if
game dot state
dot ended so the game state is ended
we can say reset complete is equal to
false so if we do die then the reset
complete will become false
then once we go into the menu state it
will reset the game for us
all right
we can now just save and test this out
this should make sure that once we
restart the game we don't just continue
i'm going to just decrease the amount of
lives i have
because free is kind of unnecessary
so let's just make that one for now but
you could keep it free i just don't want
to wait forever to be able to
die
all right so let's see what happens i
crash
the game is over
now what should happen is i should spawn
in the middle of the screen again
so new game
middle of the screen level one only one
asteroid so we have basically
successfully reset the game
cool we can now just change the player
lives back to free
save that
next we can go to globals
now here we want to
write json so we already have read json
but now we also want to write the json
so i'm going to copy that
paste it change it from read to right
we also get the file name but then we
also need to get the data we want to
write
now we are going to get
a table and we want to convert that
table into json so we can store it
inside of our save.json because this may
look like a table but this is actually
json
okay so to make sure it works we can
also print it out to the screen if you
want to but you're anyways going to see
how it looks once we put it inside of
the save the json so you could print it
out to your screen
or you could just look how it looks in
the save dot json
okay so now we can have our local file
and we want to open it and it's going to
be the same file
but this time we want to open it in
write mode instead of read mode
then
we want to go here
and say
file dot file coden right
and the only reason i'm getting these
yellow lines is usually because you'd
want to check if this file is nil or not
first
if the file is nil you don't usually
want to try it right to it
so if you want to be safe you can first
check
if
file
is equal to nil
then
and you can just like return
or something anything here would work or
you could just do this if the file is
not nil so if it's not
nil
then you want to
do this as you can see now the yellow
lines are gone because we know file is
not nil because we checked for it first
so yeah that's just something you want
to maybe take note of i'm not going to
do that right now
but you could there's nothing wrong with
it
it's actually better practice i'm just
not going to do that right now
we can then say
luna json
dot
in code so first we used d code d code
converts
json
into a lua table
whilst in code converts a lua table into
json
then here you just pass in data which we
get here
they want to close the file and then the
function is done we don't need to return
anything
and this will write to our json
to make sure it works
we can actually just yeah that's already
serious we don't have to change that
we can now go to game because we want to
save our high score so once we boot into
the game again we have our high score
there so you go to the top
and we can create a new function called
save
game which is equal to a function
that takes in self
and it just does
write json
and in the file name which would be save
and then
the lua table in this case we want to
save the high score
and just self dot high score
and this should
save the file for us
if we get a new high score
now it won't just call itself we need to
still call this function
so here in game over for right now we
can just say
self
colon
save
game
and it will save the game for us
let's try and run this and make sure we
actually get that so we can open this
save the json so we can see what happens
we say new game current high score is
zero
but if i were to just go up here you'll
notice my high score also increases but
now we need to make sure it saves
so just give me a second and let's blow
up
now you get a game over our high score
is a thousand
okay we need to see and make sure that
that high score is what we see
if i say quit then as you can see it
updated our file
now the high score is 110.
okay
now i'm just going to decrease my hp
by going here and just saying make it
one just gonna constantly have to wait
forever in order to finish the game
now let's say we only get one score here
and as you can see our high score is 110
now
and our score is 20.
so our high score and our score are two
different things at this moment if we
crash
we get our game over screen
and we get our save.json
you'll notice our high score didn't
change along with
it that is because
our high score here never changed so as
long as this high score doesn't change
the high score we save will not change
either
that is why we could just do go here and
we didn't have to do any checks before
because we already do checks to make
sure that this high score doesn't go
over the normal score unless we get more
for example if we go here
our high score is 100
if we try and beat that high score
okay so my high score increased as well
as my score as you can see since my high
score has been surpassed so now both of
them will be increasing and once i
explode
then the high score inside of save json
is also updated
so you'll notice that the high score
only changes once the score is higher
than the high score
and that is that for today's tutorial
this will be your final love 2d tutorial
however to all of you who made it all
the way here to the very last video
well done
you have all done such a great job
getting here
and with one last step
you can finally continue on your road to
being a game developer
now before we continue because i know a
lot of you probably missed out a few
pieces of code here or might not know
what to do after you finish this you
could skip this part if you want to
because it's not that important
but
here we can just bring this
over so
all of the code is on github and this
link will be in the description so if
you miss anything you can just go here
and you'll be able to find it
all the code we have up until now
now when you go into lua and then into
love2d
you'll have the asteroids game folder
and that's what we are building
and we are at number 15. so you can get
number 14's code if you have fallen
behind or if you just want to get a few
things we'll get to in a second
once you finish this course
and you don't know what game to build
next i do have a few things i want you
to try and do on your own
and also point a few out
during the game play whilst i show you
what we're implementing what you could
also add
so here is a lot of things called
homework
and you don't have to do this but if you
do this you will learn how to build and
game on your own without my help
which is very useful because i would
always be there to hold your hand
while we code a game together
sometimes you'll have to do that on your
own
and this is where it can start
there's a lot of things you can do
create a settings page
because if we look here
we have a settings button but it doesn't
do anything so you
can implement that settings page that's
i want you to do
you can add more sound effects which
we'll be doing in this video
you can add a better design to the menu
add mobile support add items to the game
so let's say
you want to give your
player better guns
so let's say after every third asteroid
to destroy
maybe a random gun will spawn that they
can
if they
hit it then instead of exploding they
will equip the gun and then they can
shoot better lasers than what they
currently have
which could help them like once they get
to like level 500 if you have a very
powerful gun it could be an easy game
you can add more enemies because
currently it's very basic but you could
add like in the original game and ufo
that will
occasionally also jump in and maybe
shoot the player or just try and hit him
and then you should also try to destroy
that ufo
you can improve the performance because
currently it's not really
focused on performance if you have a
very powerful pc you won't even notice
it
but after this tutorial
if you have a low end pc you might
notice frame drops going until 30 fps if
not lower
and last but not least
already not yet but you can also add a
better pull screen and then last but not
least
you can add multiplayer support
this is something that can bring you
very far in the future you can go and
get yourself a lua
module the love2td module or just lua
module and you can start trying to code
your game that two people on two
different computers can try and play the
game together
it's going to be a very difficult thing
to do but if you get this right you can
make any game and you can make it
multiplayer for more people to play
together and the multiplayer game is
usually a bit more successful than a
single player games because multiplayer
games you can play with your friends
so here's a bunch of things you can do
and we'll go for a few extras in the
video as well
now in this video we'll be adding
background music and sound effects
i want you to go here to our github page
go to number 15 which is the last one
then you'll notice
here inside of source
we now have a new folder called sounds
go into sounds
and here you'll also find all the sounds
we will be using
in the tutorial
and you just open all of them
and then you'll notice there's a
download button and you can just
download them all so you click download
and did it start to download yes there
it goes it downloads
and just download all of them until you
have all of the sounds
there you go
once you have all of this let me just
move this back to a different screen
we can then open up our file manager and
here under source
we can create a new folder called sounds
and we can then go here to downloads
where our things should be and we just
copy all of the sounds we just got
and we can just throw them in here into
the sounds folder
and there you go now you might have to
rename a few of them because the names
are now incredibly long and tedious
so just go
here there we go
oh i didn't do anything
there we go okay let's just rename all
of them
all right now latest we have two types
of sounds here first we have ogg and mp3
this is just to show you can use
multiple sound types
but usually you'd find people using ogg
and mp3 and a lot of people also use wav
or wav
now i just chose ogg because i think
that's what i got when i downloaded
these here
you can also play them if you want to i
would play them but i don't think you'll
actually hear it now that i think about
it
alright so i quickly fired up a
different screen recorder so if the
quality might be a little bit low that
is just because i'm using obs instead of
my simple screen recorder as usual
now we can actually hear how this sounds
so if we actually go here and just say
open
containing folder we can hear all of
these sounds to the background music
[Music]
yeah then we have the explosion asteroid
so that's when an asteroid explodes then
when the player explodes
and of course you could change these
sounds to be something else i just went
online did a quick google search for
free music or free sounds and i just
downloaded the first one i saw so you
could definitely change this if you want
that's how laser will sound then an
option select like selecting a button
then defroster
then the thruster but louder
yeah i couldn't remember why i had both
of these but we'll try and find out
right now all right
so now we have the sounds
next up we can go to components
and create a new file
called sfx for sound effects
and like usual this will go local love
is equal to require
love
and we have our
function
sfx
which will return
a table
and you can just return
sfx
all right so first we probably want to
select the background music
so let's go up here and we say
local bgm
local
bgm is equal to
love.audio
dot new source and remember
if you're wondering about any of this
this is on the love to the documentation
so just go to love2td.org i think and
then you'll find the documentation which
explains this as well
then we should select the background
music
now we can say src
then sounds
and then bgm dot mp3
so
src
sounds
bgm dot mp3 so we just selected it
and then we want to set the mode
to
stream
stream is when you have long
audio tracks like background music for
example that's going to continuously
play for a long time
so let's say it's 30 seconds or longer
you probably want to use a stream
cool
then you want to go bgm or go to next
line
bgm
colon set volume because the volume will
be very loud but you could change this
depending on how you like it
and i'm going to set mine to 0.1 which
would be very soft
but the volume will be very loud but if
you want it louder you could make it
louder by just increasing this number
then bgm
set looping
to true and this will make sure it loops
continuously over and over so once the
background music ends after it's like 30
seconds or what not of playing it will
start playing it again
cool you might think this is annoying
but a lot of games actually do this
where just play the background music
over and over and over again and usually
people don't find it too annoying unless
the background missing itself is an
annoying tune
cool
now we want to link all of our effects
so all our sound effects
so you can go local
effects
and this will be a table just to make
things easier it doesn't have to be a
table but i'm going to make it one
i'm going to copy this line of code
just remove the local change bgm to ship
explosion
and make that equal to everything here
but we're going to change this to
this explosion
ogg
and we're going to change from stream to
static because static is better for
these shorter audio tracks like that's
five seconds long or 10 seconds long if
there's a very short and static would be
better
we can then
just add a comma here
and then copy paste it four times
there we go
then this can be asteroid instead of
ship
and then of course we just change from
explosion player to
to asteroid
keep it static what not
in this we can change to the laser and
here i'm spelling it with an s because
here i figured out you actually spell
laser with an s and not as it
so just in case you want to know but if
you want to stay consistent because if
you linked your laser of a set you could
change that to z
and then here we say laser
here we can call the select
and then
option
select
and then thruster
which will of course be thruster but
loud
so if you think the thruster is too loud
you could probably go for normal fresher
but this is just for making it a little
bit louder because i think this normal
thruster is probably a little soft
cool
now first when we play an effect we
should
have a true or false value to say if an
effect has been played
so if x for effect
and then played
we make that equal to false
because by default nothing is being
played then
set
fx
played
and this will basically just set this fx
here to true or false you don't have to
use a function for it but i'm going to
use a function for it because it's just
a bit safer
we're going to go function
self and then has
played
and then just self
dot s
or fx played
equal to has played
now we want to create a function to play
the background music
when we wanted to
so we can just go here and say play
bgm for background music that's a
function
takes itself
and we can check if not bgm
is playing
so if the background music is not being
played
then
end
so this right here just checks if the
background music is currently being
played so if it's going dedede in the
background
then bg m
play
so if it's not playing you want to start
playing the background music
cool
now we need two more functions
first one is to play the effects so if
you want to play a sound effect
and then the other one is to stop a
sound effect from playing
so let's first do stop sound effect
because that's the
easiest one you can say function takes
itself and then the effect
then if
effects
and then we want to pass in the effect
so this right here will go to these the
effects and see if we pass in like a
ship explosion string on our asteroid
explosion
and then it will try and select that one
to see
if it currently is playing
which if it is
playing then you want to stop the effect
from playing
so we can just copy this
and then say stop
as simple as that and that will stop the
background music from playing
next up is to actually play the effect
now playing the effect is a bit more
complex
because we have so many effects we can
just say play
if x
is equal to a function
that takes itself
the effect we want to play
and in the mode we want to play it in
and i'll explain this in a second
now we will have three different modes
we'll have single
and the single mode is when we only want
this effect and no other effects to play
then we have slow mode
and this will just
play the effect as normal
and then we have the else which will
just stop this effect from playing if
it's already playing
and then start playing it again
all right so let's implement that
so if
mode is equal to
single and it might sound a little bit
confusing right now but you'll
understand what i mean in a second
then if
not
self dot fx played
then so if the effect is not being
played right now
then
self colon set fx played
to true so we want to set it to true
and then if not
effects
effect
currently is playing
then
we want to go
effect
at effect
play
and this will play the effect for us
so basically this is in the sound effect
that's only allowed to be played once
that's why it's single
next up we want to do the slow mode so
else
if
mode is equal
to slow
then if
not
effects
effect so the current effect
is not being played
then
effects
effect
and then play
now usually you don't actually have to
do it like i'm doing right here it's
just i like to have a little bit of
variety in my effects they shouldn't all
just be generic
there should be like different versions
of it for example single where it's only
allowed to be played once slow where
it's allowed to be played
but we first check if it's currently
being played then we can play it again
and then finally last but not least we
will stop the effect and start playing
it again
okay that can be any other command other
than slow so else and single of course
self
stop
effects and it will stop the effects
like just like here
and you can just say effect
and then effect
at effect
and then play it
cool and that is the sound effects file
it could be much bigger
but i like to keep it a little bit
simple for right now because you might
want to expand on this later and you
don't want it to be
too complex
so let's start by going to
the main.lua file
and here in reset
we can just go
sound effect
is equal
to sound effects
to create a new sound effect
object
and of course we should import it you
can either use dot or slash notation as
you can see i use both of them here as
an example
so sfx
and we can just go to
component
dot
sfx
now when we load
the game
we want to start playing the background
music so we can just go sfx
and then
play bgm and it will start playing the
background music for us
cool and let's play our game and see
what we get
and as you can see
we get background music playing for us
now
all right
so that is for the background music
next up let's go to the menu here and
let's just pass in sound effects
for all three of these
sfx
because we're going to add sound effects
to all three of them and we just change
the player lives to free
player also has another
player object being created here so we
can just pass in sfx here again
there we go and we'll later on
change that
in the player itself
now first let's go to menu
which should be here in states
and first we can take in the sound
effect so sfx
and then here where we go to
run
when we check if the button is being
hovered on
if it is being hovered then you want to
go s f x
colon
play
or
and then fx for the sound effect
and you can say we want to play the
select
and single
all right
so it should be able to run if it's not
going to crash because of those nil
values
as you can see it kind of plays
however we need to also add another line
of code
right here instead of the else statement
so if self
got focused so the one is currently
focused on is the same
as the name
then
we can go
sfx set fx played
to false
because you'll if you could remember if
we go here to sfx
and we go to single
then here it sets it to true but here we
check if it's already false
now we are manually setting it to true
or false depending on
the context so you don't want it to play
multiple times
over the same like button so we're
saying single here and we have to reset
it to false here
if it has already been played before we
are allowed to play it again
you could remove this if you want to
it's just it does help make everything
just work fine now go
as you can see you can now
go over all of them you can do multiple
times
cool and as for the menu state
next up let's go to the game state
and all we need to do here is just where
we create this asteroid
we just also pass in sfx for sound
effect
because the asteroids will also have
sound effects for once they explode
and before we go asteroids we can go
player
which should be inside of objects and
and first we can take in
sound effects
and then first
here with the
shoot laser i believe because that's
when we want to play a shoot laser sound
effect
we can just go sfx
play
fx
and then just the laser
and since we're not passing anything in
if we go here to sfx
that means it will stop the effect if
it's currently playing and it starts
replaying it
let's run that and hope it works
as you can see now if i were to
spam the button
you'll notice it just keeps on playing
because the sound effect is so short you
don't actually hear the sound effect
getting cut in half basically
so if you spam it you're going to hear
that sound effect being cut in half
which it is currently actually doing
next up we can go back to player and
just go to move player
and in here where we say if
self.frosting so if we're currently
frosting the player forward
we want to go here and just say sfx
play fx
i'm going to say specify the
thruster
and then slow
and slow of course if we go here to slow
it will just check if the effect is
not currently being played then it will
just start playing the effect
alright
and we can do the same here
at the bottom but now we can just say if
that we're not currently thrusting
ourselves forward sfx
stop
fx
thruster
cool let's see if that
works oh
that's weird let's try it again
so at thirty we're trying to index a nil
value
so right here
okay so thruster seems to be
a nil value
also it seems we haven't taken an sfx
here in game so you can just also take
that
and let's see here
uh you know what i spelt incorrectly
there we go
now it should work
okay
all right you'll notice
every time we now frost
it makes a nice sound and it stops once
we stop pressing the w key
cool
[Music]
then last but not least we can go to
asteroids
and go to the top we can take in
sound effects
then we want to play an effect once we
destroy the asteroid so in the destroy
function
once here
when we resize and whatnot
we can just pass in the sound effects as
well because we're creating new
asteroids and then at the end
before they remove we can just say sfx
play fx and then we can just say
asteroid explodes
then if we run it and we shoot an
asteroid we should hear
and there you go
so now you hear that
every time you shoot an asteroid
and just like that we added a sound to
our game and believe it or not that
actually took me a whole day to
implement on my own
just because we did it pretty fast
doesn't necessarily mean it was very
fast
anyhow and that is the end of the love
2d crash course
thank you all for watching it was a very
fun experience doing this with all of
you
now before we go i might want to give
you a little bit extra homework if
you're up for the challenge
you might want to make this
on the background to make it look cool
have the asteroids be flying in the
background wouldn't that be cool if
you're here in the menu state and it
does that
all right and if you go to new game
you might want asteroids to explode when
they hit each other wouldn't that be
cool as well but then of course the
player score doesn't necessarily have to
increase but it could be pretty neat if
two asteroids were to hit each other and
then explode into more
asteroids and yeah that's about it
you can also try porting the game to
android which i have not really tried
but it would be a pretty difficult
challenge and if you get it right then
you can make android games for yourself
and for your friends
thank you for watching